foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
come on
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
obviously after playing in Iceland and
doing well I'm just looking forward to
the CG scene hopefully I can win this
one too all right hello Hikaru it's so
nice to have you here in Toronto are you
excited for the cgc yeah it's um I was
here a couple weeks ago in Toronto
filming some other stuff so it's good to
be back where would you personally rank
rapid chess A month's Pro chess formats
for me rapid is I would say right now is
close to my favorite or uh or it's one
of the two Raptor Blitz but definitely
not classical I also think that with
less time more blunders occur so
um that's why rapid I think is a truer
test of of your overall skill ability
Blitz will always be my favorite if
there if there's nothing on the line how
is preparing for a rapid tournament like
cgc different from preparing for large
over-the-board tournaments is there a
difference what's your process like um I
don't think it's much different
classical chess it has to be quite a bit
deeper you have to do look at many
different lines many different
possibilities and Rapid generally I
think if you have an idea and you look
at a couple of lines before the game
that's for the most part good enough I
found I was going to ask you what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week as I said I'm just
going to try to play my game and if it's
good enough it's good enough if it's not
it's not but I don't really think about
anything else I love that answer just
playing the chess that's great
[Music]
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
one million dollar prize pool
sorry I was peeking should I do it again
because I was peeking I could just stand
farther I could just not like I could
just do this to continue
I'm shouting again I feel like as a as
it goes on you guys continue
to the mic more and more oh wait for me
I feel like they might like notice a
pattern go and this is me with how my
voice too imagine if I was at full
capacity break the mic I dare you laughs
[Music]
foreign
the one Hotel Toronto has been a most
excellent host through our first two
days of competition at the cgc finals
but things are getting serious as the
field has been trimmed to our final four
and these players position themselves
for the two hundred thousand dollar
first place prize it's the semi-finals
of the chess.com Global championship and
it starts right now
yes I was born in Vancouver crazy but as
fond as I am of that place it's pretty
tough not to fall in love with the city
of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess in clubs in
universities and public parks and even
in hot tubs with amaranth for well over
a century yeah I don't think that's what
the script said
you're right
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks four of the
world's best players have survived to
continue their quest for the Queen's
sized ship of the one million dollar
prize pool
that ends it officially I think that's
it resigns oh my goodness what an
Armageddon we just had
my life you're in the right place it's
time for the cgc finals Toronto Canada
officially has it all
thank you again Andrea Toronto has been
super friendly to us as has the one
hotel in downtown we are pushing to our
two semi-finals matchups which features
some popular players and should lead to
some very exciting chess
and we welcome you once again inside the
gameplay Hall at one hotel I am
International Master Danny wrench
alongside Grand Master Iman Hamilton
feed a master James Canty and Grand
Master Dania narodiski there on the end
we will also be joined soon by none
other than Fabiano caruana that's right
you've seen the pics on social media as
he calls today's matches with Robert
Hess all right guys today we begin one
of the cgc semi-final the first day of
the cgc semifinal so let's take a look
at the bracket and get everyone up to
speed on how we got here in the top half
we saw both Americans moving on Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so were both
dominant neither of those matches were
ever really in doubt guys they both
played well we'll talk about how we
think they're going to play in a little
bit but let's move on and remind you
that Anish giri and nihil Soren are
joining them in the semi-final
both of those guys had very different
roads right Naka and so were dominant
Anish Geary had to win an Armageddon
nihal Soren had to complete a comeback
to get there
the semi-final matchups today
we'll start off with Geary and Sauron
and Nakamura and so not long after that
whoever wins the semi-finals of course
will be joining us for Championship
Sunday and Monday we will Crown our
champion on Monday and boy are we going
to have fun this weekend all right guys
before we turn to today's matchup dive
into all the action and make our
predictions let's talk about some
thoughts on how these four players got
here Amon I'm going to start with you
Hikaru Nakamura right many people's
favor to win it all how impressed have
you been what are you thinking about
hikaru's Forum right now in Toronto Well
it can't be understated Hikaru is in
general in great form not just here
Danny but leading up to this event it
started out with more of the same right
all wins on day one but I don't think
you can just gloss over that almost
comeback that we saw from JKD yeah so I
think that Hikaru has to clean some
things up it hasn't been perfect but
it's definitely been more the same yeah
and there's a cliche that that is always
repeated in these situations which I'm
going to repeat again because all I do
is basically repeat cliches which is
that players in great form in any sport
make it look easy like Michael Jordan
makes it look easy when he just gets
open for a 15-foot jumper same with
Steph Curry have to throw in a Steph
Curry reference every day Hikaru is
making it look easy it's like he's
always better out of the opening he's
always converting smoothly in Middle
games he's he's doing things that are
objectively really hard and making them
look easy he's just swimming in the
waves of success and I think we'll see
it carry over in the next round but he's
up against the very very formidable
Challenger of course as in Warriors of
me of course the car was a bad boy we'll
talk about them this season too let's
not talk about the words of course yeah
but of course speaking of Bad Boys uh
like the Pistons Hikaru is actually you
know half a man right as we say you know
so of course he got he had some hiccups
right with the two games he got hit I
can bleed a little bit oh I heard a
little bit but now he's back in good
form I think he's just going cruise and
I agree with him on his form overall
right now is kind of undeniably maybe
playing some of the best chess in the
world but maybe I cursed him a little
bit when I said that the commentators
first because he did stumble against JKD
a little bit we'll see if he cleans up
some of the details against Wesley so
but speaking of so that's a guy who once
he cleaned up that minor detail of
missing Maiden 2 in game one against on
Drake and it's been smooth sailing ever
since yeah that's a great point I know
we we heard it earlier from what Canty
was saying about bleeding a little bit I
think Wesley got that out of the way the
earliest that you could in a tournament
like this right we had that scare in
game one for Wesley he missed the mate
himself it was shaky he should have lost
that game Danny but since then you know
he finished that match with a dominant
score so it's like that never happened
and Wesley's form now looks tremendous
yeah absolutely yeah so is looking good
so uh definitely after that first hiccup
he had and then he was able to bounce
back with with uh with some wins and
able to pick up the uh the match um I
think he's going to face he coverage
today it's going to be difficult he got
a lot of stuff for him to do today but I
think uh in the end he'll be all right
yeah I'll be honest and I managed to
sneak in a blitz match with Wesley after
the commentary I promised I wasn't
playing from my phone while commentating
but Wesley getting in some warm-up and I
can attest to the fact that Wesley is in
phenomenal form he was seeing tactics he
was playing quickly Robert made a point
yesterday that I want to Echo his time
management has been phenomenal and
yesterday in the blitz match I mean he
was he was making moves so quickly he
was playing well in time scrambles yeah
I you know I'm not the greatest judge of
weaknesses because Wesley is in a
different universe but I'm looking
forward to this match so much Danny
because both I mean it cannot be stated
enough both players are in phenomenal
form and we always get the most
entertaining matches in in that scenario
you mentioned he was engine like too
right yeah I mean he was so precise in
tactical positions you could just feel
the confidence yeah well we've been
talking a lot about their form making
the sports references but they say the
great ones get it done even if they're
not in perfect form so we'll see who can
find themselves as the road gets bumpy
for knocking so but all right let's talk
about Anish giri and nihil Sauron next
but starting with a niche that's a guy
who has been in pretty good form he
stumbled blew a two-game lead But
ultimately got it done in a very well
played Army again game your thoughts on
the Dutchman's performance so far well
Danny I think that's what top players do
they get it done they find a way to get
it done and Geary did so I would say
without too many blemishes but the one
that stands out is you know when he lost
a full piece in a game that should have
been a draw in a game that should have
you know been close to wrapping up that
match that caused things to go to the
Armageddon and although that was a
pretty serious moment the fact that he
was able to have a serious blender like
that and then bounce back and just win
the Armageddon fairly convincingly I
think speaks volumes about Geary and his
recovery yeah I agree with them on and I
would Echo that by saying he had a day
to analyze debrief and the greatest
players not only display results even
when they don't have the greatest form
but they make adjustments during the
tournament during the game I think we're
going to see adjustments from a niche
and he's going to be hungry to get into
the finals let me tell you some Geary
does not get weary okay
very solid right very solid play of
course he's gonna do what he has to do I
mean siren is going to swing at him and
I think he's going to be able to block
you know Muhammad Ali style and punch
him in and be able to punch him out I I
agree completely I also will say that
hard to pick against the guy behind my
shoulder a car knock more or even maybe
Wesley so if either of them make it to
the final but Anish gear You could argue
is maybe the most battle tested to this
point survived big Moments One in
Armageddon we'll see if Anish can figure
it out and will the fact that he's
battle tested pay off against his
opponent Nihao Sauron because of course
we need to talk about that guy now he
was able to come back and get past Sam
Sevin in the quarters our own my client
caught up with nihal in Belgrade after
his win on Thursday
foreign
we're here at the chess.com Global
championship in belgrad with Grandmaster
nihal sarin the only player from
Belgrade to advance now every player in
belgrad went into today with a minus
score how were you able to make the
comeback today I'm very happy that I
managed to make a comeback and
of course I was not expecting it to
finish in the rapid games at least the
first game game five was the key game
because you were worse and then you were
worse and then it turned around all at
once how did that happen the game
changed when he played D5 sort of
expected him to do that and I was quite
unhappy to see D5 I found a very strong
move Queen takes D5 Bishop G6 and queen
B7 then Sam blundered this queen Beyond
Queen B5 I think and yeah that was a
massive boost for me and in the final
game obviously he had to go for
everything and he played the tiger
modern were you thinking that was
anywhere on the radar modern is always
something to expect well somebody needs
to win on Demand with black and okay I
was already very happy to get to the
final game with the one point lead after
that seven games I'm sure you'll take
any opening at that point finally uh
what will you do to prepare for your
next match
it's a new day new match and just start
from zero
mindset for someone so young at age 18
he knows he needs to start fresh and
focus on the moment he's had a great
path to get here guys and our insights
fun fact about him I want to point out
uh he's never played Into the Now
Infamous Berlin draw in 78 rated rapid
games Canty I know you're already a fan
of the young fella yeah yeah that make
you even more of a fan of course
absolutely of course when you hear like
Berlin is a synonym for sleep so like
when you when you hear Berlin he's like
oh okay yeah you know that's how the
Berlin is right so it's uh good to see
that he doesn't play into these which
means he's going to swing all day long
imagine somebody just swinging at you
Danny just literally I'm just swinging
we were talking about this I mean he's
he's a fighter but he's also resourceful
we keep calling him mini Naka he stays
in every game and manages to Swindle his
way to victories under time pressure
your thoughts about yeah I mean don't be
fooled by his repertoire he does play
the London you know I'm not going to
count that against him you know usually
I do but you know so be careful
I'll give him the benefit of the day oh
yeah he is oh my God I need to watch my
tongue but but nihal plays these
openings he likes to just get positions
he actually deviates bucks the trend
that we've seen a lot of young players
he doesn't play the topical Italians as
frequently he just likes positions and I
mean he might be the greatest like
middle game flat out middle game player
of this Young Generation he's so fun to
watch I know Eric Rosen has the rep for
being the London guy but you're also a
London guy are you taking any offense to
the London comments
and they're all over the place world
renowned expert over here but let it
slide uh Danny thank you this time I
think we might have to commentate soon
yeah yeah keep it friendly but I mean
Nihao has been all but impressive and
it's his road to get here that probably
isn't talked about enough taking you
know guys like kramnik being lyron like
these are huge names and he's one of
those guys that just always seems to get
it done he was down in his match he had
a comeback he just always seems to get
the result and you know he's comfortable
playing down on time yeah and you live
by the sword Die By The Sword because
sometimes you're so comfortable
comfortable that you don't even realize
your time's getting down there yeah of
course even a quick compliment that I've
even heard that they've called him a
little way car rule right after you I've
heard you say that before when when you
know time gets low like that I only see
Carlo in Precision the accuracy the
resourcefulness it's really you see that
in sorry
well will he stay precise when it
matters most he has that clutch Factor
people talk about but we're going to
know soon enough so let's turn to
today's semi-final matches here they are
again you see at the uh Anish giri and
nihal sarin will lead things off they
are at the top because of that they
start on the hour Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so will kick things off 10
minutes after that we like that stagger
so that our casters can focus and give
you their full energy one game at a time
we know you like catching the big
moments fans so 10 minutes after Geary
Soren will be Nakamura so let's dig in
here guys starting with Sauron and Geary
uh we saw Gary's comments yesterday that
he thinks he maybe matches up pretty
good against the youngster at this time
your thoughts on whether those be
fighting words for Soren no I think
those are just objective words okay I
mean when you think about who's on the
other side of the bracket Nakamura and
Wesley so he would just rather play Niha
I don't think that was a slight in any
direction it's just you know
comparatively Danny he would rather play
nihal sarin and he spoke about how maybe
in the really short formats Nihao might
be the favorite in classical I think
theory has the edge this should be a
really even match up but I look to Nihao
in that time pressure situation if he
keeps getting in that spot he's not
always going to be able to get out of it
yeah I want a second iman's point I
think some people listen to that
interview and they think hey oh Geary
said you know is an easy opponent but no
that's like you know an oatmeal raisin
cookie versus nothing
nehal is still a bad opponent but better
than Wesley or Hikaru I think that's
safe to say so I don't think there are
any easy or good opponents in this
tournament but I agree I think
anishagiri is stating facts and you know
this is what you would choose between
the other Alternatives the best
candidate move yeah he was very good
great way to put it he was very
objective about it just uh speaking what
he thought and of course he even put out
there I mean if I lose I get crushed I
get crushed right and Lead would like
I'm just gonna beat the kid right it was
more like I mean we'll see what happens
I'm gonna play my best chess and be
solid about it all right well if it
makes me Health feel any better if I had
to choose one of the four players I
would take gearing okay there you go all
right well let's talk about Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so the two Americans
they have a long history against each
other uh and they they've been known as
Rivals though they spent time working
together at the Fisher random World
Championship it was seen on video kind
of practicing the positions but here
they are facing off
two two legends of American chess what
are your thoughts on how they match up
on paper I'm on well first of all it's
really interesting to go from you know
spending time together working towards a
success to spending time you know across
the table from one another working
directly against uh each other so that
already in itself is pretty interesting
NACA is coming in with momentum Danny we
know that in you know previous
tournaments in this tournament as well
but I think in his match it was that
slip up that almost comeback that you
gotta feel like a guy like Wesley if
that happens if he gets those chances
he's gonna punish them it I don't think
NACA can afford to have that happen
again your thoughts yeah I mean I think
Hikaru did defeat Wesley in in the RCC
playoffs so Wesley's gonna have to push
push that away from his mind but the
reason I'm looking forward to it is not
only because both players are in good
form as I highlighted earlier but these
are players with two different styles
two different psychological makeups and
both of them have achieved tremendous
success doing things their way so I'm
going to be very curious to see who will
be able to drag the other player into
their territory their time types of
positions that's great in fact when you
say their private positions in fact this
being a faster time format too as well
he car was definitely a favorite right
and momentum as you as you spoke about
too when when somebody's hot you know in
basketball and they shoot and they just
score rocking pass me the ball right and
Hikaru is like that right now so he
passed me the ball it could be a clean
one or it could be you know one one
point game but we'll see I think Hikaru
got this one though yeah and I wouldn't
be surprised if this one's going to come
down to the wire I love love all the
points about the Styles The Clash and
who will get the better of it knock it
or so we're going to find out right and
as many of you know we've been finding
out what your predictions were
throughout this week thousands of you
participated in our cgc bracket
challenge there are still prizes
available including some chess bra hand
towels signed by Iman Hamilton whether
they're used or not I don't know okay
but uh here's here's how all of you
picked those of you who predicted these
matchups here's how you predicted uh the
semi-final matchups from here if you had
them in your bracket hey Cara Nakamura
still heavily favored no matter who he
plays even when Wesley so I think that
probably even Hikaru would agree that's
that's definitely that's a big
percentage there in a match that could
be closer to 50 50. Anish giri favored a
much more of a coin flip against Nihao
sarin for those of you who had this in
your bracket so uh a lot to unpack there
but of course we need to also formalize
our predictions that's what the
community thought now we're going to
talk about what we think we're here in
Toronto we have two matchups to pick
let's start with uamon who are you
taking in the Geary Sauron match uh
Danny and Yuri siren I'm going to take
Anish giri in that matchup I think that
you know one of the main points that I
alluded to earlier was that the time
situation that Nihao gets in he's really
good at getting out of that spot but I
think it's because he's so comfortable
being low on time yeah that he gets into
that spot when he shouldn't and Gary's
the type of player to use that to his
Advantage use his extra time and punish
now we've talked about that a lot
players who get in time pressure can get
themselves in trouble I don't know who
those are I'm also going to take Anish
giri not just because he's here and and
sometimes we gotta hug it out from time
to time I got a niche I do think he's
the slight favorite I think it was an
objective pick
um and I'm going with the Dutchman I'm
going with the Dutch man myself I'm
going with any scary my guy listen I was
gonna go with the Dutchman but Anisha
sitting behind me I think he performs
best and he's got a chip on his shoulder
so I'm gonna go in the hall he might
like this too
so you're okay you're taking someone
okay sorry I just heard that all right
here we go we got three Anish and a
Sauron but now let's talk about Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley cell we'll be
curious how this one lines up this is a
big match to Americans I think even
though it was 63 from the community if I
had to guess a lot of people might be
closer to 50 50 now I'm on your pick
yeah Danny in this match I've got Wesley
I mean honestly speaking this is about
as much of a coin flip as you could get
so let's avoid all the cliches both of
these guys have a real chance yeah both
could win uh uh not surprised by your
pick but I am gonna go with
akaranakamura the reigning Fisher random
World chess champion who took the title
from Wesley so I think he continues his
form and is our first Global champion at
the end I'm riding with the World Champ
my guy Hikaru all day not even a
question yeah I'm gonna go with Hikaru I
think it's gonna I think it's gonna be a
really really close match but ultimately
I think he car is going to get the upper
hand in the time scrambles and I mean
his form is just speak for spoke spoken
for itself
well I'll figure out if I'm allowed to
that going forward but here we go all
right that's it for us for now we will
see you through the course of the four
games today of course for now we swing
it over to Robert Hess who also happens
to be standing with a certain reigning
U.S chess champion we all know uh Robert
thanks for being here but Fabi you're
looking fresh hey thanks Danny oh thanks
Danny and the Gang we are have the
absolute pleasure to be joined by
Fabiano caruana I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess and Bobby how's it feels to be here
in Toronto uh it feels great it's such
an exciting event and I'm really looking
forward to all the matches I think
they're going to be unpredictable and
we'll have a lot of fun today we
certainly will and it's different than
when you were playing in the event
because now it's a different format
still the same time control still the
same Armageddon bidding procedure but
Fabi in a best of eight game how does
that change the dynamic I think it's a
really big difference the thing about
best of four game matches is that one
slip and everything can go wrong you
lose one game and against these guys
it's very difficult to come back from it
eight games it still gives you a lot of
time to come back yeah we still only
have four players in the field so Fabi
there is a chance to make a comeback if
you lose day one none of these players
want to have that early deficit so as we
look at the matchups for today who do
you have in the match between Geary and
nihal sarin I have knee-hal on this one
I think that he has that clutch Factor
Anish has the experience and the class
of course he's he's been a top player
for so many years but the clutch Factor
the fact that he that nihal can come
back from any sort of lost position
that's that's something that very few
people have and I'm going with the
preparation wizard Anish Geary in this
one I know the chat for once agrees with
me they also picked a niche to win this
matchup but Bobby we are going to have a
second match staggered by 10 minutes
it's Hikaru Nakamura versus Wesley so
who do you have in that I'm taking any
color for that one I think that Hikaru
has been on fire recently I mean winning
the Fisher random World Championship but
the thing is Wesley is also a player who
works a lot with confidence if he wakes
up today and he just feels inspired he
can be an Unstoppable Force even for
ikaru but still he covers my pick the
momentum everything going right for him
recently I think that's gonna be a big
factor I think hikar uses psychological
Factor but I'm going with Wesley so he's
stoked he is unafraid and I'm unafraid
to disagree with chat I know I usually
ignore you I can't ignore your pick
akari Nakamura is chat's pick they agree
with you on this one Fabi so not too
surprising on that front but as we turn
to our first semi-final matchup it will
start with Anish giri versus nihal sarin
Anish is 10 years nihal senior but Fabi
they have not played before at least not
very much yeah I think that Anish
doesn't have so much experience with
these young players as much he's he's my
generation you know we've played a
million games but against these young
guys he doesn't have as much as much
experience but we were speaking
yesterday and you know he's been
thinking about the psychology of these
younger players how they approach
openings how they prepare for these
matches so he's put some thought into
that I think that will that will come
into play you know Anish is also a
master of preparation he definitely
definitely
prepares his openings very meticulously
and also thinks about his opponents but
still the the lack of experience against
nihal in particular that might play a
factor okay well nihaustan he has the
benefit of having not played him as
you're saying because he hasn't suffered
those defeats when you play someone
older than you usually you lose the
first batch of games that can be bad for
your comments but nihal siren is not
somebody who needs extra confidence he
knows how strong he is the faster time
kills and we are off and it's a sicilian
from Neil so are you at all surprised by
the opening Choice uh not too surprised
I think a lot of these young Indian
players they have been dabbling in these
swishing conversations I noticed that
like progdananta good cash a lot of
these players play this
um sometimes they play with G6 instead
of E6 but uh he's playing E6 I think
nehal has played this quite a bit before
as well it's a very weird setup because
the bishop on f8 is stuck there and not
developed so you would like to get this
piece out but there's a knight on E7 in
its path So eventually they're gonna
have to be some traits for black to
develop so Fabi in this position nihal
taking his first think he chooses Knight
G6 but is that catching your eyes
something that's normal or what's going
on here yeah so this this D4 move
um I I think I was one of the early
players to play it against Boris gelfin
in 2013 and Knight G6 is a slightly more
unusual Choice compared to A6 or white
takes on C6 and creates this sort of
different totally different structure
black usually takes back with the b-pawn
uh here we're not going to see that
white will try to either play C3 Knight
D2 or sometimes try to get C4 in but
looks like he'll play Knight D2 and then
the bishop will probably drop back to E2
and he'll try to get F4 that's the
typical plan for white but a typical
plan for black is somewhere to get
Bishop G5 in that that sometimes is the
thing and Boris girlfriend is a huge uh
expert of these lines so a lot of the
theory of this opening is based on off
of his games okay we see the bishop has
dropped back to D3 the pawn E4 extra
well-defended and Fabio is a really good
point that if black can play Bishop to
G5 maybe you can secure the F4 Square
some of these dark scores on the king
side there is a knight on G6 that Knight
would like to hop forward but for now
the bishop on E3 is covering its
progress I do like this position for
white if black ever trades on D4 I'm
gladly capturing towards the center with
C takes D4 improving my Pawn formation
and if not then white just has all of
these pieces nice and compactly situated
here ready to storm forward with F4
maybe even F5 and that could lead to a
potential attack against the black king
So as we sit here nihal he's spending
his time Fabi We Praise nihal on day two
for playing much more quickly his day
one time management wasn't very good but
when you see the early lead in the clock
for Anish giri and where he is the
better prepared player he's the veteran
player I feel like this should be good
news for the Dutch number one as he goes
for his Queen H5 maneuver so he's going
for a sort of attack over here F4 next I
am actually very very concerned for
nihal sarin's position because Fabi
correct me if I'm wrong the attack might
come very quickly yeah I'm a bit worried
because Ani's just playing so quickly
and he's also an expert in these lines
with both colors and yeah F4 Rook F3 and
Rook H3 is the idea that looks very
scary because if black has to play H6
then you're looking at F5 and Bishop
takes H6 tactics in the in the future of
course this is all way down the line uh
black will have time to prepare for this
attack but still you get those thoughts
that this is scary and my opponents in
preparation uh it definitely gets in
your head a bit now he's thinking will
he take back with the pawn to get gain a
temple on that bishop and D3 but on the
other hand then maybe white can use a d
file as well so uh he has a choice here
normally Bishop takes C6 feels like the
most natural move right because if you
take with the pawn then your Bishop
looks a bit silly behind that pawn you
got kind of a diamond button the bishop
1v7 is behind the pawns yeah you you
could eventually try to get C5 but then
again that c Pawn is a kind of covered
at the moment there's a bishop and a
queen attacking it uh you might be able
to achieve that but you might not I
would feel like Bishop takes e66 is the
most natural move but then the question
is how do you respond to F4 because
that's clearly White's next move do you
try to break in the center with D5 uh do
you try to play more slowly but then
Rook F3 Rook H3 is happening sooner or
later so he takes with the pawn tries to
gain a temple and plays C5 and F4 comes
so look at this Anish giri he's playing
instantly right he has nearly as much
time as he started with Neil hasn't
spent that much time but I'm getting
worried because we saw this on day one
as soon as he was down to just under a
minute he's the best bullet player on
chess.com at least his rating is often
the highest but you can't survive the
middle game when you're struggling and
your opponent is minutes on the clock
the thing is he's not worried at all
about time trouble that's why he's happy
to get there because he wants to make
sure he has as good a position as
possible and most people are terrified
when they get into I mean I'm one of
those guys I think most people are
terrified when they get low on time
because that's where the blunders
usually happen but niho he knows that he
he can avoid those blunders so his main
challenge is getting out of the opening
with a playable position because look
Anish is still playing so quickly he's
still in preparation I mean he he hasn't
spent any time on the clock and he's
already up over three minutes yeah it's
very important to note that this potency
five well it could have been captured
the Knight on D2 would have been loose
the bishop on E3 a very important piece
sitting here so that's why that pawn C5
was not captured C4 played that carves
up more space for Black's pieces but F5
and I feel like White's just storming
forward here my question is what happens
after Rook F3 you're just gonna play
with the Rook lift okay you've been
taking less than James candy lifting is
good that's a that's a mating attack I
mean imagine Rook F3 and play some sort
of uh you know non-consequential move
like Rook to C8 okay A Move where you
know black should probably do something
more concrete and then Rook H3 you cover
that with H6
and now maybe F5 is coming and and some
potential sacrifices oh my goodness yo
these things they become very concrete
maybe black survives maybe not but you
have to calculate all this in advance so
uh Rook F3 the other option is maybe the
Knight will come to F3 yeah then you
also prepare Rook a D1 so you have
multiple ideas going on wow just the
queen you mentioned this as soon as D
takes D6 The Rook can come D1 use the
open file and I'm still looking at F5
because where is this Knight going if
you don't want to take on F5 we can show
a very direct line after F5 if you take
on F5 and I take back with the pawn of
course I'm threatening your knight on G6
but if you move the Knight to E5 I can
play F6 here threatening Checkmate in
one move so you can't take the pawn F6
and you can't take you lose the bishop
yeah so this is game over so after F5
black cannot take I'm wondering about
the option of sacrificing a pawn with
Knight to E5 now F takes E6 happens and
black it looks like he's already
everything's collapsing but there's F6
and that pawn E6 it is a passport on but
it's also in the heart of Black's Camp
so it might fall off at some point and
the question here is does white
concretely have a way to support that
pawn or to use it very quickly like
maybe Knight to F3 and then you try to
either play an id4 or to remove that
Defender off E5 and break in the center
with E5 yourself right the bishop is
behind the pawn so we'll see how Anish
giri goes forward he seems to be out of
his preparation but two players who are
about to show their preparation or
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so that game
is about to begin Hikaru gets white in
game one and this matchup between two
players from the United States two
players popular that you know extremely
well Hikaru slightly older their rapid
rings and chess.com even and if you look
at the last 10 rapid meetings also tied
yeah these players have so much
experience against each other and they
are in in terms of strength they are
pretty much comparable I mean they have
very different styles but uh having been
top players for so many years now uh
free car Roots it's uh already we can
talk about Decades of being a top player
uh I mean they're they're very evenly
matched
but I wonder what we'll see already in
the opening because uh these are players
who are rather predictable in terms of
their opening choices with the black
pieces but with the white pieces they
tend to experiment a lot so that'll be
interesting let's see a Berlin draw what
do you think they did that so many times
throughout the rapid Chess Championship
and Wesley he has the black pieces he
would love that we're gonna see either a
Berlin or an Italian now that's that's
my guess okay Knight C6 big question
mark Bishop B5 so we are getting a
Berlin and this time hikar quickly
playing C3 and Wesley striking with D5
in the center so Fabi you are an expert
on these types of variations what do you
think the players want from each other
yeah so this is actually a crucial
moment for white here does he take on D5
or does he play Knight B to D2 because
these are two completely different
structures and both moves are let's say
in theoretical terms roughly equivalent
moves you know both both are kind of
equalish but Knight bd2 keeps more
tension in the position and this is
actually how Hikaru lost to her job of
in the candidates tournament he was
playing with the black pieces where
drama played Knight bdd2 and uh
eventually won an extremely important
game it turned out for the ultimate
standings because Hikaru was close to
qualifying for a world championship
match if he had just had you know half a
point more at some point so uh he he has
experience from both sides and maybe
that thought that oh I lost this with
black that maybe there's some chances
for white here so A5 is a theoretical
move and white has a choice now you can
also take on C6 and capture the pawn E5
but Wesley is prepared for that you
don't sack upon the opening without
knowing exactly what is happening
afterward yeah that's right so we can
show this variation Bishop takes C6 Pawn
takes C6 Knight takes E5 give me your
Central Pawn but Bobby how does this uh
variation continue here because black is
not just handing a pawn with no
compensation I don't remember the exact
Theory here I would assume that black
plays either Rook T8 or D takes E4 uh
Rook d8 it looks like it's sacrificing
another Pawn but after Knight takes C6
that Knight is also in a rather
precarious position
so so either one of those if white goes
for this one of those two moves would
probably be played but I assume that
Hikaru won't be in a rush to take on C6
because it feels like if you go for that
you're walking to your opponent's
preparation you're probably just going
to run into some long theoretical line
and and not get anything out of the
opening so he wants to keep more tension
in the position and that's why we saw
the move H3 yeah quiet move just
covering the G4 Square which important
because the bishop sometimes pins the
Knight other times the Knight wants to
come to G4 and attack F2 we saw
positions like this yesterday but the H3
Pawn covers the square and now the
question is what is the deal with this
tension this is the E4 D5 Pawn Dynamic
black often takes this Pawn on e4 and
well as soon as I say it Wesley does it
and the question then becomes C6 Knight
E5 pawn bishop takes e66 compromises
Black's Pawn structure double isolated
pawns but at the same time it gives away
the bishop pair so in your experience do
you prefer playing this position The
Wider the black side I prefer this from
the white side just because white has a
slightly more pleasant position it's a
symmetrical structure but the Knight on
C6 is a bit misplaced and actually we
see a funny thing with this night always
for example in hikaru's game with black
and we might even see a transposition to
that game he played Knight to A7 kicking
the bishop back at some point the bishop
dropped back and then he went back to C6
so we see that kind of standoff very
often the Knight also drops back to B8
or to d8 it looks like oh you're
undeveloping your knight but the Knight
going to B8 can come back to D7 and it's
it's a slow maneuvering position you
have time to to solve your problem
pieces and the Knight on C6 is one of
them uh I assume that we will see D
takes E4 and then at some point why
we'll make the choice do you play A3 or
A4 A4 is more like keeping the structure
okay he instantly plays A4 but A3 to
expand was also another option to play
B4 so both guys are very familiar with
this position it's clear from the the
speed at which they're moving right and
so the point is this Knight on C6
dominate protecting E5 but dominated by
this Pawn on C3 over here it's taking
away the forward jumps and that's a
dynamic that I like to point out often
but there it is Knight to B8 so Bobby
you seem to have a great handle on this
position Wesley brings his Knight back
to B8 he might want to kick this bishop
out of B5 later and let me ask you about
this they are playing face to face and
in this format where some players are in
Belgrade uh Anish is playing nihal
across the across the ocean would you
rather be face to face or would you
rather play someone from afar you know I
just feel so much more comfortable
playing face to face compared to online
it just you know I I spent my entire
career playing over the board and online
chess it's a somewhat new development
and it has just a different feel to it
and I think psychology in that case
plays a part I was even talking to Anish
about this yesterday he was saying that
he feels like some players they just
play much better online because they
don't have that psychological deficit
I'm facing Hikaru you know he's right
across from me this Legend of Chess and
uh okay in this case you know they're
both Legends of shots they don't have
those thoughts but but some people feel
more comfortable playing seeing their
opponent across from them and some
players feel more comfortable just you
know seeing a screen in front of them oh
look at that shirt I mean Wesley's gonna
be distracted to look at those patterns
there it looks great but I think your
point is a good one that for Wesley I
see him like kind of covering his eyes
looking just straight at the computer
and it could be it distracting to peer
up at your opponent to say all right he
looks a little bit uncomfortable right
now or he looks like he's just relaxed
and ready to get this game on but the
Knight went from seasick to B8 to D7
White's Bishop went to F1 this position
is quite locked up unlike the position
The Other Board the game between Anish
giri and nihal sarin that position is
much more open so these players they're
testing each other in the early stage
they have so much experience against one
another Anish and nihal uh that one is a
situation where we have a veteran player
and a young player and we see on the
left side of our screen there and as we
pull up the game kind of what you were
saying happened right where the pawn is
on E6 over here it is an extra Pawn for
white but this Knight that was on G6 it
worked its way from E5 into D3 so it
sunk its teeth into White's position but
an extra upon is an extra Pawn
yeah this is this is a difficult
position to judge uh but definitely
white is on the better side of it
because that part on E6 is not
coming off the board anytime soon and
also white can start putting pressure on
the Knight on D3 by playing Rook a to D1
and you might lose you know you might
end up losing another Pawn uh although
E4 is hanging here so white has to deal
with that as well
this next move will be an important one
I I don't see anything which is
immediately evident what white should
play here many moves come to mind but uh
yeah this is an important decision for
Anish and I think this type of position
is good for nihal he's a very Dynamic
player he loves to calculate and what
the guys over there were saying you know
they're when they started the show if
they're saying Nia loves these middle
games he's really precise in them so
Anish had the opening Advantage now the
clock the lead that he had is about even
so I feel like the trajectory of the
game is heading in nihal's favorite even
if the position is still better for
white yeah I think that overall it is an
opening success for Ani she did get a
better position this is pretty much the
best you can hope for you're not going
to blow your opponent off the board all
these guys are well prepared and they
know how to avoid you know getting an
absolutely terrible position and for
nehal you know he he got a complicated
position which is what you hope for from
the Sicilian uh and time is equalized so
neither of them can be too unhappy with
the result of the opening no I don't
think so and let's like take a look at
some moves because it's 93 is such a
thorn in white size the B2 Pawn is loose
so we do want to get rid of it but Rook
a D1 the most natural move does hang the
E4 Pawn so we can't get away with that
just yet so what do you think are we
going to give up the B2 Pawn are we
going to take this Knight and maybe let
a pawn uh go to D3 you don't just have
Duda had a pass Pawn like that against a
car yesterday I think the pawn E4 is
more essential because the pawn on B2
it doesn't control as many squares in
the center like maybe in the end game
you know we're going to talk about the
importance of the queen side but for the
moment it's not the end game and you
really want to keep that Bishop out of
you for especially once the bishop gets
to E4 those Bishops have five there's
all sorts of things that Bishop would be
a monster in the middle of the board so
white really wants to maintain that pawn
I'm wondering if like Queen G4 is a
reasonable move here
uh because you know you you don't you
protect E4 you also put a bit of extra
pressure on G6 and black can't kick that
Queen away H5 isn't working because G6
is hanging F5 you can just take the pawn
so I'm wondering about this move it
feels very natural to me and maybe H4 H5
one day you know just give up the queen
side I don't care if you take on B2
because
the most important thing is King safety
and the potential mate that white would
go for I'm already taking your ideas
into account here Knight H4 let's
sacrifice on G6 go for checkmate Rook
lifts here this Knight on B2 not in play
Queen G4 is Anish Geary's choice so
Fabiano you are uh you know a superstar
in your own right Anish is trying to
copy your plans here he plays Queen G4
and if you can't take on B2 if you can't
successfully equalize the material it
does feel like a position where white is
just a healthy Pawn up with the attack
yeah this this reminds me a little bit
of nihal's game against Sam Savion where
he was getting attacked and somehow he
found a way out of it I was already
thinking that game's over there's no way
you survive this attack and the the
computer evaluation was saying the same
thing but somehow he finds a way to
defend his King in these types of
situations but now he just has to deal
with the threats Knight H4 is a not at
the moment of thread because 95 might
drop back but H4 H5 is also a threat so
I'm wondering
how black responds to this like do you
move your king out of the way maybe King
to h8
but again you you want to do something
concrete because you're also down
material you have to deal with that
factor as well and the kick on h8 it
might not be safe either no because h4h5
still comes to mind Knight H4 definitely
the sack on G6 at some point you're you
mentioned this Knight would like to get
back to E5 so the Knight F3 is doing an
important job for the moment so maybe
throwing moves like Rook to do I just
feel like black doesn't have a plan
Black's plan is don't get checkmated
watch out for White's threats and those
are the worst types of positions to be
in where it's in open board and you're
down upon and your king is the less safe
one so like what is nihal thinking here
like what's he going for this is all
calculation the hell is a calculator all
these young players are they they
understand that it's calculation over
everything and so he's just calculating
lines he's not thinking oh I'm down a
pawn and uh you know and my position is
is much worse I mean he's just trying to
find the next move the next move he's
not even thinking about evaluations I
think that that's one of the the things
about young players is that they don't
think uh about a value evaluation so
much as just concrete moves and lines
and Bishop C5 it makes a lot of sense he
wants to play Queen E7 he's trying to
Corral that pawn right go after that E6
Pawn also bring his Queen to the defense
and maybe over to G7 later and we have a
niche Geary on camera he is locked into
this position I feel like I would want
to play them with Knight D4 to keep more
material on the board protect E6 another
time but he swaps first and then plays
Knight D4 probably a bit more precise
because that B2 Pawn was loose and E6
good luck getting to it white is just
bringing his pieces to the party and if
you play Queen E7 Bishop C8 that is very
time consuming and then white can maybe
Rook left Rook F3 as you were mentioning
earlier well the question is after Queen
E7 which is by far the most natural move
how do you respond because Knight F5
doesn't do anything it just it's an
empty thread just Queen takes E6 and and
you didn't achieve anything with this
and black has a strategic potential
he has a queen side grip so in end games
this queen side these Queen side pawns
are quite powerful and the pawn D4 is an
isolated Pawn so if that pawn E6 ever
Falls white is no longer any better and
maybe we can see like the outlines of
black having some Advantage uh of course
we're not talking about that right now
that would only be in the future but
it's very important when you have a bad
position or dangerous position that you
have something to look forward to and
nihal has that if things go his way they
could really go his way yeah and I think
that white would have to strike on the
queen side with A4 B4 move like B4 is
actually really annoying to deal with
hitting this Knight you have two
Defenders of E6 you can't grab that and
if you take on passant then White's
pieces really do Thrive after a takes B3
The Simple Plan is B4 Bishop B3 and that
could be deadly with this King on G8 so
I feel like white is just in time even
though black is going for that E6 pawn
and I think that's why nihal hasn't
moved he sees that after Queen E7 he's
just not quick enough yeah I think that
B4 is a great move and it also opens up
some tactics if we go down the same line
that you just showed Queen e7b4 black
takes white takes back with the pawn and
something like Rook 80 E8 and you think
oh I'm catching that pawn but then
there's B4 again
if Knight takes E6
you just take everything or maybe
immediately is even better but at the
very least you just take everything in
Bishop B3 and the pin wins a rook yeah
that's just an extra so there's some
tactics to look but as I said everything
is concrete it's it's a matter of one
tempo in this position so that's why
nihal is calculating and trying to find
that way that that he holds on okay well
it looks concretely bad in many of these
continuations Neo will do his best and
let's look at both games they're going
on at the same time Hikaru Nakamura
Wesley so we see them on the right hand
side of the screen and that position is
could be more different than the one we
have on the left side it's locked up
they're just jockeying for position
pieces are maneuvering around and in
that one Wesley so with a four minute
lead on the clock does that surprise you
at all and a great position to boot I
mean he got the C5 Square
that's the most important thing like why
doesn't that neither side has dark has a
dark Square bishop and so that C5 square
is a permanent hole it can only be
covered by Knights and no longer by
pawns because that pawn from B4 got
pushed up to B5 that also means that in
that end games because of the Bishops E4
is a weakness and A4 is a weakness right
now we're not going to see that it's
still a relatively you know
uh stable position for both players but
there's a lot of strategic risk for
white here and not as much for black
yeah I agree because in this game
between a car and Nakamura and Wesley so
we'll Dive Right into Bobby's points
that a pawn chain is only as strong as
his base Pawn good luck getting to the
opponent C7 it's very far away from
White's pieces but as you point out
Knight to C5 already threatens two
different Pawns in White's position and
if the Queens are ever traded as you
were saying end games will not be very
pleasant for white so Fabi Hikaru the
white piece is down on the clock has a
worse position is it just that Wesley is
well prepared and getting Advantage with
the white pieces not so easy at the top
level I think that this is going to be a
problem for a car breaking through
Wesley's openings because Wesley has
played the Berlin for so long he's such
an expert he's so stable in it it's just
very very diff and I can speak from
experience about this that
playing against Wesley I'm always
thinking like what what do you do
against his openings I mean what do you
do against His Brilliant usually I try
to avoid it because I feel like it's
it's just a rock you can't break through
so that's going to be a problem for your
car the thing is that he doesn't care so
much you know some players you get a bad
position you get demoralized Hikaru is
an amazing Defender and you're saying he
literally doesn't care he maybe
literally doesn't literally not care he
cares he wants a good position but if he
gets a bad position he's willing to
defend right and maybe he should use
Wesley's methodology a well-timed draw
offer could go a long way here white is
worse for sure in this one but the
position is locked up Wesley is using
his time and a big development is
happening in the game between nihal
sarin and Anish giri because we were
predicting some of the variations and
that variation has come to life in the
game between Geary and Sauron so this uh
position is I think getting worse and
worse for the Indian teenager so that's
uh not good news if you're a fan of Neil
sarin
yeah again this is a matter of tactics
though
uh does B4 work B4 has been played and
it looks like uh step one B4 had been
played and now it's time for potentially
step two as you're saying does the move
B3 to B4 kick this Knight open this
diagonal for the bishop and why don't we
go look at it B4 how does black even
respond here I would guess Bishop takes
C6 because you don't want to play Knight
E6 oh no then then you're stuck with uh
this pin and also your Bishop on C8 is
is like obstructing your Rook on Aid
it's just everything's gaining the way
but Bishop takes C6 I'm wondering it
doesn't look losing on first glance I
mean it looks very dangerous but after
Knight takes E6
I guess Knight takes E6 okay and Bishop
Bishop B3 and then you you have to cover
with Rook fte8 I guess it looks pretty
dangerous I mean even if White's not
like winning material immediately still
you can you can slowly ramp up the
pressure with Rook doubling on the f
file trying to get E5 at some point so
yeah this this is pretty pretty ugly for
black yeah and you see the weak points
in the position the white Rooks very
active staring at Black's weak pawns the
blackworks just protecting pieces so
it's not a good situation for uh Neil
Saron and B4 has in fact been played so
we'll see if Anish giri has the end of
this game inside Bishop takes E6 the
variation you just highlighted and now
for an easy talk to cure what is it
Queen to D1 oh no because your knight
has to move somewhere it's attacked and
wherever it moves there's Knight takes
E6 and Bishop B3 oh this guy that's why
he's a US champion everybody let's show
this tactic Queen to D1 retreating is
the first step to progress the Knight
has to move it's under attack you drop
back Knight takes E6 Queen takes E6 and
what's the queen doing back home
protecting the B3 square that pins and
wins the queen and that's game that is
game I think after Queen D1 he'll have
to play Bishop C4 because you're going
to lose you're going to lose a piece but
at least you can try to get that Rook on
F1 for it bc5 Bishop F1 and then you try
to to capture C5 okay
you know you got a a rook and a pawn for
two pieces it's it's not great but uh oh
wait is there Bishop B3 and Knight E6
here first you give a check to avoid the
check on C4 King moves n96
and you end up a piece anyway you
thought you were winning The Rook but
you're losing Europe too okay well there
might be a couple pawns maybe some King
issues for white but Queen to D1 if
Anish giri plays Queen D1 that will
indicate that he's in maybe the best
form of his career because this is a
very tough tournament he said nihal
Saran of all the competitors left that's
probably the best opponent for him and
queen to D1 just that leaves Bishop B3
and that could win him the game yeah I
have to say Anish was in a very good
mood yesterday I think that overcoming
Tamor who
in these you know rapid time formats
he's such a strong player and especially
since it went down to the wire like at
some point it looked like the momentum
totally shifted Tamer was coming back
from the match but then Armageddon which
is like Armageddon is always a 50 50. so
once you overcome that you you just feel
uplifted you feel like you you overcame
this huge hurdle so that those positive
emotions might also come into play well
let me ask you something Anish giri he's
his own biggest critic he loves his
preparation he said he's you know he's
honest about it he has great preparation
he sometimes hardened himself about his
calculation this is a moment where it's
pure calculation can you take up this
bishop on E6 first for the Knight then
play for Bishop B3 should you play Queen
to D1 do you think this idea is off his
radar because sometimes a move like that
a retreat is weird to play or do you
think he's just trying to find the exact
move or he will in fact play Quinny one
actually I think that Anish does have
very good calculation uh so he's being
hard on himself but I really think he's
a very good calculator he's trained it
since he was a child like like many
players have had to do it's not pleasant
work but it's it's work that you have to
do but this is this is a bit different
than calculation this is full board
tactical awareness this is what like
Hikaru is just the best in the world at
and obviously Magnus also and some
players struggle a bit more with it but
I would assume that Anish would find
this this is fully within his
capabilities I would say even on a bad
day he he should be fully able to find
this but you never know because Knight
takes E6 is also so tempting
but he found it there it is Queen D1
perhaps the move of the semi-finals in
game one but look at niho he understood
the Tactical sequence would not be in
his favor he goes for Bishop everyone
King F1 so that's the line we were
looking at understanding Queen C5 Bishop
B3 check then Knight to E6 picks up a
rook so white will be a piece ahead are
you worried at all about Anish gears
clock he's a very good bullet player we
should add that but nihal sarin is the
best of the best when the clock is taken
down if he plays Queen takes E5 I'm not
worried for Anish because I think that
the danger is only if black has some
other minor piece like if it was two
minor pieces against one and open King
and you see some but there's just
there's no dynamism left in the attack
white just has a solid extra bishop and
okay black has a few pawns but they're
kind of weak pawns as well it's not like
he has some dangerous pass pawns on the
third rank I don't see many chances I
don't think he'll take on too far for
that reason I don't know what he'll do
here maybe he'll play King h8 just to
like keep it murky but again white has
that C6 Pawn it'll go up to C6 yeah you
said the C6 Point that's exactly where
it's going if you don't take it no
matter what black does if you don't take
it it's going to C6 and it's cemented by
a knight on D4 maybe Niha will see some
you know potential with B4 and trying to
dislodge the Knight on from D4 but
there's also Bishop coming to D5
potentially I'm I'm not sure if I see
what hope black has but you know nihal
he finds hope yesterday against Savion I
was also thinking what hope is there for
nihal in this position but he he found
it somehow he he's sort of a magician I
hear this uh word used a lot with him
but
it's very accurate you know in these
lost positions he somehow uh conjures up
magic yeah and they call him like a mini
Naka I think that's what James and
Daniel were saying and he'll need to be
because right now he's down on the clock
he's losing objectively and he plays
move F5 speaking of Dynamics he wants to
go after this king I don't exactly see
the problem with e takes F5 but I guess
in the variations where a knight lands
on E6 he wants to have some checks
against the white king so it does make
sense here and a niche he is not moving
instantly he's taking his time I would I
mean e takes A5 is very natural but then
Queen C5 will be played and if we do
look at the exact same variation Bishop
B3 King h8 96 that's not good because
now black can take on if I would check
but maybe you have Knight E6 immediately
instead of Bishop to B3
okay so as I'm saying knight uh Bishop
oh did I hear uh sorry e takes F5 Queen
C5 and now Knight E6 oh but you can even
play 96 right away I thought you were
being cheeky over here I didn't I didn't
think of that one oh I thought that's a
bit too creative but it might also be
very good but I was thinking he takes a
five Queen c596
and you're still forked if Queen C4 you
move the king and black has to deal with
not only the Rook but also Bishop to B3
coming and black has a tactic Rook takes
F5 after Knight to E6
wow they're just yikes everywhere here
Knight E6 was in fact played by a niche
gear Queen D4 check will be lights out
by the way so I think that Anish is
going to lock some we'll keep an eye on
it but the game between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so also deserves our
attention those two in the other
semi-final matchup as we see on the
right hand side of your screen here it's
looking from bad to worse for Hikaru his
King is out on F2 there's a queen on G5
The Rook lift that Rooks joined the
party going over to G6 and look at
Wesley hand still over his eyes he does
not want to take a single glance over at
ikaru who's sitting across from him
yeah it I mean this is perfect for
Wesley nothing can go wrong his position
is so stable there is no way to imagine
that white does anything besides maybe
eventually defend after a long and
arduous defense holds the holds a draw
but that's the best that white can hope
for there is not a single weakness in
Black's position and you can play H4
look at how all of Weiss pawns are fixed
on light squares the pawn in A4 is an
especially huge weakness because it
can't even be defended by another Pawn
you always have to keep a piece
defending that and also on the king side
that's not White's biggest concern at
the moment but that King is feeling a
little bit shaky there yeah and this
Rook D2 Queen D1 configuration there's a
rook on D6 saying you're not getting
through here and as you point out the
queen is very importantly placed on D1
as soon as that Queen moves you drop A4
then there's a runner on the other side
so your problems all across the board if
you're a car Nakamura he was the
People's Choice he was the favorite to
win this entire event and right now if
he loses with white in game one I think
a lot of people will be saying Wesley so
may be able to take him down well
definitely losing with white and game
one is a huge blow I still think the
length of the match means that there's
ample opportunity to come back from from
a first round loss even a tragic one
like this would be but still black has
to convert this it's not easy at all I
think that if white can somehow trade
Rooks he will be one step closer to to
getting to a drawish position but I
don't see how he does it because if he
moves his Bishop the problem is that
black takes on D2 and then A4 is falling
so that's why he would love to just like
whisk those Rooks away from the board
but it's not so easy that's why he plays
King E2 so he can move the bishop and
then re capture with the King on D2 wow
he may go on a king run in the other
game it looks like a niche gear down
under 20 seconds nihals are not much
more time so let's Zoom right over there
to that one it is getting down to the
wire in game one and for Anish giri he's
still up a bishop his King's on F1 you
can't forget about that the A2 pawns
under attack 12 seconds Bobby this is
not looking that easy yeah it could get
a bit scary because you would love to
play G3 and King G2 but there's like f
takes E4 and Rook of Fate tactics so
King G1 makes a lot of sense you just
want to get that King away from the
center as quickly as possible but who
knows maybe we'll see if something if if
black can capture that part on C3 then
we're already talking about technical
difficulties in the conversion phase
still we're rather far from that point I
mean white is solidly winning in this
position well only eight seconds in each
gear is clocked so he is winning
objectively six seconds on this is a
just a pure bullet game at this point
yeah I think that White's goal is to
capture those Queen side pawns give up
the C3 pawn and get into an end game
which is exactly what he's going for
where the time factor maybe won't matter
as much although with seconds on your
clock anything can happen it doesn't
even matter how simplified the position
is we saw that with uh Anish yesterday
against rajabov he he had reached a
completely drawn position and then a
last second blunder but here he he's
converting very very well he's capturing
B5 and what does black really have here
I guess play your Rook just protect the
pawn and it's gonna take a long time to
win that pawn and it will require your
king to come to the queens and if this
King goes over here you your G2 Pawn
will be loose so I think there are
actually some reasonable chances here
for Neil starn to survive my question is
why did the king go to H2 like the king
needs to go F2 and try to get into the
center and like rest attack Black's Rook
so that it will lose control over the A3
Pawn why is the King on H2 maybe it
doesn't matter because white has all the
time in the world wait Bishop that was a
really bad move that's game over yo
that's a huge oversight from Nielsen he
gave away the pawn but that was looking
like almost a fortress in fact if he
hadn't given up that pawn for free I
feel like it was always losing but you
never know with low time now now there's
just nothing that can go wrong also
Anish has built up a a pretty a decent
amount of time on the clock already over
20 seconds
easily convertible position I think this
game is about to finish yeah these Rooks
might be trade off by force the only
thing you don't want to have is this
pawn and this bishop that is the wrong
corner so G4 be very careful if H3 is
played do not take it with your Pawn
that's the only trick black is left but
there is a resignation Anish giri wins
game one and a very deserved victory for
the Holland player yeah this is a great
win for Anish I mean getting the
momentum right into the match gives him
confidence and I think that's that's a
very important quranish yes he wins game
one so he takes down the player from
India the Teen Nation Station so Anish
Geary plays a fantastic first game great
preparation great calculation and he now
is in the lead he is well he's vibing to
the music he's out of his chair he's
done with that yeah I think we saw that
Anish he has the class so if he can keep
his composure with the last seconds on
the clock like he did in this game then
everything can go right for him for sure
and nihal siren will have to bounce back
going forward but we have Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so and and this is a
locked up position this Knight on E3
Fabi you would love that pawn E6 to move
but unfortunately that's going to remain
there and it just feels like you have to
shuffle around yeah I don't see how
black is going to make progress I would
think the only plan would be to get that
Queen around Queen H2 Queen G1 but of
course white will always stop that with
the queen to the first Rank and you're
not gonna get in there and the only Pawn
break for black is D5 but I feel like
that will be too risky for black to go
for that pawn is very well covered by a
knight on E3 a beautiful Knight by the
way defends G2 it controls D5 it's just
it's like a a monster which holds
everything together so I think that this
game is most likely leading towards a
draw and if you're Wesley so you don't
want to lose your sight on the queen
side because this Knight at some moment
can hop to C4 and B6 and D6 will be
under attack for now the Knight has to
stay put as you're mentioning the G2
Pawn is loose but for Wesley do you
think there's any disappointment because
he had a pretty big Advantage it's not
necessarily about the result right for
you top players when you draw a game
you're better it's not like oh I'm upset
you I drew it's more like I'm upset I I
didn't put more pressure on my opponent
I think it's a bit of good and bad for
Wesley the good thing is that he was
never in any danger opening went
extremely well and he car will now
struggle against his Berlin because in
the first game you usually show your
best idea you don't save it for the end
so if he car doesn't have ideas in the
Berlin he's going to have to start
jumping to other openings and then who
knows maybe Wesley could get Chances
with black of course he did have a
better position he would have liked to
press but I think he's also he's a
relatively calm guy he'll understand
that overall it's a good thing for sure
drawing with black pieces that's
generally good is there a D5 I mean we
say it's covered and it is covered by
all of these white pieces but D5 is not
out of the question A4 drops if you make
the move D5 and I'm guessing that
Wesley's happy to make the draw but if
he had to win the game do you think he
would play that movie if he had to win
it's not even a question he would just
do it I mean you have no choice and at
that moment was specifically the best
because the Knight on A4 would come into
C3 with the queen on D1 there would be
some Fork options but yeah he Wesley is
generally a somewhat risk adverse player
and it works very well for him it's a
style it leads to very very stable and
consistent results but if he was in a
must win then of course he just goes for
it I mean there's no choice right no for
sure but I think we should show that
because that was a moment that might
have passed him by so if we analyzed the
position with the queen going to F4
there will be a timely it was right
around oh they agreed on a draw so we
didn't even have time to look at it they
just said nah nothing to see here but
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so split game
one I think that's a fair result some
tenacious defense from mikaru Nakamura
yeah hikar will be very happy uh but we
know his his quality in terms of defense
is unmatched he's one of the greatest
Defenders not the only of his own
generation but in the history of Chess
so that's one of his uh that's gonna be
one of his strengths in this match well
it is half half good news for Wesley so
for sure he had the black pieces and
well Hikaru he's not going to be phased
by that he's had bad results before he's
able to bounce back but I mean
momentum after yesterday's debacle he
did win the match against youngest of
Duda but it feels like he's maybe a
little bit out of shape right now I
don't feel that way so much I think that
he had some emotions after winning 4-0
on the first day against Judah that
maybe led to somewhat shaky play because
he already thought this match is wrapped
up it's over and that can get into your
head and cause some you know some
weaknesses in your play but overall he
played a great match against dude that
was just amazing like to dispatch a
player like that is just
amazing okay well Anish gear had a big
victory in game one so Bobby as we look
at that matchup nehal you know what do
you say his odds are to strike back in
game two I mean I still pick knee-hull
so I'm I'm still rooting for him but uh
yeah this is a tough one to come back
from but he was also down against uh Sam
Savion and he came back from that uh
even more so he won two games in a row
at some point so I don't think he's a
player who gets so phased by bad results
he's still able to come back for sure
and well we do have uh this game in
front of us between Anish gear and nihal
sarin and around here Fabi we're already
worried about nihal's position this Pawn
on C6 blocking the bishop and White's
plan seem very straightforward so C5 F4
and it seems like this move C4 was the
start of Neil's troubles instead he
probably should brought more pieces to
his King's defense yeah I mean the
preparation point was so important that
anise just blitzed out his moves and he
got a good position to boot I that was
preparation will be a factor for nehal
because Anish is so well prepared he's
so versed in so many openings he's I was
one of the best prepared players
in the top I mean it's like Magnus him
there's there's not many guys who can
compete with Anish in the opening but
one of them's right here but you're not
gonna say yourself well I'm not even
sure if because I always feel
uncomfortable against Anish in the
openings too like I feel like where do
you run against the guy he's just so
well prepared in a variety of openings
and he can jump anywhere so you always
have to be ready for opening switches
for him to attack you in this direction
that direction it's it's a big Challenge
and it will be a big challenge for nihal
and it was a challenge in this game he
attacked him straight there on the king
side he was not holding anything back
this was a critical moment after F5 the
Knight was under attack you could not
take back here we'll show that once more
because when the Knight moves F6
threatens check made in one and
threatens this bishop on E7 at the same
time as well as the 9 E5 so he had to
give up a pawn here 95 takes the Knight
is loose on E5 and after that honestly
Anish played a fantastic game Queen G4
then this B4 move maybe they're moving
around Bobby I think Queen G4 and B4
shows that he really is in good shape I
mean queen G4 was not a very obvious
move before you pointed out it comes to
mind but it's not easy easy to make that
move because it's very concrete and it's
based always on these tactics with B4
and Bishop B3 in the future which is
exactly what happened and then Queen to
D1 I mean this was a game of extreme
accuracy beautiful game from Anish Guru
he did go on to win a couple minor
pieces for a rook and take game one and
that's all for us now here in the studio
but we're gonna send it right back to
Danny and the Gang
thank you Robert wow do we have liftoff
or what guys we are back here on the
couch I'm on Hamilton Danny wrench James
Canty and Daniel narodisky guys we're
underway in the cgc semifinals we've had
a couple of pretty exciting games let's
check in with the scores and show
everybody what the results were here
after our first set of games are now in
the books Wesley so and hikaranakamura
Drew but it was a game where Wesley had
a little bit of an edge we're gonna
unpack that and maybe maybe see what we
think the two players are feeling but a
niche Geary continues to play well here
in Toronto he won an arm regret
Armageddon he starts off with a huge dub
as Fabiano said he's clearly showing
great form guys uh biggest takeaways as
we back out we'll come back to Geary
versus Sauron but the the match I want
to dive into first is this Wesley
sohikara Nakamura game right ultimately
it did end peacefully but Wesley had
some pressure right putting a little
heat on nanka what do you think about
that well the game was definitely one
where Wesley had some chances Daniel
yeah and with the black pieces game one
of the match to have chances like that
strong night on C5 I think he should be
very happy with how the match has gotten
underway but Hikaru Nakamura is so good
at defending it's one of the most
resilient Defenders so well it looks
like it's that small Edge you know I
don't think it's enough against Nakamura
and he proved that in this game when he
held on nicely yep yeah I I agree with
him on I don't think there was anything
too concrete so I don't think Wesley is
going to be all that upset in fact like
Amman said he drew from a position of
strength he had the black pieces he's
already on the board yeah I think this
is a positive result for Wesley and uh
it definitely calms the Jitters to make
a draw like that with the black pieces
but we we always say Canty that when you
have chances against Hikaru you gotta
take him because he's not going to give
you money right this is what we're
saying Wesley shouldn't be said yeah
we've seen this pony dance before with
Hikaru many times that's actually right
I mean I like to call them flexly so you
know what I mean like because he
sometimes he comes out he flexing he
Flex just now to let you know look okay
Carl I know you world champion
everything and fish are random but if
you slip I'm a hitch in your lip Okay so
you gotta be very very careful here so
you got to step it up I love the Rhymes
I love you I love the looks by the way
also I love that you you actually caught
up with a lot of the players this week I
did I did that's right I was able to
grab a few minutes with each of the
players that included Anish Geary where
it was all about the drip
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and we're here with the Mr The
Fabulous super GM on this Gary man how
are you good thank you good man good
luck at him first we got to do a drip
check look at the drip check the drip
okay show them the socks one time show
them the socks bro
look at it you see the lace game with it
Jack okay taking those super GM drip for
my Niche Geary himself okay all right so
I have a question for you Halloween was
Monday what scares you the most spiders
no not and insects no it's not snowing
cute but uh cute what was the most of
interesting you've done I mean I went
like Mountain skiing a lot of times but
I don't honestly think it's that
adventurous like if you tell me like you
know you I don't know you've become a
suggested winner if you go bungee
jumping okay I'll do it right pregame
rituals I have this playlist called like
um
you know you've got these soundtracks
yeah like of this epic movies yeah bad
boy you've got this uh Inception type
you know the Dark Knight Rises I tried
that didn't really work so how do you
handle high stakes pressure 200k on the
line big fella that's a lot of money
they honestly like you don't think about
money so much yeah I think nowadays with
like the bank accounts who are transfers
and all that you don't really get the
feel like I mentioned if you had like a
like you would have to pack all these
dollar bills into your bag from every
tournament you know like you want to buy
like I don't know a car and you just
come with these big bags yeah okay put
it down and all right well thanks uh so
much for being with us today all right
internet congrats and good luck to you
in uh cgc thank you
foreign
[Music]
but he is 28 years of age he's had a
really interesting path here to get to
Toronto as he continues to play well uh
one fun fact he has the highest
percentage of brilliant moves in his
games that were played on chess.com
Donya unpack that for me yeah anisha's
like always underrated and I think the
reason is that when you think of
anishikiri brilliant games you know you
don't necessarily think of one game in
particular but Anisha has been so
consistent now for years and years and
years we sort of take that for granted
but he's always at the top of the
tournament standings he's always beating
the top guys he never seems to have like
a truly bad event so all these like
intangibles again that we take for
granted are the reason that I think
we're seeing yet another excellent
performance consistency
maybe the undoing for Soren he's up one
game right here in this match your
thoughts on what Soren would have to do
to turn things around right now well uh
shoot is you gotta play you got to play
better obviously but Geary playing good
I mean it's really hard to do that I
think what he said is reset remember
when he came in he was like I gotta
reset right so of course that reset
every game is a thing I remember ikaro
actually says uh you need to have
short-term memory loss and when it comes
to this kind of stuff right so it's even
it's uh easier said than done but I
think that's what he's got to do yeah
yeah first of all do you hear that point
of contact on that Erie and Canty that
was smooth but uh seriously speaking uh
in that match I think what we're looking
for is you know Geary he's he's hot
right now right he's playing out of his
mind yeah like Queen D1 that whole
combination was seriously impressive
incredible it's not that nihal is you
know lacking in certain categories I
think it's that Geary's on another level
right now so I mean if he keeps at that
level Danny I don't know how nehal is
going to handle that well and you saw he
also was up on the clock throughout most
of the game as Fabi said the shuffling
of the queen from from G4 to D1 the
timely B4 he is on form find form and
he's looking fresh and he's very well
dressed uh he's uh he's going to be a
tough man to slow down here in Toronto
even if you are playing from Belgrade so
all right well before we take a quick
break let's get a reminder from our
sponsor Brave means private browsing and
so much more by default Brave blocks ads
and trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it also
means 35 percent longer battery life
while saving on mobile data and internet
bandwidth for Android iOS and desktop
get the best browser for gamers
streamers and creators which in 60
seconds at brave.com chess much more to
come from day one of the cgc semifinals
our first games are in the books with
our game twos right around the corner
twitch subscribers we have plenty of
exclusive content for you during the
break don't miss it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bro how long have you been working out
because the way that you grab that King
and broke the top of it shows that you
have some Incredible strength Sam yeah
I've been working out for at least the
last eight years until right now you see
them you see them yeah exactly right
what scares you the most anything like
spiders bugs movies
[Music]
um if anything it probably hurts the
most yeah really okay yeah you get like
afraid of you throw up or like is it
like oh man I can't just go up there no
no no when I'm like standing on a cliff
possibility before yeah that's actually
probably the same for me too don't do
the home chat what's the most of
interesting skydiving back flipping off
your back porch or something sadly no
but I hope I do one day actually yeah
yeah yeah
thank openings and why oh canvas yeah
yeah okay initiative really quickly yeah
this one's in particular I like Evan's
Canada oh Evans okay
what a Savage congratulations on all
your success Sam and a good luck to you
in the cgc thank you
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
try to write a little more allegedly
this time yeah yeah don't worry I got
you do you though
take two
I was born in Vancouver but as fond as I
am oh God my voice is already cracking
okay I'm gonna do this again and the
thirst for Bros
do you agree with that statement I don't
know Sports can you name a single
Canadian team
Canucks
Vancouver baby my wife you're in the
right place it's really hard to wear a
blazer and be professional and stuff you
know what I agree with xqc
he's like I meant to tell Andrea she was
so annoying like the most annoying but
it was because I was roasting you no it
was because she's annoying oh it's
getting hot again Alex could you fan the
director please I can't do it I need you
to Fan me can you go you can't do it
anymore it's too hard
you're gonna break something sisters
it's already a little broken in there
let's go all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
back to Toronto and the cgc semifinals
back inside the gameplay Hall you see
the cgc championship trophy which will
be awarded on Monday also to be awarded
the 200 000 first place prize here's
what we have given out thus far tied for
fifth through eighth we have Dimitri on
draken yanchist of Duda Sam sebien Team
rajav all earning 25 000 if you lose
here in the semis you still get a cool
50k and of course the big prize fund is
200
000 I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess we have
Grandmaster Fabiana carwana the U.S
chess champion with us Bobby an exciting
game one of those semifinals yeah this
this was great I mean we saw some blood
we saw some potential blood in one of
the games but Hikaru showed his
defensive skills and the other game
Anish came off to a blistering start
showed his preparation showed his
accuracy and calculation and putting up
pressure so yeah it was a great first
game yeah I think that Anish giri is
going to be the happiest camper probably
followed up by Wesley so but as you said
Hikaru Nakamura a tenacious Defender
when he has an iffy position he makes it
seem like no problem at all but Anish
giri he wins game one nihal sarin this
is gonna be tough for him yeah we'll be
talked the good news for him is that
it's a long match he has a lot of time
to come back from it and he has
experienced recent experience from
coming back from deficits if he needs
inspiration he just has to go back to
yesterday
yeah for sure and Wesley so he will get
the white pieces against a car Nakamura
that's good news for him after a good
start and well our first matchup we have
them staggered by 10 minutes will be
Anish giri and nihal SAR and this time
nihal gets the white pieces as we dive
into the insights of these two players
look at that average accuracy it's even
for both but nihal prefers those Wild
Games Bobby well that's not a surprise
to anyone I mean nihal is known for his
unconventional openings his defensive
abilities and also his Wild games and
the wildest thing that could happen is
you get into a lost position and somehow
come back from it and we have multiple
examples even recent examples of that
happening to to nihal so I'm not
surprised at all to see that his Wild
games are so high compared to other
players and they both have a high
percentage of end games in each Geary
there he is as you said good at all
elements of the game his preparation is
Stellar his calculation is up there with
the best and then in the end game he's
able to win and convert those advantages
so uh for Anish giri settling in for
game two sometimes you feel like when
you win game game one you get even more
nerves because you're like I need to
keep this up and you may lose your
objectivity at all I think that could
definitely happen near the end of
matches because then you're thinking the
goal is in sight I'm already so close to
the final but still we're at the start
of the match I don't think that Anish
will be nervous yet and he's also so
highly experienced I mean he's been
playing chess at the top level for more
than a decade so this is not a new
experience for him he's not going to get
psyched out or anything that's for sure
but there has been a lot of critics out
there saying anishq hasn't won a Super
tournament with him being so close right
now he is in the semi-finals he has a
one point lead do you think this matters
to him more than say Hikaru or Wesley I
don't think so exactly I think that
Hikaru cares so much about these things
I mean like especially coming off
official random World Championship win
he'll think I mean I I have a momentum I
want to keep showing the world that I
can win these huge events Anish of
course he he doesn't have as many of
these successes as Hikaru has for
example especially in these fast time
Patrol formats but still I don't know if
he'll let that pressure get to him I
think he's a relatively
stable person he he understands he puts
things in perspective so I don't think
he's going to let that get into his head
and notice we haven't talked about Neil
star and he's the teenager he really
wasn't expecting Nest to get this far he
beat Vladimir kramnik he beat dingley
Wren and now he'll need to beat Anish
giri in game two to even up the score
and we see Knight F6 and F3 will we get
a London system we have the start of a
potato Griffin Knight D2 Fabi yeah I I
actually played this so many times with
white that I'm not too surprised by it
uh at some point I was playing a lot of
games against Yanni pamiyachi and I
didn't want want to fight against his
grunfeld so I was playing also against
Maxim varsher lagrove I was playing
these kinds of Knight D2 and B4 or 92
and B3 setups so I'm not too surprised
to to see that happen I think it's a
good way to get a game and also one
thing that Anish mentioned yesterday was
these young guys know how to play
somewhat offbeat lines that are good at
getting a fighting position and this is
exactly the type of opening where you
got a fighting position for sure we
already have tension in the center of
the C4 D5 now C5 and D4 pawns they're
these pieces are all staring at each
other and you don't want to release the
tension too early because if say black
took on C4 in comes at night you improve
your opponent's pieces with these
captures so both sides they're going to
leave the tension until they feel the
moment is actually perfect and probably
is it that moment will we finally see a
capture you know what I think shows
anisha's familiarity with his line is
that he didn't play E6 because it's so
automatic to at some point play E6 but
he played 97 C5 in a particular move
order that makes me feel like he knows
it not only in like where you're
generally supposed to put your pieces
but in in a very specific fashion like
concretely I make this move here and I
make this move at this moment so and H3
also played so quickly it's like you
don't just play that without knowing
anything that feels like he's studied
the position and H3 was something that
he sort of prepared maybe not in massive
detail because in this position you
can't prepare massive detail but in some
detail well Niha is also ahead on the
clock he's over 15 minutes so that's
good news for him clock management has
been a struggle now in the previous game
that wasn't the issue it was great
preparation and an advantage for Anish
Geary but I think he's going to show
Anish who is going to be ahead on the
clock throughout today's action because
if nihal can keep that lead in The Clock
I think that puts a lot more pressure on
a niche and Anish he's the type player
who spends time in moments where he's
unfamiliar so we know he's out of
preparation right now overall yeah I I
think that despite him being out of
preparation it is still a good opening
for Anish I mean he might not know this
position so specifically but still he
has a very very stable close to equal
position and
is this the position where it's easiest
to outplay on each I don't think so I
think that on each has some weakness in
chaotic positions and this is relatively
normal you know you make your moves that
could be E6 it could be Queen E7
thinking at some point you take on C4
you play A6 but these are relatively
normal moves you're not going to get a
very bad position with black here nehow
is saying I don't care it's a rapid game
at some point something crazy might
happen and I'll get my chances but is it
the best strategy it's hard to say okay
well maybe Neil needed a lesson from
coach Fabiano over here because the
position while white has the better
place pieces the Knight on C4 and a
knight over here on D4 these Knights are
great for white the problem is that
there are no more targets to exploit so
the knights look positioned well but
what pawn do you know after A7 is hard
to attack you attack it with a knight
the pawn just pushes up so I feel like
uh with that in mind I agree with you
that a niche should be right at home in
this position yeah I think he played a
very natural move he's just trying to
Knight E4 he's trying to reorganize his
Knights so the Knight on e4 is a bit
annoying because you can't push it away
with a pawn so it just kind of stays
there like a thorn near side the other
night will probably come to F6 and maybe
to D5 and he's just saying okay all my
pieces are well developed why am I any
worse and that's probably true I think
we might see Bishops F3 at this moment
because if you can't challenge that
Knight with a pawn you might as well pin
it and make it kind of annoying for
black to to uh you know move that Knight
in the future if he ever wants to and
it's also planning Queenie 2 and Rook to
D1 putting some pressure on the open
file so we might see Queen E2 here feels
like a very natural choice but it's a
position where you can do whatever you
want not whatever you want but you you
have a wide choice of natural moves for
both sides and I learned this from the
Legends like gotta comps and Peter lekko
the C6 Square that's what you need to
keep an eye on I'm already looking at
Knight to E5 because now you have three
pieces aimed at that square if you can
plant in the nc6 then it starts to get
annoying for black you know speaking of
Peter laco because you you mentioned him
one of the games I was most impressed
with of anishes was how he knocked out
Peter laco from the 2015 World Cup in
exactly the structure it was a Catalan
but it was the same structure and at
some point he traded pieces and he
exploited the C6 Square exactly as you
mentioned so it's funny that you
mentioned those names with that theme
because that's exactly what happened
between the two of them so here he's on
the other side of it but Anish is an
expert of these types of structures and
symmetrical positions where white has
the tiniest of poles based mostly on his
slightly better pieces like the knights
on C4 and D4 they're beautiful the
knights on e4 and F6 also good but the
Knight on e4 is pinned for the moment
and black would love to organize his
Queen but how do you get the queen out
of the way of Rook f2d1 with potential
96 Knight to five tactics coming you
don't have a very very comfortable
Square for that Queen because if it goes
to C file now you have you have other
you know discoveries involving Knight A5
uh on the cards so that Queen is a
slight issue for Anish at the moment for
sure the queen will have to dodge the
threats and Anish is burning some clock
here it seems to be the case that Nihao
is more comfortable he chose the opening
he must be happy with it and you know we
see the players on screen and Niche he's
in that thinking pose how many times you
think you've sat across a niche over the
chessboard how many games do you two
played I can't even count I wouldn't
even know how to to guesstimate it I I
would say including Robin and Blitz it
has to be over 100 times and if we
include rapid uh online uh rapid and
Blitz chess I don't even know but you
know he's he's a little bit uh annoying
than me oh sorry I wasn't going to say
that he's a little bit younger than me
so we started playing at a young age and
uh you know we've been playing since I
don't know uh more than 10 years for
sure a lot of games okay well Bishop
comes to A6 in something you see every
day the bishop was on his feet and keto
Square it pins the Knight and I guess he
was that worried about Knight C4 to E5
and a knight landing on the C6 Square so
he pins it in advance that means the The
Rook on C1 doesn't get the open line but
Fabi I feel like white can make Rook
after D1 that's a normal move another
idea that comes to mind is Pawn to A4
and Knight to B5 just saying you pin one
night I'm gonna block your Bishop with
the other yeah those were exactly the
tunes I had in mind in some order or
another I think they'll be played I
would say you play Rook after D1 first
because you know it's always going to be
useful and A4 may not always be useful
but A4 and 9b5 is a is a crucial idea
because if black takes then white gains
advantage of the bishop pair and also
the pawn on B5 could create an outpost
on C6 so Rook fd1 where is the queen
going to move C7 feels a bit vulnerable
he does it this highlights another point
of Bishop A6 that the Knight can't move
to create a discovery anymore because of
the pin A6 to E2 of the queen is hanging
so will he play A4 here I think it's
very likely A4 with the idea of Knight
B5 and then that Queen is still in
trouble because there's Bishop to E5
coming oh if it goes to B8 it's still in
the in the vulnerable place you know
like A4 Knight B5 and Bishop B5 where is
it gonna go it doesn't want to go to A8
so you still have to solve the issue of
that Queen yeah the queen is a long-term
issue for black because there are no
safe squares as Fabian is pointing out
so this is not a great position for
Niche but he's going to hope that Neil
makes that one mistake because that's
all it takes in these positions if you
make one slight inaccuracy it goes from
better for white to equal yeah this is
this is a position of very small margins
on the other hand once it gets
unpleasant it can get really unpleasant
I am somewhat wondering about the move
A4 Knights G5 because you would love to
get rid of that Bishop but I I have a
feeling there is a tactical issue with
it
uh it might actually not even be a big
tactical issue it might just be that the
bishop can safely go to C6 but then
there's some E5
stuff like some Tactics get uh get
started here so there's some calculation
in play I think Knight G5 might be an
idea but it might not work tactically
because specifically here white has this
beautiful move Bishop to B5 and save is
a piece right because the Knight on D4
was under attack if that Knight moved
from D4 the C6 Bishop was loose so
Bishop B5 Bishop's drag in the wrong
direction Bishop B5 will attack the
bishop on A6 so it either has to take
and if it does take incomes at night
from D4 so that's actually a nice
tactical sequence that allows wet to get
away with it and the move that was just
played in the game was a four so A4
played by nihal son he wants Knight to
B5 I'm gonna be honest Bobby this is
starting to look really really good for
him yeah I think maybe Queen C7 was a
mistake because that Queen if it were on
E8
it couldn't have been attacked by
anything it's not a great place for the
queen it's kind of gets in the way of
all the other pieces so it's very
natural that Anish didn't want to put it
there on the other hand at least you're
not going to like potentially lose your
queen or get it trapped in the corner or
something or have to move it around five
times and waste all your Tempe while
here where does that queen go I mean 895
is coming pretty much it no matter what
I mean unless black like makes some sort
of threat and then Bishop to E5 is
always an idea I'm wondering if you can
like try Queen C5 here it looks scary
and crazy to do so but it's based on
this tactic that have Bishop to A3 then
you have either Bishop C4 or queen takes
A3 and the Queen on E2 is in the way of
all these tactics that's why it doesn't
work for white so specifically here okay
Queen C5 might be a viable option we'll
see if that is indeed played by Anish
curious he spends his time but the
second game of the round here is about
to get underway that's the other matchup
between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
and let's check out those opening moves
Fabi we have the insights between these
two players Wesley the slightly more
accurate in fewer games but Hikaru
Nakamura when it's down to the end game
that's when he thrives yeah from what I
know about Wesley and his accuracy is
that it is among the top of players in
the world
so so he has that but accuracy doesn't
always mean that you win games because
you can be very accurate and then at the
critical moment uh you make a mistake
and sometimes some moves are more
valuable than others so Hikaru does have
the factor that when it gets low on time
he is arguably the best player in the
world with seconds on the clock it's
hard to match with Hikaru okay well
that's why Wesley so would like to make
the most of the time control 15 minutes
to start with for each player does not
want to have under 10 seconds of
scramble but we have a an ante Berlin
from Wesley so it feels like these
players have a similar opening
repertoire we just saw this what's going
on
um did they make a mistake did uh they
get the same cousin no you see a car
left it's because Wesley has a similar
repertoire to a car and that sometimes
happens yeah they both play the Berlin
they're both very staunch supporters of
the opening and I think that is Suits
their style because they like to get a
stable position and then play a long
game where their strength really shines
through and I remember there were there
were days when he car was playing the
night or and of course he is a very
sharp player it would seem like the
Knight Earth would really appeal to him
but he was having some theoretical
problems and in the Berlin you don't
really get those theoretical problems
because it's very hard to break through
no matter who you are if you have the
best preparation in the world you can't
really put a dent in this opening so
that's why both these players feel so
comfortable in it I'm a bit surprised
though that they're both butting their
head into it with white pieces because
you'd feel like there are better chances
to prove an advantage elsewhere but
don't you feel like when you as with the
black pieces you play the same thing
that your opponents play against you
isn't there an onus on Wesley to some
extent to be like I need to change my
move because uh Hikaru just you know
that position didn't looks good so good
for white so maybe I have to choose
something else it's just weird to repeat
a game we just saw I think it's purely
coincidence I think that they both
prepared this with the white pieces and
they can't change their game game plan
now so Wesley you know he faced it he
probably didn't expect to face it in the
first game but then he had already
prepared to play this with the white
pieces but that might actually explain
why he was so comfortable people with
black because when you prepare something
with the white pieces you know exactly
what you don't want to see your opponent
play well well finally Jeffrey Zhang we
have a feature chat from him he said he
had this against Wesley as well in the
American Cup so Wesley this might be a
tried and true weapon of his playing the
likes of Jeffrey Zhang yeah well we
already mentioned that Hikaru faces in a
huge formula like the candidates Wesley
faces in the American Cup also a huge
tournament so they both have very very
real practical experience in this line
which is maybe why they keep playing it
like if you play something and analyze
it often you feel more comfortable there
so you are inclined to repeat it uh
it'll be interesting to see if Wesley
has more success proving an advantage or
at least not getting worse compared to
how Hikaru face uh uh played when he was
playing white in the first game because
there he he just got a worse position I
mean that wasn't too inspiring maybe
Wesley can do better yeah and we see
that there's a knight on F1 so there's a
bishop on F1 and the other game this
Knight often coming to G3 maybe there
will be a bishop swap on E3 as well but
for Wesley he's ahead in the clock and I
want to know if this is gonna be a theme
of the match we're so used to Hikaru
bullying people in shorter time patrols
but Wesley's not a player who looks at
his opponent says okay you know I'm
scared of you he just plays the position
he's a very objective player would you
say that's an accurate assessment of
Wesley and how he approaches the game of
chess I actually think that from a point
of view of time expenditure he is
generally from my experience I found
that he's faster than Hikaru wow and the
early stages like he plays so so fast he
doesn't like to get into time trouble I
think kikawa doesn't mind so much
because he's so strong low on time but
most people don't like to get into time
trouble and I think Wesley's quick play
is a facet of that he's just trying to
avoid those crucial time travel moments
and the interesting thing is that in
this position he avoided H3
like Hikaru had played H3 to potentially
deal with some Bishop G4 and ig4 stuff
and now maybe that's exactly what hikar
was going to go for because H3 it is an
expenditure of time on the other hand
it's also very useful for uh defending
against potential tactics like that
right yeah and the Knight coming to G4
is one of the big Ideas here that it
attacks the pawn F2 and black can go for
that now but often this Rook just slides
up to E2 to defend this Pawn on uh F2 so
that I guess is a one move threat that
is parried and it might not be the end
of the world but you do have to look out
for those things when you have not put
your Pawn on H3 and we see Hikaru on
screen there he is laser focused on his
board maybe he's calculating this
variation with Knight G4 I feel like
that look suggests that he is looking
for concrete stuff because if you're
just going to play like Knight B to D7
or C6 or some move where you know it's
not very unusual and concrete then you
just play it you don't like look super
focused and intense it feels like he's
looking at Knight's G4 and then the
question is could Wesley play Knight to
E3 trade off pieces but then you feel
like Black's totally okay does white uh
maybe go for some kind of Bishop G5 some
crazy counter-attacking stuff those
variations might be in the player's
Minds uh as we speak right and we see C6
kicking this bishop and that move the
eval bar it started going a little bit
up in White's favor the bishop will just
play Bishop to C4 I imagine why not
scoop back a square that might allow
Bishop E6 if not for the fact this Pawn
E5 is hanging we see this time and time
again in these uh anti-berlains and
things like that where the Knight on F3
it causes black some problems because
the pawn E5 can be a little bit tender
yeah I I have to say we can't consider
C6 like a bad there's no way that it's a
terrible move because it's a position
where black can never be like massively
worse from the opening it's a
symmetrical position on the other hand
maybe it's not the most accurate move
because now also we have to consider
that Knight to G5 might come at some
moment gaining some time or putting some
pressure on F7 forcing black to go Rook
to f8 to cover that pawn so maybe you're
also chasing the bishop to a more
natural Square on the other hand if you
play like Knight B to D7 here and even
Knight G5 rook f8 and then you kick the
Knight out with H6 later how bad can it
really be for black it's a good question
so both sides they have their flaws but
the position remains solid not many
trades and we're gonna see this kind of
struggle between these two powerhouses
but let's go back to the game between
Anish giri and nihal sarin because both
of those players they are struggling
here in game two because a positional
battle the dynamic is over there on the
queen side we see that the Knight did
reach the B5 square and white is missing
a light score Bishop so it's two Bishops
for black and in return you've great
control over the queen side well now
it's just one Bishop well Annie's
probably felt like that [ __ ] 106 yeah
it's a bishop and you might think the
advantage of the two Bishops but on the
other hand it's getting under attack of
Knight C7 and if it doesn't take on B5
what is this actually doing there so he
thought I have to get rid of it now the
thing is it's very concrete if he can
consolidate somehow he might be okay on
the other other hand why does
threatening Rook to C7 that that's very
very dangerous because you might start
dropping pawns on the queen side or the
E7 pawn and the other thing is the stare
down of the Bishops E5 and G7 this is
favoring white because if black ever
wants to get rid of that active Bishop
he has to move the Knight and
potentially allow Rook infiltration like
Rook to D7 Rook C7 into the position so
this is purely concrete we might think
end games oh they're positional they're
boring no end games are always the most
concrete calculation plays a huge factor
and that's what we'll see here and this
is the most miserable type of position
you could possibly get if you're in each
Geary right Fabi because you have no
active play of your own you're sitting
here and being like 60 moves from now I
might make a draw you're never like I
have a single Iota hope to play for a
win and the position looks so good for
white well some players they love to
defend I don't know if vanish is one of
them most players don't it's it's
depressing and you only want to play for
draw on the hand if you consider a draw
as a victory if you just have that
mindset like I'm not trying to drill the
game anymore I'm trying to win in my own
way just trying to salvage the Half
Point as best I can then maybe
psychological it's easier for you like
personally I like to defend uh but I
understand most people don't like that
but I like it it feels like there's some
sort of accomplishment when you
when you save a terrible position or a
lost position and you know most people
wouldn't be able to do that and you feel
like oh I'm psychologically very strong
it it like gives you a sense of Pride oh
wow I didn't know that about you see
we've known each other for so long I
learned things with you every single day
I mean
the defending thing yeah this isn't a
very personal thing but
still it's like it's a factor of your
chest personality in a way and that's
meaningful to me but this board right
here A6 has been played that means
Knight C7 is a little baby Fork against
the rook and the pawn this Rook will
have to slap to A7 Fabi I feel like
black is putting peace on really awkward
squares and in fact if we get concrete
for a second if Knight C7 Rook A7 I'm
already looking and moves like Bishop to
D4 and what in the world is black gonna
do about these A6 and B6 pawns being
loose I have no idea because of Rook to
B8 here there's A5 and that's the real
problem you're pinned and this looks
like a disaster because how do you
defend that pawn I don't see a single
way and then you might lose that pawn
you might lose the A6 pawn and we see
like the stair off of the Bishops it
doesn't work for black because let's say
you want to play like Knight to D7
but it just doesn't work because Bishop
takes G7 and Rook takes D7 so the
tactics are not working for black hero I
would I mean he has to play Rook A7
because otherwise you just drop A6 this
is what happened The Rook came into C6
first and that also is a great move
because Rook B8 seems very difficult to
play that Bishop on E5 is ready for that
Knight to move out the way that would
just lose material Rook B is a blunder
Knight to B5 for example hits one Rook
on A7 with the Knight directly hits a
second Rook on B8 with the bishop You're
simply losing in exchange and thus
losing the game yeah I was thinking
about this position
um and after work C6 I was thinking
Black's most natural moves work to C8
but then the question to me is white
plays Rook takes B6
black takes on C7 and okay you think oh
I got the uh the two pieces but on the
other hand black white does have these
like two two pass pawns where like you
take on A6 at some moment and then you
have the two passers on the queen side
supported by Rooks I wouldn't be so uh
comfortable for black here so I wonder
after Rook C8 Rook B6 what black has to
uh to survive uh does not look good and
the EVAP Bar says that white is winning
so your assessment is correct that if
black thinks that you can just get out
of there with a couple minor pieces the
answer is no those two extra pawns for
white and we'll just run up the queen
side so I'm not looking liking the look
of any move for black in this position
and that's the real problem with three
minutes and 30 seconds and counting down
for Anish giri you know some players
like to defend I don't think anyone
enjoys defending this position no when
when you're losing you don't enjoy it at
all and I'm just trying to find like
some chances for black I
came up with like maybe Knight to EA but
I don't believe in it at all because I
think that white will simply trade on G7
and then you can go for a rook end game
I thought that was me I didn't even get
to grab the piece I guess it's played it
but I mean he's trying to like try to
try to simplify into a broken game where
you're a pawn down which looks miserable
but maybe like there's a saying all rook
and games are drawn maybe you can hope
for that that there's George tendencies
in The Rook end game but I'm even
wondering take take a knight D5 like
even with the Knights on and Knight on
E8 especially passive now also looks
extremely bad to me if B5
you think oh maybe I'm training Polo but
even A5 here just cementing the weakness
on A6 this is this is miserable no
matter what nihal does it's miserable
anisha's only hope is if I defend well
enough for long enough maybe I'll get
chances but the problem in addition to
everything you just stated is that nihal
is like five minutes ahead in the clock
so you can survive for a while and
that's all good and fun but every move
for black seems a bit difficult whereas
for white you have like four different
options that all seem good for a nihal
and after Bishop takes G7 he hasn't even
recaptured that just goes to show that
he's considering Knight takes G7 but in
comes that Rook from D1 to D7 bringing
more pieces into the game
oh gosh this looks really really sad
Rook D7 looks very nice for Rook D7 you
might think maybe Knight to E6
to like trade off because I just want to
trade off some pieces with with black
I'm just thinking I need to trade off at
all costs but then at some point you'll
end up in a rook ending with a pawn down
that's the best case scenario maybe it
even ends up being two pawns down
because let's say Rook d796
and I'm thinking like maybe just Rook
takes E7
because in Rook C8 it looks like oh
there's a pin but then there's just
Knight takes E6 well this is hilarious
that all these Rooks are staring at each
other through the night so Knight takes
E6 as you point out oh my gosh you're
not even taking the rook and I said yeah
you trade off Rooks but then white ends
up two pawns up in a rook end game and
that's just dead lost it's Checkmate
first though oh that's even worse Rook
takes Rook his Checkmate I thought Rook
takes A7 but rookie yeah I actually
didn't realize it at first either and I
was like oh you slide devil you Bobby
I've known you for a long time and you
know I wasn't even thinking that well
you don't think about Checkmate I I see
two Pawns of working game I want to make
my opponent suffer I don't even want to
give him get him off the hook for the
Checkmate nah you got to go for the
checkmated one there so uh we see Anish
giri on screen in front of us and well
it's a big moment for him he wants to
survive this game and keep his lead and
honestly if uh neon Sirens into it he's
gonna say Checkmate I couldn't lose
shout out to Mastermind because it's me
hi I'm the problem it's me so let's uh
let's see how this one develops here but
the other game well that looks actually
pretty solid in that matchup between
Wesley so and akara Nakamura we have
both games on screen in front of us
Bobby it looks like the game on the
right is on move 12 and the game on the
left is like move 35 yeah and also the
difference in evaluation I'm probably
also in the player's mental States right
now because in Niha against Anish
they're both thinking
I'm either I'm going to win or I'm going
to lose and the other game it feels like
we might see the same result I mean you
never know crazy things could happen but
two guys of this level in this type of
position playing
a position which is objectively very
very close to equal
you might expect a draw to be a natural
result but I like this move work to be
one he's showing some ambition and
expanding on the queen side the only
idea of Rook B1 is to play B4 there's no
other point of this move okay so we see
Wesley so playing the move Rook to B1
and Fabi what strikes me is he really
hasn't changed his posture he does not
want to look over at Hikaru so that is
part of his calculus in terms of match
strategy is I really believe he does not
want to take a single glance over at him
yeah I don't know if that's a
psychological thing or he just wants to
be honed in on the position because
Wesley is also a player who he famously
was writing notes of like inspiration
during a game because he he needs to
like pump himself up in some way some
players do with music maybe he does it
by like laser focusing in on the
position and we see him trying to block
out with his hand all outside
distraction so that might be the case
here yeah you can even say he's a razor
focused over here staring into the
screen trying to find the best move and
it's a position where there are so many
different candid choices where not much
has really happened to this point
typical rerouting of pieces from the
queen side over to the king side that
Knight on G3 in particular and this
Knight on G3 I have to call you out on
this one that was a terrible pun what do
you mean we appreciate terrible puns but
that was an absolutely terrible pun okay
one second first of all I have the host
seat here I'm about to kick you out of
here I'm gonna send you back I don't
know if you can do that yeah I can I
really can't you have too much control
over here I'm sorry my apologies Dania
and I have been hanging out so sometimes
the puns they stumble in but this F5
square a knight would love to jump right
into there and then go for a king-site
attack the bishop UNC one staring at the
H6 Pawn as well so I feel like Fabi in
this type of position Hikaru will likely
bring his Bishop from C5 back to f8 at
some point and then that night on B8 May
land on C5 and just like we're talking
about the C5 Square in game one in game
two that can be very useful for a black
knight you know I noticed some sort of
correlation between the good and bad
Bishops in the first game we saw that
Wesley uh with the black pieces had the
good Bishop uh because of the pawn
structure right that there was that
Knight on C5 that was cemented the pawns
on A40 for a week but here we have the
opposite white has the the dark Square
Bishop which means that the pawn is on
A5 and E5 are a bit weaker than the
pawns on A4 and E4 so we see some kind
of uh slight reversal in the games but
again Wesley is on the side of having
the slightly better Bishop here I don't
think it matters so much because black
has perfectly placed pieces and with B5
he's showing his intention to trade off
the potential weaknesses on B A5 just
simplify all the pawns off get into a
garage position yeah I think what you
just said drawish position these two are
so evenly matched and yes West had a
better position game one but it was
never that much right it was a press
like he can try to get go for more
playing for two results either a card
defends well it's a draw or somehow
Wesley wins feels like this game nothing
and both players have been impressive
with the black pieces you never know it
might get crazy at some moment
especially in these fast time patrols
when the players are getting low on time
but at the moment it is looking like
it's heading towards a piece will result
and I'm not too surprised the start of
the match is peaceful these players are
feeling each other out they're trying to
find some small weaknesses in the
repertoire some chinks in the armor but
there aren't many chinks in the armor
these are these are very well-rounded
guys so we're seeing relatively stable
play from both of them but at some point
they're going to have to to take some
chances to get to get chances well chaos
is not among us right now in this game
but in the other game between nihal
sarin and Anish giri it's Anish giri in
huge time travel he is down under a
minute on the clock neon still nearly
four minutes for him with the white
pieces with the advantage so this game I
think it could almost determine the
match if nihal does not win this
position he'll be kicking himself it's
hard to recover psychologically
especially when you're playing a niche
Geary so here Fabi 55 seconds are left
for a niche and he didn't take the I
thought Rook takes B6 give me a free
Pawn he's kicking this Knight around the
Knight goes to a more sturdy Square on
D6 and then they'll take on B6 but well
I think it might be something a bit
different I think his idea with G4 is
after 96 maybe there's Knight D5 and
then besides the option of taking on B6
there's also Knight takes E7 Rook to D6
trying to get into a rook end game so
you win that King Side Pawn and then you
try to go for the queen side pawns
because they're always going to be weak
you can take that pawn on B6 or you can
leave it as a weakness for later for
example here black plays B5 thinking oh
I'm getting out of it maybe there's A5
but maybe just for Knight takes E7 hmm
rookie seven Rook D6 and the pawn A6 is
still weakness white has more active
Rooks on top of having the extra Pawn so
Anish is just trying to keep the knight
in the game Thinking okay at least with
Knight I have some practical chances
nicer tricky pieces
at least in like in a rook end game you
just think okay this is a clinical
technical Victory that's what Anish is
trying to avoid okay and for Anish who's
had no plans for the last like 15 moves
all of a sudden I feel like F5 is
something that comes to mind you have a
knight on e4 there's a tender Pawn on F2
that Rook would like to open up on the f
file and if F5 has played the right
moment and some pawns are traded I feel
like Suddenly at least has a plan yeah
that's the downside of G4 that you're
giving a hook for black to create some
counter play on the king side and he
immediately goes for it Anish knows that
he's not gonna I mean he's an
experienced player he's not gonna get
many chances to save a lost position so
he sees like a slight chance with the
pawn G4 upon an F5 some opening of the
king side and this is again when you
have a bad position you just want to
like find your chances even if they
don't exist you're like looking for best
case scenarios so Anish is trying to
look for a best case scenario of well
maybe someday I'll take a Pawn on the
king side that's his hope and that's the
only way that you keep your optimism in
defending a bad position and I think
here for nihal sarin Rook C is the move
I was suggest it protects F2 by trading
off some of the pieces the rookon A7
quite passive and that Rook can't really
go anywhere because if it does the A6
Pawn will be loose it goes to B7 but A5
protects the knife Bobby I feel like one
move threats from black and nehal is
just protecting everything and now he's
actually improving his chances over
there on the queen side actually I don't
like this move Rook B7 but when you're
so low in time and defending a bad
position it's hard to criticize
decisions but this just gives nihal an
easy way to play A5 and then you know
one second oh my gosh sorry and he's
just barely getting he's not gonna run
out of time I I know Anish he's actually
a good bull player he doesn't run out of
time but the time is not even the
biggest problem it's the position here
like he can take and play Rook CA Rook
A8 and Corral that pawn A6
nothing is looking good for on this year
okay but H5 he's at least just you know
creating some small ideas of course
nihouse aren't in complete control this
game with proper play should be a win
for white but the downside is with some
of these trades you might have enough
pieces remaining enough Pawns in
particular so black could think about
sacrificing his Knight for a couple
pawns and trying to make a draw it's not
completely out of the question even if
unlikely I think the problem here is
that his Rook on B7 is so passive
that like it can't go anywhere at the
moment and it can't even go to B8
because there would be some like forks
and stuff maybe he has to move his
e-pawn to get it out of the way but I
just don't see it like Rook to A8 is
coming at some point he is going to take
that pawn on A6 okay he tries to spend
against it but you're just so passive
here it's not just that you're down
material but you can't you're just
trying to like hold things together and
that pawn H5 I don't see it as a
strength that pawn is falling off in the
near future okay so white in complete
control 3.6 seconds excuse me left for
Anish giri and The Rook on A7 does
defend A6 now we're told when up
material trade but the move Rook to A8
here I wonder if that's actually a good
move because after the swap of Rooks
maybe there are not enough P's remaining
maybe this King can just Venture right
over to the queen side it's a risky
decision that's why Nihao sarin is
calculating it he's not just gonna
Intuit it I think you make this move
when you realize that Knight to C7 is an
Unstoppable threat and after that you
you could see that Knight C7 A6 and once
your two pawns up that's that secures a
one Pawn sometimes it's not enough adish
is like nearly running out of time with
every move but he's somehow getting the
moves off just in time
unfortunately as you said the position
is not good he goes Knight D7 this Pawn
can just be captured on H4 give me that
you take on B6 you give me a pass pawn
two extra pawns one over there on the
queen side one towards the center the
black rook and king can't deal with them
both I don't think he'll take the ball I
think he'll play 97 and Rook C6 because
it feels like a little bit more
technical because then black has to like
passively defend that A6 Pawn or trade
off more pawns and end up in even more
hopeless position but regardless white
has many many wins here and I think
nihal has this in the back there is
almost no way that he lets this one slip
well 3.7 seconds and a bad position for
Anish giri not the way he wanted to have
game two go after and really wonderful
win in game one so
I mean okay there's really not much life
left in it but 40 seconds counting down
and that's what mistakes happen we know
how good nehal is in time trouble but
he's spending all of his time you get a
little bit nervous that he doesn't see
the concrete win the direct way to
promote a pawn and now he's burning too
much Glock I think this is a case of so
many good ways to win that you have this
like problem of choice
and some players are just very good at
okay everything's windy I'll just pick
one I won't even think about what's more
accurate and that's probably the right
strategy but some players are
perfectionist they want to find the
absolute most clinical way to win and
that can lead you a bit astray he's
getting a lot of time but still I
believe that nihal is just such a good
ball player and he has such a winning
position but look at this King F6 Rook
G7 check all of a sudden at least Anish
has some squares first pieces something
to attack and I know the evaluation bar
is through the roof but both sides in
time travel this is the best chance
Anish has had in a long time I have to
say at least his work is active that
Rook was passive the whole game at least
it's on H3 rookie three rookie four
ideas are in the air but look at this
though Knights come to C5 protecting
everything that that is super accurate
now you can just play F take Z5 you
can't even take that pawn back because
rookie six you're gonna be four puns up
it's four pawns as long as he doesn't
blunder a rook here King D3 would
blunder it that's why the king went back
the king went up Knight takes E5 would
have been a fork but now A6 Falls and
there's nothing that Anish gear can do
he brings his Knight in hoping for some
checks now watch out because there are
some drawing mechanisms but I don't
think he has it in this position not in
this position
but there are sometimes there is this
Perpetual the night checking going back
but yeah the king can escape I think it
could escape to either side so Anish
just elects to grab a pawn instead still
pawns are getting a bit more limited
there might be some hope if he wins if
he wins another Pawn there's some hope
but it's gonna be hard at least white
king is in a slightly vulnerable place
where it's open to checks so you never
know oh and he can't go to the queen
side because I want to see one to be
Rook C2 check the king's in the corner
now and he goes Rook A7 a7's over that
pawn is provoked okay six that's it
takes game two here and each Geary just
trying to find the resignation button
there it is and nihal yeah the little
head nod he ties it up yeah that was
that was super impressive I mean such a
clean game getting almost nothing from
the opening but a little bit of
Advantage echoing exactly what Anya said
that somehow these young players they're
very good at finding chances in in the
opening like some players think oh Anish
he's so he's like a solid rock in the
opening you can't find a chick in his
armor but nihal just finds a playable
position and accurately increases his
Advantage it's a great win a great
comeback that was a wonderful game from
the All-Star we were staying at the
opening not much there anishkiri had
under control but he made small
improvements gain some squares for his
pieces he earns that Victory he
definitely didn't just win by accident
that was a nice game from Neil sorry but
we do have one more game going on it is
Hikaru Nakamura versus Wesley so and
this game again slightly better for
black but not too many pieces but
there's a bit more life in the position
at least there's some Intrigue left uh
like there is some imbalance you know uh
bishop and Knight against two knights
you could say maybe the bishop is a
slightly stronger piece in open
positions of course I would say Wesley
is not the type of player who will lose
this position but against some people
Hikaru would be getting optimistic right
but against Wesley as you're saying too
strong of an opponent Knight takes E4
that is a pawn that is hanging right now
but direct calculation shows that white
will regain it right back Knight takes
E4 Knight takes E4 Queen takes E4 thank
you very much but after the move Rook to
E1 you hit the queen you hit the pawn
behind it you have a knight on F3 and
that just trades off a bunch of material
so I feel like in this game wouldn't be
too surprised if we see them just make
those series of liquidating moves I
think Hikaru is going to keep a bit of
tension yeah because he he can't be
worse here and I don't think that Wesley
is going to be ambitious here so Wesley
will be a bit happier to make a draw
Hikaru realizes that he they both
understand the psychology of how it
works
um Wesley getting a slightly worse
position he'll start to see maybe some
ghosts of course he'll still I think
solidly uh defend a position without
making any mistakes but I don't think
that hikar will just go straight for the
draw I think he'll want to play this a
little bit okay we see his eyes dying oh
but there that is that look is like I
don't really have everything I want and
hey Fabi can you just answer this
question I think Chad wants to know who
is right you were right Robert oh my
gosh that feels so good wow well Hikaru
Nakamura he'll feel good about this draw
in game two with the black pieces I know
he may look disappointed but it's mostly
that there's not more life in the
position no that this is hikaru's faces
for the most part are an act oh yeah I
think so I mean he has he has a bit of
Showmanship uh especially
as he's known as one of the best chess
presenters in the world so there's a bit
of Showmanship involved I don't think
he's disappointed because I mean he
never had anything with black really and
it's a solid draw with black pieces you
can't be upset it's not easy to draw
these guys with black like we just saw
that
um in the game with nihal and Anish that
they put some pressure on they increase
the pressure
uh you start to get in trouble so he's
definitely not disappointed but there is
that element of oh I was a bit better so
I'm disappointed okay well in this
position we see the queen slide over to
C7 protecting the bishop on C5 keeping
an eye on that Rook on E5 and the issue
is there aren't too many pawns remaining
no weaknesses to go after and both
players are keeping their pieces
defended the pawn on B5 is eyed by the
queen on E2 and The Rook on E5 but I
think that we might just see pawns get
traded on the queen side there is a way
for black to get in trouble here oh yeah
it's it's very difficult and it will
never happen but if black plays the
natural moved B4 which is a fine move
okay white plays Rook to E8 yes and if
black takes which is natural and it's
also okay and if black plays one more
natural move King okay it didn't happen
but there were some ways for black to
get in trouble but Bishop they draw and
that's exactly what we expected don't
worry you'll never get in trouble for
talking chess but these two players they
have no distance between them no
separation can be found in this matchup
slight advantage for Wesleyan game one
hit car in game two but we have two
draws the players walk away from the
playing Hall get a little rest but one
to one Fabian now you said you kind of
expected this these two players so
strong so accustomed with each other's
style that an even match feels about
right yeah this is a slug Festa it's
sort of what we expected that these guys
are evenly matched and they might take
it slow and wait until the games get
really crucial and You Know Anything
Could Happen uh in the final games we
might even see an Armageddon potentially
because these players are so evenly
matched but at the start it's it's going
slow this is like a train that's picking
up speed yes and well for a car Nakamura
he is the speed demon he's won himself
enough speed Chess Championship so as we
look at the overall picture here with
both matches in sight we have tied
matches and both but very different
matches Fabi because for Wesley and
hikar were just saying just locked
positions even throughout but the other
matchup what do you make of it
yeah I think we're seeing the same
result but very very different ways of
getting there and there's going to be
more emotions in the Anish against nihal
match I think more positive emotions for
nihal because when you it's the same
thing win one lose one but the order
matters once you come back you feel a
little bit happier about the result he
should be feeling great about his chest
as well because this was the position we
were saying that this might have been
one of the biggest mistakes even though
it looks like nothing when Anish giri
brought his Queen to C7 Bobby you're
saying maybe Queen E8 staying out of
trouble was better yeah I think that was
a costly mistake it looks like he was
happy to use that pin on the Knight but
he didn't consider that the queen even
though it looks like it's getting away
from the the danger it's always in the
danger zone it has to stay on E8 even
though it's a passive place it's not
it's not what you want to do but
sometimes you have to do what you what
you don't want to but a less informed
player and frankly a player not as
strong as Neo would not have maximized
the potential this position but look at
this A4 Knight B5 all of these useful
moves and he kept his pieces going
forward you predicted something might
happen but even giving up the bishop
pair wouldn't seems so easy to do but
when we got here again nihal doesn't
just make the obvious looking move let
me go Knight C7 Fork your rook and
Bishop but the problem here was that the
bishop takes Knight takes there is
Bishop takes B3 at the very least black
takes a bunch of pawns for that exchange
so I love the restraint shown by nihal
yeah Knight seat A3 is super impressive
move probably the move of the game from
his point of view moving the game
because it looks unspectacular but this
is how you have to beat uh top players
you have to not make the obvious move
sometimes and this is a move which shows
it looks like the Knight is going to to
the rim and we say Knight's on the rim
are dim but sometimes they have a future
and here here he saw that the Knight
would have a very bright future it ended
up plaguing all of Black's pawns every
single one of them and you wouldn't have
expected that future from a knight
that's currently on A3 but yeah he had
the foresight for that well the Knight
recaptured the bishop the Knight jumped
into C7 and you're correct that this
Knight was causing black all the
problems and I just love the way he
continued this here he was thinking
spending time and at this moment he he
could just take on B6 a lot of us would
have done that's a free Pawn but you
said G4 was a really useful move for him
yeah he showed that he's not rushing and
there's nothing wrong with Rook takes B6
but sometimes making the less obvious
move it also has a another impact it
makes your opponent think more and
you're surprising them that that is a
psychological effect and it did in this
game because Knight D6 and once more
Rook takes B6 please take that pawn it's
actually good for white but Knight to D5
because your B6 Pawn still hanging and
as your point out Knight takes E7 check
it might lead to liquidation and an
easier win so as the game continued here
and good try by a niche but trades
everywhere and nihal didn't rush his
decisions he ended up scooping up all of
Black's Pawn just to show you where that
happened this decision one last one that
was important was at this moment Knight
D7 to C5 attacking E6 attacking A6 and
protecting E4 against the one threat
rookie three that was that a few moves
later Neil sarin won and he tied up this
match with Fabi just great technique
yeah he showed also that he's not afraid
to get low on time that's not even in
the timetable phase but there's a
pre-time trouble phase which causes some
people to panic and to make mistakes
just make like fastest decisions to
avoid getting into time trouble and
their play suffers but nihal doesn't
have that it looked like he was allowing
some counterplay but he saw that it was
all a mirage there was never any danger
for him to miss out on the win he just
swept up all of Black's pawns uh
collected everything and took home the
win well he may be young but he has the
experience of a veteran at this point
playing online all the time and the
match is Young so the only two games in
the books it is halftime at four games
played today so we'll send it over to
you Danny and the Gang thank you Robert
you didn't see my heart okay anyway uh
guys can you feel it this is we are
getting wild here at the chess.com
Global Championship semifinals amazing
amazing chefs amazing commentary this
has been awesome here with me Amon
Hamilton Danny wrench James Canty and
Daniel narodinsky we we got a lot to
dive into here guys it's two games are
in the books Let's show the scores and
where we stand like Fabi and Robert said
both matches knotted up at one game a
piece but two very different feels to
those matches right now Anish Geary wins
first Nihao sarin Strikes Back in a game
as good as the one Anish played first
with white Wesley and Hikaru both
deadlocked right now neither player
wanting to give an inch despite here
Carter giving us some great facial
expressions I agree with Bobby that I
think akara was pretty happy drawing
easily with black so all right
let's talk about it let's dive into that
actually dive into the Hikaru Nakamura
facial expressions as the world's
leading expert in that Amman I know
you're also pretty used to reading
hikaru's facial expressions I think he
was pretty happy with that game that he
drew there and he should be uh you know
the interesting thing is that game kind
of started the exact same way that the
other game started so there's that not
at the beginning where it's kind of like
okay you want to show me how to play
that opening yeah interesting we'll see
buddy yeah um so there's a little bit of
competition there at the start but
ultimately I think uh this match has
been level half half there hasn't been a
lot between them this is the coin flip
match that I think at least myself and
you know all of us anticipated Daniel
Fabi said that the order matters right
he was referring to Gary and Sauron but
I think even in the Nakamura so match
the order matters probably Hikaru
feeling a little bit better about an
easy draw with black than maybe so is
about the white game he just played yeah
this match has kind of been like taking
a sip of lemon flavored fresh water you
know might not taste particularly
intense you know the games might not
have been all that riveting but they
have been evenly matched the games have
been very clean and I think this is all
building up to an absolutely fascinating
finale to address your point though
Danny for sure hikara sort of stays the
course plays the Berlin with black
Wesley was playing that meta game hey
let me show you how the Berlin is done
yeah and Hikaru one could argue had the
same situation Wesley had in the first
game we're all knotted up totally fair
score can't wait for game three no candy
I know Berlin makes you fall asleep
yeah your thoughts in the battle right
now deadlock which means so I mean
Berlin is definitely boring and it will
put you to sleep here but
um at the same time these boys are at a
neck and neck it's uh if you breathe
wrong and if you think wrong if you do
anything wrong oh you lose in this game
like this this whole match is very
locked and you know one point right so
honestly accuracy is high from both
players and we just got to see more
chess really I think Hikaru may be like
ready you know to pounce this next one
because of his facial expressions and
you know I this oh my goodness you know
that's how he is right so yeah right so
probably he'll probably be ready for
another expert on the face yeah I was
going to say that was I was adding some
some sounds to the conversations well
I'm curious what a car will do with with
the white pieces he gets the first move
for the second time will we see another
Berlin or does Hikaru show that he's the
first one willing to Blink and take this
match a different direction I'm gonna
make a prediction I'm going to predict
one Knight F3 and I think akara will
revert back to what he's played in the
RCC religiously and has brought him a
lot of success I'm just going to throw
out my prediction say he's gonna play
Knight F3 and B3 the prophet is spoken
you like that particular I like that
prediction but I'm gonna go the other
order just like these matches are
knotted up one to one in different ways
I'm gonna go B3 first now we're now
we're playing move prediction all right
B3 you know I'm gonna go Knight F3 B3
right in that order I'm gonna say you're
also yeah you should have another Berlin
keep track out there all right Danny's
gonna be right let's move on to the
other match now that we've made our
impromptu move predictions and talk
about Nihao Soren's comeback Victory
here over Anish giri Geary plays
fantastic with white Zarin says anything
you can do I can do better even at the
age of 18. we're deadlocked what do you
think about nihal's performance staying
cool Under Pressure showing he is wiser
than his youth your thoughts done well
beating anishagiri is tremendously
impressive period the way he did it
making Jose capoblanca proud just a
clean crisp positional game making it
look easy winning like a .4 end game
against you know one of the best
defenders players of all time we take
that kind of stuff for granted there was
no point in chess history at which like
an 18 year old Grandmaster could do that
with such regularity that was a
phenomenal game
by any Hall it should be studied by
anybody who wants to improve their
positional understanding their end game
technique and you know I'm so so excited
to see which direction this match is
going to go I can make a case for for
both players taking the upper hand in
the next round candy I know you keep
talking about that Indian water you're
trying to get me you know I feel them
I got the D3 I got the creatine and then
I need some Indian water as well
straight from India whatever they're
drinking over there we need that because
of course Sauron been sparring you know
what I'm saying like he's been really
out here sparring ducking and weaving
and then hitting right and he's playing
some good chess the kid is actually
really strong as we see taking down uh
Gary and he's like yo I'm coming for you
big dog I'm coming well your thoughts on
sarn well Danny the way I see it is is
not that this was a comeback like I know
it looks like that he's down one game
but I think of it more like a tennis
match like it was just his time to serve
if you know in tennis you can you can be
down a game sometimes you even have
those weird break points where it looks
like you're behind but I just feel like
he was waiting for the white pieces his
game with the white pieces was just as
nice as giri's was these guys are both
playing at the top of their games so I
just feel like it was like just waiting
for the white pieces like okay now it's
my turn and the technique that he
displayed was incredible well done yeah
the Gary holds serve as well I think
yeah I think it's likely that he is I
think we're gonna see a lot of white
victories uh in this match and I totally
agree with them on I don't even think
the players are thinking of it that way
or that nihal was panicking after game
one five you made this point at the
start it's a two-day Affair it's an
eight game match yeah the players aren't
necessarily too broken up over one loss
I think when the lead gets to two points
that's when we start talking about like
a potential comeback one point is is
nothing to these guys absolutely one
point is nothing I mean Gary can
stabilize and come back there there was
a hard hit from from star and air and
like you said a 0.4 position which is
like really not a lot you know he was
slightly better from there but I think
Geary now switching colors here has a
strike back you need to strike fast and
harder all right well as we move into
the weekend we're going to have a lot of
action but we've been here all week
we've been enjoying our time in Toronto
really when our eight players got into
town we thought it might be fun to test
their knowledge little Canadian pop
culture here's Nemo and our cgc players
with our Canadian IQ test
are you ready for the trivia questions
no but let's do it anyway who is the
current prime minister of Canada the
current prime minister is of course
Justin Trudeau perfect I didn't have to
run through them all
okay
okay I'm done which of these is
Toronto's hockey team or if you already
know you can just let us it's I mean of
course it's the Maple Leafs thank you
okay I think because there are two Maple
things I'm going to go with the maple
one that's how I passed my final School
exam as well Maple Leaves correct who is
Canada's top rated chess player
Alexandra
well unfortunately I played him last
week so I know the answer it's of course
of getting bereave I'm not sure about
wherever I think to be honest so no one
is getting younger and oh okay I also
he's not as good as he used to be so
um but um I guess I didn't have some
let's go with Eric which of these
celebrities is not Canadian so I knew
the first two are Canadian so it must be
dangerous but you see a celebrity though
why well I would like chill between
Dragons Demons like I can't see any of
them being Canadian to be honest and
then maybe they're both Drake is
actually like the icon of Toronto this
is a trick question I'll go with
everybody
obviously it's uh Danny Ranch but I
think his singing skills are someone
behind the other contestants
so that's okay okay you know
thank you
you know first of all anisha's never
really heard me sing right so I take
offense to that you don't know you don't
know what's coming out of these fights
but I mean to me the biggest takeaway of
that was when they listed highest rated
players from Canada our boy here made
the list okay just happy to be
considered yeah yeah I got a ballot
that's all I know it was awesome I was
also impressed with both Hikaru and
Anish just pulling Justin Trudeau out of
thin air would you have gotten that
Dania I I would have gotten that but you
know I'm like a geography type nerd so I
like useless trivia I watch Jeopardy you
know guilty but if Jenny Beret if that
was a hard one that was Eric hey Colleen
Eric and you've got you very very
similarly rated I was impressed can't do
you having a great time here in Toronto
and how would you have done on that on
that little I would have did gray and
then on the um celebrity one um I would
I would have felt you know pretty bad
actually when he said you know did Danny
celebrity almost you know walked up to
him like hey man don't don't do that I
appreciate that but you know I told him
offline I don't think you know I knew
you had my back I know you were in the
room yeah we talked offline you know
yeah I handled it for you bro I'm on uh
honestly I was just impressed uh with
how well people with it I think people
kind of knew their stuff and they
weren't thrown off by a really close
trick answer Iman Hamilton yeah could
have easily been I feel good this is
like you welcomed us to your home yeah
and you've made some great restaurant
recommendations by the way shout out
Amman he really has so but do you feel
like good about how people are
delivering and appreciating the Canadian
trivia I do and and you know what I do
get the feeling I've watched like some
interviews from the players and just
chatting around outside I do get the
genuine feeling that people like it here
and they all have like a little
something that they enjoy whether it's
the food or the tournament organization
everything so we'll talk a little bit
about that this is this is I think the
biggest prize money any Chesterman has
ever had on Canadian soil first time
we've had a super tournament like this
in Canada in a very very long time what
does that mean to you is you know you're
the Homegrown Canadian Toronto Toronto
boy I mean how exciting and how how
meaningful is that to have an event like
this here in in Toronto well Danny it's
actually the first tournament ever in
Canada
great to have everyone here
but it's it's nice to have Tournament of
this caliber and of course I hope that
this sort of sets the precedent going
forward that there's more of these and
that you know the production here is is
insane actually like it's really fun to
be a part of and I just hope that this
lets everybody else know that hey you
gotta up your game because this is the
standard now I love it well have any
other waiters challenged you no no
waiters uh but I was at the gym and like
uh one guy wanted to challenge me to
some pull-ups right and that guy was
Danny
I did not want to challenge you man you
smoke I I literally can't move working
out with you it's been crazy there was a
guy who walked up to us today and
recognized Levy oh yeah right we're just
working out some dude comes up like are
you Levy Rosman yeah yeah that happened
he did not he didn't he did not
recognize that's the only serious common
aging kind of well I can't take this guy
anywhere but all right we got to get to
a break but before we do a quick
reminder the SEC is back with these
confirmed 14 players if you missed the
news yesterday the main event begins
November 21st participants including
that guy right there the world champion
Magnus Carlson I was asked out there by
a reporter shout out to cigar shop from
chess face India asan is here he said
whether we think Arjun era guy C and
Nihao Sauron these and gurukash are
these guys gonna have their time this
year and beat the guns like Jana
plumnushy and Hikaru Nakamura we don't
know we also know though there will be
two other qualifiers who will earn their
way into the tournament with a hundred
thousand dollars on the line don't miss
it it's the most exciting speed Chess
Championship we've ever held to date
type command SCC in the chat for more
all right everybody much more to come
from day one of the cgc semifinals as we
push towards game threes and each of our
semi-final matchups twitch subscribers
we have plenty of content coming your
way don't go anywhere during the break
you don't want to miss it
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we're here at the chess.com Global
championship in Belgrade with
Grandmaster nihal sarin the only player
from Belgrade to advance now every
player in belgrad went into today with a
minus score how were you able to make
the comeback today I'm very happy that I
managed to make a comeback and
of course I was not expecting it to
finish in the rapid games at least the
first game game five was the key game
because you were worse and then you were
worse and then it turned around all at
once how did that happen the game
changed when he played D5 sort of
expected him to do that and I was quite
unhappy to see D5 I found a very strong
move Queen takes D5 Bishop G6 and queen
B7 then Sam blundered this queen Beyond
Queen B5 I think and yeah that was a
massive boost for me and in the final
game obviously he had to go for
everything and he played the tiger
modern were you thinking that was
anywhere on the radar modern is always
something to expect well
somebody needs to win on Demand with
black and okay I was already very happy
to get to the final game with the one
point lead after that seven games I'm
sure you'll take any opening at that
point finally uh what will you do to
prepare for your next match
it's a new day new match and just start
from zero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
all right let's get it let's go
okay
I haven't seen that one before actually
so it's a very strange move
don't forget to look out your windows
wow totally totally totally not a
distraction
wow look at the view here I am way off
the ground right now
yeah this wasn't bad
[Music]
oh that's a good move yeah goodbye dear
Bishop who won
can we watch the balls yeah sure yes
yay
all right we're at Landing wow that was
incredible that was super cool that was
incredible
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
in Vancouver crazy but as fond as I am
of that place it's pretty tough not to
fall in love with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess in clubs in
universities and public parks and even
in hot tubs with amaranth for well over
a century yeah I don't think that's what
the script said
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks four of the
world's best players have survived to
continue their quest for the Queen's
sized ship of the one million dollar
prize pool
that ends it officially I think that's
it resigns oh my goodness what an
Armageddon we just had
mama
you're in the right place it's time for
the cgc finals Toronto Canada officially
has it all
oh
welcome back to Toronto and our coverage
of the cgc semi-finals it's been an
amazing day so far as we see Anish giri
getting ready for game three against
nihal sarin oh my God we've got so much
action to review because both matches
between Geary Andy Hall as well as
between Wesley and hikarnakamura are all
knotted up at one a piece through two
games okay I'm Grandmaster Daniel
naritzki here alongside International
Master Levy Rosman once again can't wait
to bring the two games that remain today
to you Levy how are you doing how are
you feeling are you excited I'm super
excited I went out and got some really
fancy dress shoes today because we had
to up our level from yesterday and I
realized that you can't even see my
shoes so you're gonna have to wait until
tomorrow or check social media these
matches are so close and in such
different ways I'm so pumped for the
afternoon I'm incredibly pumped as well
and it's not a surprise that the matches
are tied we are waiting for Anish giri
and nihal sarin to start their match
both players winning one game and
yeehawk coming back from that one point
deficit anyhal star and we have been
saying that name so many times Levy and
for very good reason as we review his
bio I am most mesmerized just by the
path that he took to Toronto he'd be
kramnik EB dingley ran Ralph Mama that
guy has won a couple games in
tournaments in his life Levy Rosman this
kid is a Phenom yeah he's amazing and we
watched him beat Savion in the way we
thought that he would it's just amazing
defensive prowess but that's not how he
started this match against Geary in the
first game he was blown off the board
which something that we thought about
potentially happening and then he struck
back right away let's see what happens
here let's see what happens the game is
under underway fasten your speed balls
whoa they better be fast and tight
because we have Knight C6 and D6 wow
channeling Magnus Carlson against Anton
Smirnoff at the Olympiad yes this is a
really interesting move order because
essentially nehal sarin is playing a
pierce defense that's what he's doing
right but why didn't he just go D6 on
the first move because there are more
aggressive setups for white so he move
orders Anish giri into What's called the
classical setup which is very stable for
white not super aggressive and when you
say the word classical what you mean is
that the F Pawn is no longer capable of
moving out to F4 that is the Austrian
attack and that is considered one of the
most dangerous systems against the perk
but here we see the downside of
developing the Knight to C6 this early
you're actually provoking white into
playing D5 the Knight moves back to ba
this is the definition of a hyper-modern
opening now Levy I have played this
extensively with the black pieces in
recent months so I feel right at home
here what do you make of this as Geary
slams down the bishop on H6 I have a
theory here so if you go back over the
last year 2022 and you watched uh Anish
giri's games with the white side against
the guy named Magnus Carlson on the
other side some of you may have heard of
him a couple of times that Magnus played
this like he played the Pierce or the
modern Anish did not get anything super
promising and I think that's nehal's
inspiration it's a very annoying opening
to play against when you're playing on
the white side and look at this I mean
Anisha is playing a very aggressive
setup here but he can't even count so
long because Queen takes F2 is a free
Pawn yeah this Pawn is under duress the
B2 Pawn is literally hanging you
definitely don't want to play the move
P3 here that's the last thing you want
because the way that Anisha is playing
he's essentially committed to Castle in
Queen side and there he goes He castles
Queen side anyway he sacrifices the F2
Pawn he says yo go take it and Levy I
should point out that Knight G4 may look
like it wins the game here but it does
not know the queen slides into G7
attacking The Rook on h8 yep and if you
move the Rook on f8 this position is
still not entirely clear but I think the
move Knight G5 leads to a devastating
attack against this Rokon f8 which is
now feeling mighty uncomfortable so
nihal he says I don't care about the F2
Pawn I care about development Bishop G4
is on the board interesting because
Queen takes F2 if I just back up yeah
quick moment and kind of show this with
an arrow that that's a free Pawn no
questions asked but it does put
development second and that's probably
not something nehal is interested in so
fascinating to the untrained eye that
just looks absolutely free and there's
no questions asked it is the second best
move but Bishop G4 is the best one and
that's why it's on the board and one of
the benefits of Bishop G4 is that of
course you reserve the right to take on
F3 now this is not a devastating
positional threat but one thing that
Bishop takes F3 does is of course it it
ruins White's kingside Pawn structure
and it often makes it more difficult for
white to push this h-man up the board
black can actually put the Knight on H5
in these lines and orchestrate kind of a
blockade on the king side
as for the queen side there's nothing
going on just yet but hey give black
three moves Knight comes to D7 Rook
comes to C8 when the C file gets opened
you could have Sicilian type ideas like
a sacrifice on C3 so Anish giri can't
fall asleep here he has to keep the ball
rolling on the king side and in the
center and he does with Bishop C4 and
nihal sarin by the way will probably
just keep his King in the center of the
board unless White's Queen is somehow
evicted but that's probably not going to
happen at least for many years on H6
that's exactly right now there are some
very nasty attacking ideas still with
Queen Queen to G7 because blacks kind of
stalwart Bishop here on G7 has been
traded very key idea in the position for
white but I agree I mean this is going
to happen at some point and then when
black captures on F3 you ruin the
structure for white and E5 suddenly is
not so scary so I mean nehal absolutely
has claim to the position and it's
probably just bordering on equality I
mean I think if you showed this position
to any world champion or Grandmaster
before 1990 maybe they would just you
know have the same reaction that I do
when I see like mayonnaise anywhere just
get this away from meow it's my do you
think I do like it when I just pointed
that out well I what do you put on
sandwiches mustard horseradish sauce
Sriracha I just put ton of sriracha on
on our lunch anything that's red all
right now we need to check do you put
mayo on that sandwich you can't have
mayonnaise Mayo Chad knows I'll throw
away a burger if it has mayo on it they
already know that see I've I'm I'm an
open book but if it also has Sriracha on
it no no nothing will compensate for
aioli or mayonnaise or anything of that
nature this is the high level Chester
yeah we have a job well I mean listen if
they want us to commentate they should
make a move right Moonlight is a
restaurant critics which one is it which
one of those two guys you think likes
Mayo more which one of those two guys I
would guess a niche okay I mean Anisha
has a sort of a European palette I think
so yeah yeah okay now do you think nihal
sarin will play Knight pd7 is he gonna
snap off the night on F3 this is the
first substantive think that either
Player is taking here might he be
actually revisiting the topic of Queen
takes F2 that's a move that you have to
consider on every move like you said
pawns Don't Lie by the side of the road
what do you think he I did not saying
for I don't think I said though
paraphrase the great living yes to
paraphrase by the way I'm wondering if
Queen F2 can you just get completely
just obliterated somehow with Bishop F7
sacrifices once I capture and E5 just
Queen G7 I'm I'm very scared I think
nehal is probably choosing between
Knight bd7 and the immediate capture
Bishop takes a bishop takes Knight is a
huge commitment right so it's a massive
commitment right you can't undo that and
that's why you want to be as flexible as
possible I'm predicting Knight bd7 but
something else is catching his eye he
would have already made that move if you
know there was nothing else on the
horizon Forney Hall maybe after Knight
bd7 he's he's asking himself whether
white can circumvent Bishop takes F3 in
any way maybe the Knight G5 move or
something he did take and he did take
maybe he was afraid of something like
this and Bishop takes F7 whatever it is
and he all decides not to allow it he
switches up the move order he takes on
F3 first and there comes the Knight to
D7 now something you did say Levy is
that E5 is now harder to achieve you did
say that right yes yes that I did in
fact say and that means for the first
time this game I think Queen takes F2 is
on the docket should Geary let this Pawn
hang for one more move which is why I'm
not ruling out a move like Rook hf1 yeah
it's a move you kind of don't want to
play you're putting a rook behind two
pawns not just one like at least if you
put a rook behind a ball you can push
the button in this case you need to push
the pawn in front of the pawn and then
push the pawn behind them and then you
wouldn't be able to push the bomb behind
the button again yeah exactly so and
then your queen can't come back on the
diagonal but it might be a really a
necessary evil but Queen retreating also
possible it is and I think nihal has
stabilized the position it's a
complicated middle game we will keep a
very close eye on it love the opening
choice but we have another game to watch
as much as I hate watching weak players
Wesley so against the car Nakamura you
see them on camera there on the right
side of your screen getting ready to
start pensive Expressions on their faces
two draws to kick off the match 29 year
old Wesley so once again displaying
phenomenal form so clean his play is so
darn clean it's very clean uh I feel
like that that fun fact we gotta I gotta
we gotta talk to Wesley a little bit
let's get a little bit more fun of a
fact out of him yes he has the highest
draw percentage but I feel like that's
the conserve energy and then Crush
people right so he's done that he did
that in the match against on Drake
exactly I was going to say that it
doesn't sound flattering but he
weaponizes the draw for he uses it as a
tool when he's scared of his position
yep so it served him well thus far okay
Hikaru getting ready Hikaru will have
the white pieces will we see another
Berlin I predicted one Knight F3 my
comment didn't age well Levy I never
thought I'd say these words in the booth
but Danny was right yes uh we do have a
Berlin and Auntie Berlin and a delayed a
delayed D5 right so uh we had D5 on the
previous move didn't we yeah we had D5
uh well we also like Duda played D5
before castling if I'm if I'm not
mistaken so we're not gonna get a super
sharp line here but these lines are very
very tricky so they're all the rage
everybody's playing this structure
everybody yep so H3 thereby Hikaru
Nakamura you often see the knight from
md2 Levy coming out to E4 that's how you
get that symmetrical structure you have
the nitrate on e4 and you're right
neither side is playing for a big
advantage or they're playing for
minuscularly they'll developing the most
subtleties nobody's playing for
checkmate in the foreseeable future here
yeah it's gonna be a long maneuvering
battle White's Queen is going to decide
whether to go to C2 or E2 whites Rook is
going to decide where to go white will
decide what to do with the expansion
over here you notice in that Duda game
Hikaru got to move all these pawns
forward that's why he won the game
exactly in the end game Wesley's like
yeah you ain't playing this against me
and you know there's a silver lining to
the fact that they keep repeating the
Berlin of course you can take uh the
pessimistic view oh these are boring
positions but think of it this way both
of these players are specialists in this
opening they're blazing new trails right
in terms of developing new Theory and
new ideas these are the players to do it
so it's actually exciting to see two
players who know this opening backwards
and forwards duking it out let's see who
prevails in the end so far they've made
two draws will we finally see something
more decisive in this game H7 and H6
yeah it's a slow move I just wanted to
add here that when you associate boring
chess with the word Berlin it's because
we think about the end game and we think
about all the draws and we think about
all the forcing lines but this is
anything but right like this is there's
tons of theory still going on here and
if anything there's still seven pawns
per side a lot of tension in the center
of the board still plenty to play for
and nobody's trying to kill the game off
and that's because the move for D3 is
played right that's a Nancy Berlin yeah
it's called an ante Berlin so
anti-boring so uh Wesley threatens us
with a boring opening but the meta
strategy with black being to equalize
and Hikaru says you're not going to get
a boring opening yeah this is as
interesting of a middle game really as
any other just because the structure is
symmetrical after Knight E4 Knight takes
E4 doesn't mean that the game is a draw
you know these players think a lot more
deeply than that rookie one is on the
board as is rookiee defending the pawn
on E5 so I keep waiting with baited
breath for white to put the Knight on e4
Hikaru has been delaying this trying to
keep flexibility maybe he's actually
gonna deploy his Queen to B3 Levy aiming
for that F7 that is a common move in
these positions that is a drawback a
well-known drawback of rookie 8 another
thing is that Bishop E6 is a hard move
to make with the queen on B3 because the
B7 Pawn hangs and that Queen is an
artist evacuate back if you look at
these colors
though right now oh my goodness yeah can
we get it can we get a snapshot that's
actually beautiful I'm looking up the
screen now for the first you're not
supposed to compliment your own art
right you're supposed to die first and
then we're supposed to sell it 100 years
later that's how you become a famous
painter right please but your art will
be worthless in the meantime but this is
yeah I mean this is amazing uh well I
don't even want to remove these arrows
from the board yeah let's just keep this
here I think production will yell at us
quick okay get it off the board back we
go to the live position I agree though
Queen B3 and what is black gonna do I
mean rookie seven rookie seven Queen E7
I don't like because it puts the Queen
Under the Rooks x-ray that's not good
Bishop B6 we discussed I think rookie
seven is virtually forced but no he goes
the other way does Hikaru I thought
Queen B3 was a spicy little move there
yeah wow very perplexed what he didn't
go Queen B3 what did he not like did he
not like A4 oh but then Bishop F7 Queen
C4 yeah and you have that square and you
attack the bishop on C5 so yeah I don't
know not entirely sure he takes the
Tamer approach this is obviously not a
mistake what does that he just sort of
keeps what does that mean take more
approaching Tamer yeah
this is also the tamore approach I think
it's likely tame Moore would also play
Queen E2 yeah Queen B3 is like a very
deliberate move and I sometimes I feel
like they trust each other like oh he
wouldn't let me play this move if it was
good he's just gonna defend his position
my queen is offside because black can
defend and then kick the queen out so
yeah the queen has decided to go to E2
now what is the Knight going to I think
it's finally going to E4 I mean finally
you've you've put this problem off
enough but eventually you're gonna have
to get the dark squared Bishop out and
you're not gonna go Knight F1 Knight G3
in this position it's a typical real
Lopez maneuver but with black
controlling the Lion's Share of the
center white needs to play a little bit
more assertively in the center yes in
fact if you go Knight F1 Knight G3
you'll find very quickly you can find
the same road back to the center you
took just way more time to get there it
doesn't make yeah you flew through
Frankfort and Atlanta there was a direct
flight that you missed yeah and you just
people so so people understand the
Knight doesn't fit here in many
positions it's a it's a one move kind
it's a one move kind of concept if the
Knight goes here the bishop Retreats the
Knight is just offside and will
immediately be attacked by the a pawn so
uh the Knight will go to E4 this much we
know and so Wesley I think is deciding
kind of similar things he plays the
movie for continuing his Queen side
expansion and the idea Levy to Echo your
point is not to prevent Knight B3 it's
just a grab space right yes and that's
an amorphous concept that a lot of
players struggle like would a space give
you it's not as simple as that he's
making an investment for the future he's
controlling squares you never know when
that when that will come in handy is
there a chance that he will get
overextended that this Pawn will be weak
absolutely anytime you grab space that
is a risk that you assume but the pawn
is protected by The Rook both sides are
super solid here the position is dead
equal that is not disputable yep when
will we see some form of imbalance or is
the position just going to stay equal
are we going to see a trade of knights
and then a trade of Bishops and a draw I
sure hope not and a move like A4 it's
very difficult to figure out whether
it's an asset or a liability even in 12
minutes of thought you cannot solve the
position here and it was the position of
maestro Boris gelfin who said if you
can't figure it out in a period of time
like you just have to make a decision
and that's why he played A4 we do see
this trade we do see D take so now no
Queen trade and I like why it's position
I have to tell you
yeah I mean maybe if either side has a
micro Advantage I agree I like the
bishop I like the way it's aiming at F7
maybe the other Bishop coming out to E3
but I think largely the position is
balanced we will keep an eye on this
middle game as it unfolds but one middle
game that already has been unfolding is
our other game wow between the All-Star
and you've said it all Levy the pawn on
F2 has been captured by The Fearless
nihal sarin holy smokes what a spicy
position we have talk about Sriracha
yeah this is uh this is not no
mayonnaise involved in this one no no
just gonna back this up for a moment
here we had we left the game around here
you see even the arrows that we were
drawing and then and you captured on C6
which which prevents the attack on the C
file but Allah right so he's basically
saying it's not so scary and then here
this was again something he could play
and he says no I'm going forward yeah
but what's the idea because now we're
right here he pushed the pawn he knew it
was going to get taken what did he think
he had well just instinctively perhaps
he wants to engineer the E5 Pawn break
which to me seems like really the only
way to put these pawns to good use but
you can't really play E5 straight away
if you play E5 straight away then first
of all D takes C5 doesn't look that
scary but there's also the move Knight
to G4 and white is experiencing
logistical problems this is why you
often put the King on B1 in these
situations yep Queen G7 looks mighty
good attacking two pieces at once but
black takes on F4 with Chuck and after
King B1 black could perhaps even get
away with taking another Pawn or just
castling Queen side just because there's
some damage doesn't mean that the king
isn't safe here it's actually quite safe
on C8 with White's pieces sort of
scattered about the board so that's not
really an option and Levy if you take
that Tempo to prepare E5 I'm not
entirely sure what black is going to do
with this Tempo maybe this is the way to
go but perhaps Knight G4 trying to
disattach the queen from the pawn that
still looks pretty scary yeah you still
go Knight G4 to remove the queen from
the defense of the pawn and if the queen
tries to hang on I'm sure there's ways
that you can just get in there with the
Knight attack everything in threaten
Checkmate so that's precisely right
Knight E3 that's a fork you can't go
Rook D2 because if Queen takes one you
betray you save one rook and you lose
another rook and Bishop and everybody
that ain't good Levy no no no it's whoa
it's it's anything but good I I don't
exactly know what was missed
okay he does go rookie one oh this is a
big moment Knight G4 looks might as
scary for white here because if you
don't go Queen G5 that means you go
Queen G7 and that means you give up
another Pawn on F4 with check then
you'll never be able to go E5 yeah then
you can't go E5 but he I guess he's
saying he has an attack well he's
actually saying I've messed this up a
little bit so I'm gonna go all in that's
what he's saying I think I've understood
I've deciphered his idea so after Knight
G4 Queen G7 okay I guess I can make
these moves on the board Knight G4 Queen
G7 Queen takes that four check
King B1 yep Rook F 8 you go Rook F1 but
what about skew or go into the pawn but
you have something to say yeah I was
gonna say what you said long Castle is
an option right first of all on Castle
is an option just to finish this style
yes I'll let you share your life even
even here Queen E5 worst case scenario
big deal you give up F7 you go King d
The Rook is defended white basically has
to accede to the queen Trend and that's
a terrible sign but you were gonna
propose yeah I was just gonna say that
in this position if we go back instead
of even playing the Mover Cafe I thought
I thought we were still thinking about
you know what you said which was long
castles and then yeah you can just Chuck
F7 and well you don't have to be up two
pawns the whole game you can just be up
one Pawn with no real attacking chances
for the other side moreover with the
queen still stranded on G7 it goes from
being a great asset to a terrible
liability with Black's King tucked away
on the queen side I think what nihal is
asking himself here is is this too good
to be true could Anish giri really have
bungled the attack to this extent or by
move 15 I've not only repelled the
attack but basically stand to win yeah
listen being better with black in 15
moves at this level is incredible
especially when you play a pretty
offbeat opening so I remember what I
said about anise struggling against the
Pierce when Magnus plays it this has
worked out absolutely perfectly I think
nehal might even play this again given
an opportunity yeah and people often ask
me not that I'm qualified to answer you
know what does Preparation look like at
this high level for Rapid you often
don't spend hours reviewing your files
it's more about choosing the opening
astutely what does that mean that often
means identifying as you're saying
openings in which even these top guys
struggle there aren't a lot of them but
sometimes you find that little hole
sometimes you find that one opening that
tilts even the strongest of players in
the most well-prepared players and he
certainly fits that category this has
been a tremendous Choice by nehal but
will he gather the guts to play that
move Knight G4 it's not a difficult it's
not a gutsy move right it's natural yeah
and he's done it he's done it he gave it
some thought and went is this really
happening I it is it is and I have
actually one more question after Queen
g593 We concluded that Rook D2 was
impossible but what about Rook E2
chasing away the queen I see
I see because now black is experiencing
the same problem okay it's a moot point
I think there might have been the move
H6 here uh counter-attacking the queen
maybe it was was that missed but I guess
okay quick in any case he went to G7 but
he went to G7
so Queen G5 was never his idea and now
the question is will nihal take on F4
with check he's winning a pawn with
check
to be up two bonds and then he will deal
with the situation of his Rook yeah take
first eat first think later the craziest
thing is the computer is saying you
should go Rook f8 which is just so like
that's not human I mean who plays this
to not take a pawn like that and defend
your king and it's check exactly how do
you not how I guess the point is that
you I mean the pawn and F4 really cannot
be defended by what because there's a
crazy subtlety here lpdo and one of my
favorite chess acronyms loose pieces
drop off after Rook f8 you might say hey
the opportunity train passes that ship
has sailed after Rook F1 but another
ship has arrived at the harbor after
Queen C5 it's a fork I call this a
second order Fork you Fork another Fork
attacking C4 and you're threatening a
fork on E3 and there's no way that white
can defend both at the same time if you
try to move your Rook up to defend the
bishop yeah exactly just sound effects
cue the sound effect after E5 the blood
Queen is strapped at the corner The Rook
can't defend the bishop the [ __ ]
resign here
this is this ain't good if and if you
all plays Rook f8 we see the eval as
something like -3 and that's not one of
those minus threes that oh it's
contingent on you finding a bunch of
moves okay he's taking on F4 he took an
effort what I was going to say is what's
contingent on playing against this
opening that black is playing is that to
prove that 0.7.8 in the beginning or
that plus one that the engine sometimes
likes to show when a person plays the
Pierce or the modern defense white has
to play aggressively you gotta use that
F Pawn right and so the move order that
nihal shows in this particular game
maidenich develop more naturally hoping
for a kingspawn response but Anish even
still is not the type of player to go
ballistic attacking right that's not the
style that he plays literally his style
is balanced and this is why the Pierce
is actually a great weapon when Anish
gets 15 minutes on the clock because he
has to prove it and you see when he
tries to improvise sometimes he thinks
things can go crazy wrong and taking the
Levee approach is nihawk castling Queen
side yeah I totally cosine your point
and you could argue good that Anish has
risen to the challenge he did so
yesterday in the arm again game he has
shown his willingness to play outside
his quote-unquote comfort zone when the
occasion demands it but that doesn't
mean he wants to repeat that and you
know nihal forced him to repeat it Anish
did play aggressively he sacked the F2
Pawn but you know it's darned if you do
darn if you don't he did it at the wrong
moment and this game is not over but if
Anish if the best that he can do is just
capture on F7 and go down this go to
this Pawn down end game he's still going
to be two pawns out actually you take on
HD no that is the pawn you're gonna
capture absolutely yeah yeah this is
this is really bad this is very bad this
is the funny thing is if the rules were
reversed we'd be thinking how can the
hell get out of this yeah of course but
that's a skill set that really only he
and Hikaru possess I mean Wesley also is
a very very good Defender but I feel
like just saving completely horrible
positions it's listen if I had this with
the black pieces against Nakamura on
y'all I would already think that I'm
lost I think a draw is a good result so
just be happy like to go into an end
game up a pawn Drive yeah barely and we
see on each Geary they're deep in
thought he senses we can tell he senses
that he is in crisis mode if he loses
the second game in a row with the black
pieces New Hall is so so solid with the
white pieces and I was just gonna not
good I was just gonna show that you know
you have this check and then after King
to B8 you can think oh I'm gonna come
back and I'm gonna attack the king I'm
gonna come back and I'm gonna attack the
king Levy and then just Knight C5 and
but Queen B4 Checkmate yes Queen before
it made on B7 oh my gosh yes King King
goes here and actually who's attacking
who hello yeah hell mate there's no mate
your Bishop's hanging dude that's one of
the fast and Robert has says that one of
his favorite Parts about sports hope I
can reveal that is when offense turns
into defense we saw a great epitome of
that there White's attacking on the B
file no blacks attacking on the default
give me that file I'm just sending all
of your pieces back home
anishkiri Rook to F1 Queen E5 I think is
going to be nihal's response yeah just
Queen E5 I mean don't let the queen out
and we've been saying this time and time
again yeah I won one of my pawns back
now I just gotta win now you get tripled
you get Triple forked I will say that
again triple four triple how many four
four okay now the good news is the
bishop can escape with check he's still
gonna lose a rook so now it's only a
double yeah now it's only a double and
eval got worse yeah King C7 there and
okay Rook F7 but uh trade the Queens I
think okay I get the idea though after
the trade of Queens you're gonna get a
situation where white does have
that Rook on G7 white also has no not
that but the E6 Square for his Bishop so
if you play sloppily if you play Rook
de8 maybe Anish is trying to hang his
hat on Bishop E6 but again even here the
Knight goes back to E5 and look how
compactly black as position is minor
piece this Knight is going to survive an
apocalypse Rook takes D6 never an option
because the knights defend each other so
even if a niche plays this in a rather
straightforward primitive manner he's
still going to have great winning
chances now we have the luxury of seeing
that there's an even better move he
might try to trade on his own terms with
this very shrewd move Rook dg8 I mean
you're blundering the E7 Pawn it's a
fork Forks Galore and white has to throw
in the check on A6 only move but the
king slides over to D and defensive and
now the Rook is booted you get out of
difference right so the bishop is forced
to go to A6 because it has to avoid the
pin the king defends this The Rook now
has to retreat and hell's like
ah I can enjoy my life here yeah he's
like wow I finally got that pest out of
here and now I'm just gonna go whoop
whoop and you know what happens when a
pun makes it yeah this board game you're
like sitting in 70 degree weather you
got a glass of you know Cold Lemonade
that night on E5 sangria for Sangria
eliminated yeah for sure so Rook dg8 is
the precise move the one complicating
Factor here what do you think I'm gonna
say
even though for Newhall it's like it's
actually a good thing yeah at the time
yeah but it's like it's like Rock Lee
you know in in Naruto I mean time gets
lower he just gets more people like the
belt or the shorts I mean what he has I
uh listen for the Die Hard fans it's
going to be really really bad reference
but I remember the fight against Gara
you know you know I don't want to spoil
anything I'm going to pretend I
understood everything that's like
literally the only Naruto reference that
I know one of my best friends really
likes it he sent me that fight a long
time ago on YouTube I was like oh it's a
tremendous fight anyway
um but speaking of mayonnaise sriracha
and all that good stuff Rook Jade is a
great move and it's not even that hard
to spot because it you just attacked the
queen well worth it listen what makes it
harder to spot is the fact that you
finally can see a queen trade on the
horizon so it's so easy to get impatient
and say let me get the Queens off the
board first and think later but the fact
that Neal is investing time first of all
I'm impressed by that the fact that he's
not panicking but he can sense that if
he just makes two or three more accurate
moves then these 45 seconds he invests
are going to be worth it 100 fold in the
end let's wait for his move I want to
check into the Hikaru game but sure at
this point I'm curious what he's gonna
play it's it's like the more I look at
it the more natural it becomes because
it it the the hardest thing to spot is
your king can then replace the Rook
that's very hard when a piece moves you
fail to visualize an empty Square great
it's important that happens it's
important you do that otherwise I'll
take on E7 in the future so he's got 57
seconds which under any normal
circumstance I'd be nervous I ain't
nervous yeah and we have the beautiful
two board view with hikaru's game on the
right side of your screen you can see
that that game has been a lot more Tamer
with an end game now on the board blacks
Rook situated nicely on A3 First
Impressions Levy Maybe I'm Wrong it
looks pretty much dead balanced but if I
had to choose a side at this point I'd
probably wondered if you like other
things
wait he just wanted the E7 what did he
do maybe he thought he had 93 at the end
Rook takes E7 oh wait does he have 93 on
the end but there's Rook D4
and I guess C5 he missed some check
there's like Knight D5 or Knight B5 yes
uh chat we hear you we're getting word
that you know everybody wants to see
Hikaru Wesley that that game is
deadlocked dead even and daddy dead even
on the clock I really feel like that
match is gonna go to uh like a split
decision and we won't know any any like
any result until it gets there the good
thing in chess is that you don't leave
it up to the judges you leave it up to
the players uh King where what what was
missed here I think he just straight up
should I show the line while Anish is
thinking yes yes so you're absolutely
right you hit the nail on the head
Newhall is hanging his hat on the Move
Knight E3 he might have missed there's
the existence of the move Rook D4
defending the bishop but I think the
likelier explanation that maybe he
thought C5 is good but now there's a
check on B5 another thing that's hard to
visualize that when you push upon
certain squares are weakened in your
mind and the line is long Rook D6 and
exactly right 66 and at this point white
is winning yeah and it's going to be
another rook and Knight end game and
we've seen so many of those it didn't
take a niche long to follow through this
is an incredibly puzzling
uncharacteristic Mistake by Neil who
spent like 90 seconds on this move back
we go to the current position yeah he's
shaking his head and oh my land he's got
20 seconds this is a massive change of
pace huge turnaround oh anisha's
breathing just the biggest sigh of
relief this was a gift this was a big
gift at this point I would argue that
almost white is playing for a win
probably the position is still balanced
that night on E5 you know but yeah I
think he missed that his King could go
to d8 I think that's honestly what he
missed after Bishop A6 check he missed
it the king slides to the center
defending it's very rare that the king
is the anchor of of the position okay
but then he should have traded Queens in
gun rookie there was nothing wrong with
that option he keeps the extra fine
maybe he was worried about something
there you never know you never know when
you're in the moment these small enemies
become huge in your mind you're playing
ishqiri it's totally understandable but
we have an end game to watch and nihal
he's known for his stability for his
ability to stay composed and that's what
he has to do here there's no reason he
should lose this game no there's no
reason he should lose if he defends
accurate now the question if you're in
each Geary is do I just trade the pieces
and make a draw or what happens do I
play for a win because he never thought
that he was going to win this game
literally after the first 10 moves he
went Jesus girl what am I doing like
really what am I doing so he probably is
thinking do I play this for a win like
he could take on D7 right now and he
does that doesn't mean he's not playing
for the win but okay if he wants to make
a draw then he should try to make a move
like A3 or B3 that's what he does
tossing the ball back into knee-hole
score nihal has to smoke this Rook out
of G7 he's got to do it now rookie yep
and now Rook F7 and probably you link
them up you know the drill Rook F7 ah
Rook F7 and Rook F1 is what you wanted
oh Anish is not he's not playing the
position he's and I like this Levy I
like the fact that he's not pressing his
luck he's not being opportunistic he's
saying listen I was losing I'm taking
the draw I'm breathing easy I'm taking
some rest yes and I'm coming back with
an equal score practical decision the
score is knotted up at one and a half
one and a half what a shocking turn of
events that was unbelievable King C7 is
such a shocking blunder it was a one
mover basically it was a one or two
mover there so it's the first draw of
the match right we had back to back
absolute knockdowns by both guys just
both clipping each other on the chin
just dropped to the floor this one was
weird this was like a reset button all
right play a weird opening and but this
is such a great save for giri because
now he knows this opening is coming he's
gonna have something prepared he's gonna
prepare for it you're absolutely right
this might be a big turning point in the
match if indeed anishagiri manages to
win it and back we go to our remaining
game the one everybody wants to see
Hikaru Nakamura against Wesley so are
locked in a complicated multi-piece end
game Levy I pointed out that Rook on A3
things have only gotten more concerning
for hikarnakamura only one side is
playing for a win here those are
dangerous words when you've got a
Nakamura game he can win any position
something tells me that Wesley's not
gonna let this one slip this is a battle
for two results as it currently stands
yeah something definitely went a bit
wrong for Hikaru but that last move I
don't like that move Knight F1 yeah so
Wesley is just allowing the Knight to
come in here and attack the king why did
he play King to E7 when just a simple
Knight to E6 was available maybe he just
didn't like something she didn't like
something right that's he threw Hikaru
bone there yeah he did not not literally
he's still very much focused on Staring
at the screen are we going to get a
repetition here too somehow I mean I
think the likelihood of a draw here is
somewhere between you know 70 and 90 it
just the position looks too symmetrical
again neither side is any Target so even
if the white knight gets to D5
conversely even if the Black Knight gets
the like C4 whichever is the ideal
Square nothing specific happens I don't
see either side giving this game away at
this point no and even King E1 a very
passive move is still completely
reasonable you know you could basically
just think I'm gonna get my knight in
I'm gonna double up on the D file yeah
Wesley's Rooks look very very well
positioned attacking the Target and his
Knight was going to be of a high quality
as well but he just can't get in with
his Knight and he can't add any more
pressure so luckily this game will
simply be a draw yeah and I kind of fell
for the Optics of the position because
optically it looks like black should at
the very least be slightly better but
okay maybe King E7 relinquished whatever
tiny pull he had given that 93 and 95
now come with Tempo but the more I look
at this the more it occurs him that
there is nothing to attack there are no
outposts for the night and Wesley with
Rook Disney it's not necessarily A draw
for I think he he's basically saying
that if the Rooks are traded which they
just uh got traded his remaining Rook is
slightly better positioned than hikaru's
but Levy if necessary Hikaru could
travel to D2 and knock the Rook off of
the second rank he might be doing just
that yeah there comes Rook D1 check
and Wesley will likely move the king to
C6
wow he's again voluntarily walking into
the night attack but he clearly
understands something about Chess that
neither here I do I would not do this
right you would not allow you would put
your king somewhere where the Knight
can't attack it so we might get
repetition now do you go Rook D1 or do
you actually take that moment instead to
go up you could go up to A3 but the
depressing thing is that you're not even
threatening Rook takes C3 to your point
because of this pesky Knight D5 check
and even if you were threatening Rook
take C3 that pawn is academically a
weakness and he has played Rook A3 it's
like the easiest weakness of all time to
defend you can defend it with any of
your three pieces he could play Rook D3
you could play King D1 King C2 I'm
predicting a repetition in like the next
10 moves yes and I'm just gonna be real
here this is not does not mean the end
game is that hype but let's be objective
right and I I wonder if Hikaru will stop
playing the Spanish I wonder if he will
go instead for an Italian oh
oh no was there a point there where you
could have got Knight F5 check and Rook
D7 was an opportunity just missed yeah
wait if we well yeah because they might
repeat moves at any moment we'll revisit
that later I had a brief inkling of a
thought that Knight F5 check with a
square on D6 weekend might have been a
thing okay this is
the king dance the king Dance all right
we can sit back yeah the king dance
ready King up
this is where the eye contact is made
between the players yes they're like
yeah I've seen I've seen players with
the language barriers sometimes just
look up at each other and go like she's
kind of like well
I had this with a Tien Baker the French
Grandmaster in a tournament where
drafters were not allowed we had bishop
and four against bishop and four I
played Bishop B7 to A8 looked up at him
and started laughing and he played
Bishop B2 to A1 and we just choose the
repetition it was a wholesome moment
okay they're not quite repeating just
yet G5 is on the board yeah another
question here okay Wesley just at night
Wesley watch it uh-oh you don't have to
take like this now Knight takes H4 and
maybe the game goes on I have no idea
why Wesley just played G5 and GH it
doesn't like ruin anything the position
is still deadlocked yeah but it splits
black spawns it splits black spawn not
white spawns exactly under a different
set of circumstances I would be a little
bit worried to be doing this against the
car you're playing with fire anytime
you're creating these unnecessary
weaknesses as it stands the White's King
has no infiltration squares neither it
is White's Knight the H5 has safely
defended this is still a dead draw yeah
it's still a dead draw
Hikaru I mean it wasn't a dead dragon's
Duda but he will play he will play and
he is well within his right to do so no
I mean that's what that's Icarus calling
card he exhausts every last opportunity
and even the moves that aren't really in
Opportunities he turns them into
opportunities
and it's important to know when you're
trying to defend this first of all it's
important to know who's trying to defend
it between the players it's not a not an
easy skill by any means it's also
important to know like what do you trade
one thing two things nothing when if if
hikara would have played C4 there and by
the way right this is always a thing it
totally is you should also evaluate all
pawn end games like you should just in
the back of your head
and you should be asking yourself who
benefits in the event of a transition to
the ponding often the answer is neither
and the draw is maintained but with
black structure now kind of permanently
damaged I wouldn't even risk going into
a pawn game I wouldn't even calculate
Knight C4 check because it's unnecessary
to calculate it again Knight C4 check is
a massive decision with absolutely zero
calling essentially now let me ask you
something Levy does white can white
flirt with the idea of playing F3 and
then walking the king slowly around to
H4 does that have any Merit or chances
of success at all yeah it looks very
reasonable see my plan drawing with the
king of course was slightly dubious with
this weakness but yeah white can either
do that or maybe this I like where
Hikaru has the Knight here to keep some
eye on this but is Wesley gonna go for
kind of a breakout so he loses his
weakness is that the idea there yeah and
if White's King Strays too far from the
center maybe after C5 that isolated B4
Pawn can be attacked by Black's Knight
so obviously Hikaru doesn't want to take
any crazy risks you I mean the match is
tied yeah he's playing white but okay
with that said he's played F3
again squeezing out every last
opportunity at the very least I still
think the game might in a drop of Levy
at the very least he's gonna make Wesley
sweat a little bit he's going to make it
work a little bit every ounce of energy
matters in a long match yes and notice
how in a position especially in an end
game if you don't control any pawn
breaks you cannot make any of the pawn
breaks to improve the position or
clarify the situation it's probably a
bad sign white has many Pawn breaks that
he could have prepared literally all of
them and he has this idea so yeah Hikaru
is definitely gonna flirt with the idea
of walking the king over if Hikaru wins
this game we might as well just give him
the trophy now we might as well just by
the way great trophy there's that we
have it it's so sleek and I love
trophies aren't about like size it's
about just the the Elegance of them and
I think this this trophy has like the
perfect balance of of sleekness size and
elegance yeah it's a it's a global
Championship right Global has got to be
the Earth we see it I don't know I don't
know if we're gonna ah oh beautiful look
at that camera work right there right
outside the screen just do some
voiceovers exactly look at that and look
at the their trophies too we got three
trophies on the street now look at that
and we got the players in the background
Wesley and Hikaru hard at work in this
end game the White Knight has
circumnavigated the globe it's gone from
B3 to D3 to the king's side the the
underlying issue is that it cannot
attack the H5 upon the White Knight
physically cannot get to a square where
it attacks the pawn the only such square
is G7 but black will have just a couple
things to say about that yes should the
Knight try to reach G7 maybe your car
will try him in Knight G2 Knight H4
Knight F5 it's the pathway exists
there's an airport on G7 yeah it does
but the airport's gonna be closed yeah
maybe it's more like a helipad yeah and
again here's another don't let James
Canty near it oh yeah yeah exactly
they're gonna get get into another uh
chess content over there in the
helicopter my question was okay these
guys are playing he's made a threat Levy
yes there was Knight G7 there we've
we've crossed the 60 Moves In the
meantime giri and nihal are furiously
preparing eating bananas or other things
and snacking as they prepare for their
game uh four
okay now is this where Hikaru no never
mind I was gonna say it but there's no
infiltration squares in the queen side
or am I hallucinating you can't get to a
for that he's illegal right yeah that's
most certainly trust me he would have
definitely made it to A4 if it was
possible I think it's the time has come
to uh to make the eye contact and you
know start start the process of the
arduous and long process of move
repetition yes it's like uh animals have
mating dances chess players have king
dances to make a draw or Bishop dances
or or queen dances right F4 no no no no
no no no no no no no that's not
happening Knight back to H4 Hikaru
keeping the flame going keeping this
position going the problem again and
again no matter how many Pawn breaks he
carries out he's still not gonna
actually be able to attack anything and
just just showing that there's no need
to do this with black you could you
could still claim that it's a draw but
Wesley doesn't have to do anything nor
should he but there's zero necessity to
play with fire just zero it's hardly
fire it's it's more like a little smoke
yeah a little little Matchstick but hey
Matchstick could turn into a fire pretty
quickly yeah there's uh not you don't
you don't have to go crazy here you
don't have to reinvent the wheel you
just gotta gotta hold there with black
knight back to C4 for the 30th time yes
Knight D6 DC4 has been that move has
been played like more frequently than in
this entire tournament night back to D6
and we might if Hikaru pushes F5 it's a
deadlock now he does and that's it he's
not going to break through on that side
uh time to make it official yeah yeah
I'll probably get the well maybe not
maybe anything is possible by the way
now Wesley whoa whoa whoa Knight D2
Knight B3 Knight A5 I guess the moment
the Night hits B3
black snide should land on E7
so you're not you're telling you're not
worried about this which black might
have to play now I think he absolutely
should play there's nothing to lose
this is this is okay okay he he decides
a knight B3 threatening Knight A5
another threat has been made yes the
king runs back yeah Wesley could have
made it spicy there for a second Russia
but Hikaru is a Mayo guy yeah the king
is out of breath it reaches E7 in time
no oh whoa 96 97 and EA you can go in
both directions on the king can't that
was actually very sloppy by Wesley to
not play King H6 and King G5 I think and
then put the Knight somewhere
appropriate I don't know what would have
been appropriate now 96 and Knight G7 is
actually a serious threat yeah are we
starting the discussion again are we
reopening the factories
Advantage we've had this is what it all
starts with the Knights oh my goodness
and now Hikaru could start heading once
again for the king side with the Black
Knight hamstrung on E8 ain't no way man
ain't no way come on I still think it's
a fortress but King F3 here he goes yeah
sometimes end games are like that you do
everything right it's still a fortune
and Levy at this point it's not really
about the evaluation he's got to sow the
seed of doubt in Wesley's mighty's gonna
make him Panic do something drastic for
the time being Hikaru trying everything
yeah this is another moment does Wesley
take or does he leave the tension he's
been leaving the tension but maybe now
the decision is to take he has 59
seconds to figure it out this is
honestly no matter how the game ends the
fact that Hikaru has put Wesley in this
position is I cannot believe how much
he's able to do in this position I can't
believe it it's it's very very
absurd let's put it my Wesley seems to
have an incredulous expression on his
face like really I'm still defending
this yeah why am I still here
well he's here because his position's
unpleasant okay King back to F3 we've
seen this before
so the reason Hikaru isn't well he does
go King G2 but I think now the Knight
should go to D6 and it does yeah but now
King H3 King H4 oh but 98 Knight G7 just
in time yeah he's making these moves
with shorter and shorter margins I know
40 seconds on the clock now yeah you
only move yeah you have to go 98 97 it's
very unpleasant to do so by the way
because your night is really passive and
after then I get to G7 you're gonna have
to reckon with the move Knight to E6 it
turns out that because of the F5 Pawn
break the pawn in game is fine for black
but Wesley has 30 seconds left okay he
finds it just in time the 87th move to
hold the Integrity of his position and
now all he has to do is Shuffle his King
the Knight on G7 is self-sufficient and
there's no way for white to attack the
pawn on H5 again crazy just because the
geometry yeah he's trying
I don't think there is a way to attack
the planet I think it's finally finally
yes going to be a drop maybe he'll try
G4 but but then black loses his only
weakness basically and you know what
this all started with Wesley going G5
and G takes H4 that's what created this
brouhaha in the first place yeah we're
gonna get to 100 moves we probably will
it's move 91 Hikaru once again jumping
hither and dither and there and here
with his Knight back with he goes with
his King he comes back he's just now
he's not gonna stop trying well listen
Wesley gets down to three seconds
anything is possible we've seen crazier
things happen that's for sure the king
is back on G2 he works the good news is
at this rate we won't even go to a post
game a mid game show he's just gonna
stay right here for game four do you
think nihal and giri are entertained
watching this because they've got
nothing on the line here yeah King E7
all right 95 moves
now Wesley once again has to deal with
the problem of the white king getting to
the other side of the board kikaru once
again saying the pressure is not over no
it is not 29 seconds he has milked
Wesley's clock down but this is about as
low as it'll go Wesley has understood
the defensive mechanism yes and now he's
basically going to just like pre-move oh
my gosh Knight G7 they're almost one
upon if thick pawn and E4 was defended
which would have just been completely
winning for white I mean the margins
have just been thinning and thinning and
thinning there was a point when 10 moves
would have drawn now we're in only move
territory and 20 seconds on the clock
for Wesley yeah what and the problem is
the frustration and the doubt starts
setting in now Wesley's of course one of
the best players in the world maybe not
but Knight G7 Knight D6 yeah it's just
in time this is as thin as the margins
can possibly go before you blunder
the problem is that white only has so
many more problems that you can pose and
you might accidentally repeat moves and
it not moves but position because Knight
g70s plundered it uh-oh he's blundered
it uh-oh he's blundered it but it's
still probably a draw oh my gosh this is
insane
yeah this defies belief and we are
sitting here watching this with the
players two feet away from us no I still
can't believe this he's just gonna go
King C4 King C5 and G4 now is like okay
I think he should have maybe maybe play
Oh No but then there was Knight D6 yeah
but he's should Black's knight move away
at the wrong moment the king infiltrates
D5 your point is well taken this is so
ridiculous 18 seconds who can prepare G5
and he can take as long as he needs to
do so another 100 moves maybe this is
insane it's move 115 but Wesley holding
on for now he hasn't panicked
G5 oh wait a minute wait a minute yeah
but the White Knight is gonna travel
from G oh attacking he's gonna go Knight
C3 maybe it's not maybe it's like yeah
and he shakes his head Hikaru totally
forgot about no 91 Knight D1 and Knight
F2 I thought he should have played oh B5
whoa now Knight D2 but down Knight D2
Knight D2 and Knight F1 check is is an
immediate draw but will Wesley find it
he's got 18 seconds plays Knight E3 yeah
that's a draw Knight takes G4 is
possible
Hikaru is not gonna be happy all that
work to win the pawn and then just like
immediately draw so he wasn't winning
for the record but there was probably a
way to dislodge that King from G5 but it
I think it was still always a draw that
was hikaru's consolation yeah that was
so all that effort Jess is such a brutal
game you work that hard get him down to
20 seconds by the hair on his chinny
chin I mean Jesus that was intense night
back to see where they're still going
yeah they're still going by the way it's
almost like the basketball games have
been over five hours and you're still in
the gym shooting three pointers yeah
they're still like wait if I make this
one what is the last shot right here
it's 5 a.m the lights are off you know
the fans have left I mean the fans have
not left I think we've got about 25 000
of them still watching this end game on
the edge of their seats
gosh that that's good he's still my
Beating Heart yeah both nights hanging
Knight f8
130 moves
that's it nothing to choose between them
can we see some fighting chests for a
change I know seriously
yeah okay yeah there it is I know I mean
just it's just a draw basically there's
no fight to be had anymore okay but like
this game as they draw for the third
time really does kind of show that you
can work that hard you can still make a
draw one and a half one and a half both
players not even leaving the chairs
Wesley's like I can't believe I just
played two games in one
I I can't believe it either you can see
the frustration to see Karo pulls his
headphones off he has incredibly high
standards for himself he was expecting
himself to win that end game yeah
probably from the very beginning but the
positive for Hikaru is that he's got the
the psychological Edge now he has
exhausted Wesley but for Wesley
objectively on paper the match is tied
it's one and a half one and a half three
draws have been made but Levy not for
lack of trying actually very clear on
that point actually I completely
disagree with you I think uh Wesley
might even have the upper hand in terms
of real expensive yeah because well look
I mean yes we do we do see hikar there
looking and Wesley also looking
intensely on the screen but I think if
you just held 120 moves you actually
lost the pawn right but then you uh went
on to draw anyway
all right maybe I'll concede the point I
think both players are confident they're
playing well they're in great form this
has been another amazing amazing round
Levy two draws in both of our matches
both matches are deadlocked at one and a
half a piece
holy smokes yeah I mean this is what you
signed up for right the one on the top
of your screen back to back blows and
games one and two spectacular
demonstrations by both gentlemen uh with
the white pieces uh definitely I cannot
say that same sentence in game three and
each Geary definitely has to bring
something to the table against the
Pierce modern I don't think that's the
last time he's going to be seeing that
opening Wesley so and Nakamura nothing
to choose between them nothing nothing
at all no it's just so so even the form
is so good the play is so clean but you
called it the play has not been clean in
game three of Geary here it is clean
though damn oh my God that looks good
you look great too man oh thank you you
had to say it's okay all right you won't
hurt my feelings okay so they had this
position Anish messing up the opening of
Royal I mean the opening worked like a
charm the hall wins the F2 Pawn he wins
the F4 Pawn he currently stands up upon
all he had to do to win the game let's
be he would have won the game had he
found either Queen takes G7 or Rook DGA
which is the most accurate move can you
guide us through this variation yeah
exactly so we looked at Rook G8 which
attacks the queen and the queen cannot
Escape because of the Knight on G-Force
the Queen's only option is to go here
now there is the alternative in this
position Donya to play Bishop A6
trackfires which by the way is even
worse but let's just show that variation
first queen takes on E5 black will
recapture and there's a fork white is
lost but why does this move saving the
day but that forces the king into a
defensive position kicks out this piece
blacks just upon Him beautiful Knight
look at that pawn majority in the Rooks
perfectly poised to exploit it nihal
would have just closed his eyes and
pushed these pawns this is indefensible
from a human standpoint yeah yeah one
thing I just wanted to show was that
after Rook G8 if you try to give this
check first on A6 right and then and
then you go here and then you take and
you're like aha well actually the Knight
D takes is even better that you didn't
have that option in the first place now
when The Rook where does The Rook go
literally I can't move I have no answer
for you later there's a fork here and if
it goes here then G5 hello right Rook is
getting booted around so it's a it's a
completely insane sort of events that
Ruchi was just winning on the spot he
hopped out down to 50 seconds we thought
ah you know he's doing his thing he's
yeah he's doing his thing but no he did
do his thing but he didn't follow three
played King C70 blunders the pawn on
he's on very own character wonders of
the game makes a draw and he kept his
composure made the drop pulled out to
half point but Anish giri saves the game
matches tied yup big big save right
there for Anish Niha will have to push
this out of his mind he's been playing
well that's what he has to extract what
a round we had two draws but not for
lack of trying and before we take a
quick break and set up for the final
game of day one of the semi-finals a
quick reminder from our sponsor Brave
means private browsing and so much more
by default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and video you visit even
on YouTube no ads means up to three
times faster page loads faster streaming
and faster playback it means 30 five
percent longer battery life while saving
on mobile data and internet bandwidth
for Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com
chess oh my Lanes don't adjust your
screen don't turn your phones off don't
hop on your meeting don't eat food don't
do anything but sit in front of your
computer because there is much more to
come from day one of these cgc
semi-finals as we head toward the fourth
and final game of the day in our
semi-final matches
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right
well I'm back in Belgrade and didn't
work out so well last time so let's hope
the rematch goes better so good luck
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for the game yeah I guess I'm
even in Belgrade but I had a very good
play here today so great City to play
chesson
hey everyone GM Daniel nerditski here we
ask the chess.com Community to show us
their best games from the cgc qualifiers
and we're here to highlight some of the
exciting chess that our awesome
community members cooked up in these
competitive cgc games so here we have
stevis 5 with the black pieces against
akac the Pro 12 and he might be a pro
but he got squashed in this game so
Steve is put together and carried out a
lovely maneuver in this end game the
maneuver starts with Knight D7 pushing
the bishop back now the Knight travels
to B6 what could be the point where is
the night going well it's going to A4
it's attacking the pawn on B2 and this
Pawn is almost impossible to defend
because the B1 square is covered by
Black's Bishop white ends up giving that
pun up and trying to open up the center
Steve is happily accepts this other
sacrifice and after Rook fb1 it looks
like black white is winning the B5 Pawn
but the Knight drops back to A4 and
after Rook takes B5 stevia's captures
yet another Pawn on C3 and this move
comes with a fork Bishop takes C4 and
Knight takes V5 and Steve is very
comfortably converted his material
advantage lovely display of typical end
game plans and a smooth victory for
stevis this has been GM Daniel nerdinski
with another Community highlight from
the chess.com Community Global
Championship qualifiers
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and we're here with the Mr The
Fabulous super GM on this Gary man how
are you good thank you good man good
look at him first we got to do a drip
Shack look at the drip check the drip
okay show them the socks one time show
them the socks bro
look at it you see the lace game with it
okay take note super GM drip from my
Niche gear himself okay all right so I
have a question for you Halloween was
Monday what scares you the most spiders
no not and insects no it's not snowing
cute but uh cute what was the most of
interesting you've done I mean I went
like Mountain skiing a lot of times but
I don't honestly think it's that
adventurous like if you tell me like you
know you I don't know you've become a
suggested winner if you go bungee
jumping okay I'll do it right pregame
rituals I have this playlist called like
um
you know you've got these soundtracks
yeah like of this epic movies yeah bad
boy you've got this uh Inception type
you know the Dark Knight Rises I tried
that didn't really work so how do you
handle high stakes pressure 200k on the
line big fella that's a lot of money
yeah honestly like you don't think about
money so much yeah I think nowadays with
like the bank accounts who are transfers
and all that you don't really get the
feel like I imagine if you had like a
like you would have to pack all these
dollar bills into your bag for every
tournament you know like you want to buy
like I don't know a car and you just
come with these big bags yeah okay put
it down and all right well thanks uh so
much for being with us today all right
and congrats and good luck to you in uh
cgc thank you thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Toronto and our coverage
of the cgc semi-finals our players are
getting themselves settled to head into
the fourth and final games of the day
both matches between Anish giri and
nihal siren and Wesley so and
hikaranakamura are dead lacked
deadlocked at one and a half a piece
these have been fascinating high quality
matches and I cannot wait to jump into
the final game of the day here alongside
the one and only International master
Rosman it's been a pleasure covering the
games with you Levy how are you feeling
before our final game of the day yeah so
there's two story lines here one and a
half to one and a half in Hikaru versus
Wesley we expected that I can't say we
didn't it's deadlocked and nobody's
really even had the upper hand it's
gonna take seven or eight if not nine if
not 10 or 11 or 12 behind the scenes to
figure it out nihal star and Anish giri
traded blows in games one and two then
sort of chilled out a little bit but
almost didn't Anisha almost threw that
game away with white so that's
definitely a match to look forward to as
we see what happens here in game four
man I feel like this entire match has
had me out of breath back and forth they
win and the last game that huge moment
where Newhall star and all he had to do
was make one move and he would have been
knocking on the door of a massive
Victory with the black pieces but Anish
giri let's take a look at his player
card if we don't talk about him enough
Fabby mentioned when we were talking
before the games that a niche one of the
most perennially underrated players ever
there is a good reason that the guy is
like 27 70 feet a forever Levy yeah and
27.96 chesscom Rapid obviously he's
defeated uh the the reigning women's
world champion to get here around
because I want a young talented Indian
player he beat his round of 32 and 16
opponents sixth to one and then he beat
rajaba in a nail biter in the
quarterfinals obviously highest
percentage of brilliant moves in the
field he's definitely going to need some
here with the black pieces but I
actually think he just wants to
stabilize he'd be cool with two too and
go out tomorrow I agree I think he's
gone through the emotional roller
coaster today Anish he delivered
yesterday in the arm again showing
nerves of Steel but what opening are we
going to get what kind of nihal sarin
are we going to see what we're about to
find out he repeats the opening from
game one and again B3 rather than B4
yeah game two rather yeah G6 is a great
line to play against London players and
it forces them into this whatever the
heck this is I kali-ish
opening yeah the sarin opening H3 right
you know normally you play H3 in the
London so the bishop comes here uh now
they're repeating the exact move order
that they went down in in game two so
there's no question in my mind that
Anish look this up the ball is in his
court he was the one who lost right now
I'll be totally honest I'm not entirely
remembering whether they had this exact
position or something very similar yeah
who does any single person that I
remember if the night was on C4 the
bishop was on C4 the structure is the
same Levy and just visually this looks
dead equal I think it is dead equal it
is dead equal and there's lots of play
there's a lot of flexibility and you see
Anish already there that was his longest
spot he thought for more on that move
than
any of the others combined staggering 20
seconds on that move yeah 17 seconds but
all the others were 0.5.4.6.7 I mean
somebody had that up that's definitely
not 17. so he thought for a while and
now after Queenie two white is better
after Queen E2 apparently white is
slightly better and part of the reason
why might be tied in with this bishop A6
idea maybe and it's yeah C7 Knight C7
he's not going to D6 necessarily he
might be going to C7 but just visually
that does look a little bit passive and
we kind of saw in each getting into
trouble in game two for this exact
reason played a little too passively
nihal got his Rooks to C1 and D1 first
and black started experiencing problems
with his Queen
yeah it's it's never easy to tell if
guys are still in their preparation but
sort of gamesmanshiping one another
which is totally they're totally allowed
to do that like oh I'm gonna think for
17 seconds and play this move but I've
actually studied it for six hours prior
so he knows the move or maybe they're
just making things up at the board and
trying to feign confidence both of those
things are okay but one of them can
actually get you into trouble one of
them can get you into trouble and that
would be feigning confidence yes and at
this point and he's definitely not
fading confidence there goes another 30
second think at least and Counting and I
think you hit the nail on the head Levy
Knight D6 is the natural move that's the
move you would play in like a bullet
game okay maybe in a bullet game you
play Bishop takes F3 expecting a bishop
A6 pre-move uh that would be me at least
yes let's not talk about that but after
Knight D6 Bishop A6 let's explore that a
little bit as Anish contemplates this
important moment 96 Bishop Basics why is
white the one contending for a slight
Edge we won't have to play these moves
in the analysis board Knight D6 is on
the board as is Bishop E6 yeah cut the
analysis board we have this on a real
board yeah we have this on the real
board very tough decision there do allow
the White Queen into A6 essentially with
black you can say oh that's really
dangerous I don't want to be under
pressure you can also say that's not
dangerous at all what a bozo why would
he put his Queen on A6 I don't know if
it would go exactly like that in
anisha's head but in mind okay I have a
concrete idea but it starts with Bishop
takes A6 looks incredibly
counterproductive as you're saying Queen
on A6 attacks A7 reminiscent of Geary
screen on H6 in the last game now black
plays C takes D4 and if the Knight
recaptures on D4 I think there's this
move Knight D7 to C5 exploiting a
tactical foible which is that Queen
takes A7 okay what I don't know I just
wanted to use a fancy word how do you
spell that idiosyncrasy
f-o-i-b-l-e foible it's like a I'm gonna
peculiar characteristic of a person can
we get this up on a monitor wouldn't you
learn that word I mean I've got a lot of
foibles including liking fancy words for
no reason
this is absurd man I don't I don't know
any words fast like seven letters okay
please hey Rosman how many how many lose
oh that's six six all right okay fair
enough okay so this drops the queen this
means that white would have had to
recapture with the uh Pawn on D4 and
that's an isolated Queen Pawn that's
pretty well blockaded that can't move
forget it though because nehal he has
taken on A6 but he's followed up with a
different movie he's played B6 to B5
Levy looks like a similar idea he's
playing against the queen what do you
make of this yeah so the the clear idea
here is that uh he's trying to play
Queen B6 right that's that's that's the
idea I'm not telling you this you have
you you of course are aware you are just
straight the queen he wants to trade the
queen he wants to take with the a pawn
bolster up C5 and just use the a file
for his own uh ideas and attacking the
A2 pawn and much like in the other line
Queen takes a seven Rook a traps the
queen because the knight from D7 guards
the C5 Pawn yep now wait a second Queen
B6 if that occurs on the board Black's
Knights are going to be very well
positioned very well we're gonna start
talking about
potentially a slight Plus for black is
Neil Hall the one who suddenly has to
worry about keeping equality
um or am I over overstating the case
here I mean you
you will not be you may not be in fact
when I look further and further down
what what the computer is saying it says
that white needs to start doing this if
white weight's any longer and allows
black to completely untangle then no
you're absolutely right and E4 is a
tough move to play because your entire
position is set up to defend that yeah
how are you just gonna release that
defense and try to use this weakness as
a an asset and it's protecting the
center I don't know yeah E4 is a
difficult move to play it's hard to
sense that the level of urgency has
reached a point where it's time to start
pushing Pawns in the center but you made
a great point there after Queen B6 and
the trade the a file opens much like it
does in the London when you capture a
takes B6 and the C5 Pawn is bolstered
which means you don't have to worry
about it no and nihal is clearly doing
the right thing by thinking one thing is
obvious the start to this game is much
superior to the start uh of the second
game if you're a new scary by this point
in the second maybe was already slightly
worse yeah he was already slightly worse
by the time I showed up from upstairs
the eval bar was like plus five that's
why you were slightly worse you weren't
there to give him emotional support
listen one thing that I would say okay
one thing that I was saying Anish giri
is this far in the event and he has had
dinner multiple times in Toronto and
he's had dinner with several groups of
people but the common denominator in all
those groups the size of 3 5 10 has been
myself I'm not gonna say I'm a good luck
charm but we better go to dinner tonight
you better that's all I'm saying and
he's paying especially especially if he
uh if he does well in this game no that
will support your point it'll come out
of the uh whatever allowance or whatever
you know whatever it might be but uh
Knight E5 so nehal does not choose e45
he instead shoves a horse in the center
of the board what happens if we just do
your idea of taking on D4 yeah well
obviously first of all Queen B6 it's
actually not like impossible for the
reason people might think because Knight
t7 one is the queen right it's
impossible because if Queen takes B6 and
then Pawn takes C5 Forkey in the night
that's pretty Savage forking the horsies
now you're proposing C takes D4
eliminate the pawn oh but I just
realized there's Knight C6 which could
be unpleasant yeah Knight C6 looks nasty
of course you just take it Rook takes C6
of course I mean that totally natural
move what what an idea look at this Rook
takes these ideas
oh my goodness and if Queen takes C6 the
kicker is that here black plays D and
look at the White's pieces all of a
sudden all of them are hanging yes takes
takes invites come over to the studio
for a second take the DC Knight DC
tonight let's make a night that's so sad
oh my God all right fine DC not actually
not a terrible move have you ever seen
three nights on the board by move 20 no
okay Rick takes C1 King takes f8 and
finally the Smoke Clears how many
captures that enroll at the folks at
home count that up but black has two
knights and a pawn for their work this
is out of the question for white this is
losing yeah I feel like we went to an
art museum and we like stumbled into
like their storage unit I don't know
what we're doing yeah we're just there's
picking and choosing yeah we're so far
gone I don't know where we are yeah
let's let's rewind let's let's get back
to the main street this all started with
your ideal let the record reflect C
takes D4 and we were looking at Knight
C6 now if Knight C6 is out of the
question that's what we should extract
from this line yep that means white kind
of has to bail out with something like
Knight takes D7 and Bishop takes D4 and
at this one I think only black uh can
contend for a slight Edge I think this
is very Josh yeah but if anybody's gonna
win it's black but this is like right
upanisha's house this is what he wanted
he wanted a risk-free position solid you
know he's fine with the draw but here
you can keep stepping on the gas pedal
if this happens no I'll listen I I'll
tell you right now what Anish giri is
calculating is CD in Knight C6 Rook C6
like uh certainly he must be calculated
yeah now his Knight takes E5 out of the
question I take C5 and Knight F5 I do
95. I don't like that because the Rook
can come to D1 you also lose two Pawn
you you well the night oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh you were just making
sure that I used why I suggested that's
too many pieces coming off that's crazy
board Vision look at this this is why
you have the GM title right here I don't
really know I have the GM title I think
some people have something to say about
that you're like the kid in class all
right I didn't even study and you get
the highest grade there's no noise I
didn't even study yeah okay let's put
that up on the board you're right if you
can't take any of these pawns what are
you just gonna play Knight F3 Rook fd1
I'll I'll set up the trebuchet right
there okay and then perhaps put the
Knight on e4 you got this and these are
still weak so I guess
yeah and then the computer is trying to
say that this is no longer good I mean
it was good for like 10 moves but now
all of a sudden it's no longer and I
think it's because it's fun if I have
restricts and upon an E3 restrict the
key Central squares and On Demand white
can play this move before I wouldn't
play it yet I would play something like
you know maybe maybe even E4 chasing the
Knight away because Knight H4 loses its
luster due to G3 so this end game
definitely a lot more palatable for
white than the other version of Queen B6
Queen takes B6 that we saw but the fact
remains this is a very big moment and
Anish giri continues to ponder this
critical position he's down to nine
minutes plenty of time to make his call
I feel like when you think this long
right if you spend 25 of your clock time
which is sort of what he spent you you
may not place he takes D4 I actually
feel the opposite I feel like there's a
sunk cost effect where the more the
longer you think the more tempted you
are to make the committal move but then
the argument against that is if he
already proved that he takes D4 it works
then why hasn't he played it what what
is he digging for yeah that's an
interesting type of logic I'd be very
curious to know what is going through
his mind at this very moment but that
will have to wait because our other game
is about to get underway hikarnak more
and Wesley so are also deadlocked at one
and a half a piece all three of their
games have ended in a draw we're gonna
take a quick look at hikaru's card he's
34 years old we don't need to talk about
him anymore
yeah very deep point right there oh it's
a very very deep point he had a very
solid run in the quarterfinals he's been
basically just jumping over every
opponent thus far and I look forward to
seeing what happens in the fourth game I
mean right now there's just nothing to
choose between these two guys it's very
interesting to see if Wesley's gonna go
for a year or D4 there's just so little
air I mean there's so little margin for
error as Canty said you breathed along
and these guys punish you and are we
gonna have yet another Berlin finally a
deviation the bishop doesn't reach B5 he
didn't have the strength yes to push his
Mouse all the way up to B5 instead we
have a main line Italian yes oh joy
amount of move orders are like the
winding streets of a of a small Italian
Village you know it's like very that's
that was so poetic Levy have you been to
Italy I have one I haven't I played in
Italy once and just made that right I
can assure you the winding streets of uh
Little Italian Vision Village do indeed
resemble the Italian that's what it was
named after really no I don't think so
[Laughter]
you take it away man yeah you just
accidentally like named the reason why
the Italian opening okay I think this is
we're backing ourselves into uh a corner
in some deep dark alley of an Italian
Village A4 is on the board now this is a
move talk about all the rage everybody's
pushing the pawn up to A4 there was a
time and a place where nobody was making
that move where the bishop was calmly
sliding down to B3 now the sort of
battle has transitioned to the queen
side and A4 and B4 is kind of dairy Gore
uh for for GM's in the Italian yeah and
I've seen positions like I remember the
game knows your backup the sotoro versus
taking her same name right but the pun
was on A5 and when the opponent was on
A5 you prevent B4 and that's when you
start doing all of this but since white
is already very quick on this side I
feel like black will not play h6g might
play H6 but he's not gonna play G5 yeah
and H6 is played to control the G5 score
so that Bishop G5 is not an option ig5
in some cases but you're absolutely
right Levy you know usually we see this
maneuver 97 Knight G6 assembling pieces
on the king side lap that's often the
next stage of the game and white does
the same Knight D2 Knight F1 Knight G3
uh this position looks extremely similar
to uh yesterday's game five Geary rajaba
and then we played Knight G6 Knight F4
G5 and just got obliterated but yep okay
this is also very common and extremely
and D5 now yeah these guys hate Bishops
I just hate him I think I've seen this
exact position something tells me that
D5 is like the main move for black but
no he takes only three I mean black can
still play D5 yep I can play D5 now
we're on the next move or on the next
move yeah and that's like always the
question do you play D5 do you keep the
center closed let me taking
Chad is not gonna let me go for that he
takes he gets the Knight to G6 is white
slightly better there here is there a
case to be made that white is the one
who holds the pawn breaks white is the
one who can put the Knight on F5 first
or do you think this is dead battles I
never know how to evaluate these
positions I never know I always like it
a bit more for white the problem is I
have to make moves I can't just sit
there and go it looks nice okay C4 right
C4 is a move expanding on the queen side
okay Hikaru kind of does the same yeah
yeah normal stuff yeah it's hard to come
I mean if I have lots of Queen side Bond
moves yeah basically they're they're
preparing the the structure of the
position in the long run that's what
they're doing and yeah I know it's yet
to be seen well I actually I really like
this for white yeah there's just like no
piece to piece contact yet so it's sort
of hard to comment on this from a
tactical perspective there they're
investing in their future finally some
piece to piece contact the pawn moving
over to D5 striking at the center and
white doesn't have to react to this why
can't you keep the tension you don't
have to play CD you don't have to play
Edie you don't even have to play C5 you
can make a general improving move you
often see white play G3 in these types
of positions to restrict the Knight and
if you try to do something like well I
heard somewhere Queen side majority
three on two and I'm gonna yeah you're
just worse I'm gonna exploit that
majority how are you gonna push any of
your pawns yeah you just gave up two
Pawns in the center black will maybe
move one of the night somewhere and
queen D7 bring the Rooks yeah gotta be
careful how you capture these things we
don't have to tell them that but we do
have to tell the chat that we most
certainly do and I similarly don't like
C takes D5 he plays the move C5 so he
locks up the queen side yeah so that's
not the same C5 as I showed because the
tension in the center remains it remains
and if black is the one who resolves it
that gives the Knight it hands the night
a beautiful Pathway to this D6 Square so
it's not that D4 is always bad D4 is
often a good move if black follows up by
attacking the king side but here black
is not ready to do to do that if you
play D4 and Knight F4 hey you've just
blundered the E5 Pawn this Pawn is not
that easy to protect if you play Queen
C7 maybe something like this but now
white can already play G3 to stop Knight
F4 so if I'm Hikaru you know I'm keeping
the tension here I'm making a move like
Queen D7 uh or maybe queen queen E7 but
this is the reason they're playing I'm
not good at handling these positions
full disclosure and black could consider
rerouting to H7 P5 it's it's always the
thing about these positions is you
legitimately have six or seven different
options at times and it's not clear
which one is best locations 98 another
reroute is he heading that way is that
the idea yeah that most certainly is the
idea Knight C7 Knight B5 maybe just
Knight C7 yeah man why are they making
any Bishop moves I don't miss the
Bishops yeah whoever you guys how to
develop their Bishops I know okay so
what if white plays Rook 81 and tries to
exploit the fact that your knight is
left to Center by pushing D4 really
quickly is there any Merit to that idea
I like it Rook D1 D4 let's go so it's
backing up I'm going forward D4 looks
very interesting yeah D4 and my idea is
that if black plays e takes D4 and says
you're gonna lose your E4 upon I can
play e d yeah
after Knight T5 Knight takes D4 little
x-ray going on the queen this that's
unpleasant Knight takes E3 Knight takes
episode
barely not because Knight C2 and that
doesn't quite work because at the end
you're working wait a dozen 96 no Knight
C2 and then your Rook on E1 is hanging
ah yes Knight takes it The Rook is over
extended
but I think you take on E3 with the pawn
and apparently you're better which is
just that's a tough move to play well
because I think Knight takes C6 is
coming I think the reason is very
practical ah yeah you're just winning a
pawn and going back to D4 but all of it
is kind of a moot point Wesley has taken
I almost said Levy Wesley has taken a
Tamer approach he's played G3 it's like
the third time I'm using that word but I
still he he is kind of out of options at
some point he's gonna play Rook D1
probably right or or he'll play on the
king's side you often see people go like
King G2 H where I never quite understand
the point of any of these moves I don't
even think the players always do it's
just what you know but the computer does
that's the most important thing is there
some crazy Rook F6 and King G2 you can
maybe even sacrifice on F3 I'm like
trying to come up with and then go like
Knight if especially if the Knight is on
B5 then that just wins the game yeah
yeah I'm Rook F6 King g295 something
like that well I guess the first thing
you have to decide is whether you're
completing the maneuver of the 19 B5 or
are you going straight down to business
on the king side playing Rogue F6 or
queen F6 that Knight is just loose but
yeah Wesley really didn't like Knight F4
I guess which is why he played G3
yeah it's it's such a it's just hard to
make moves in this position I just
wanted to quickly shout out Levy over 50
000 and 52 000 watching on YouTube and
twitch damn 52 000 talk about a small
Italian Village that's a population of a
large Village yeah so welcome everybody
if every single one of those 52 000
texted a friend or two we could get that
up to uh seventy eighty ninety thousand
because that's not all of them would
agree then you would maybe get it to a
hundred thousand yes yes no just
incredible numbers folks we appreciate
your time and attention we hope you're
enjoying this we also would appreciate
if you texted somebody seriously we
would appreciate it even more yeah
actually because then you know when we
pitch this next year yeah anyway really
text somebody okay back we go to the
game Queen slides over from C2 to B2 and
Hikaru did indeed complete the maneuver
with Knight B5 Levy now the Knight has
gone to B5 so now if something goes up
then I got a B5 yes it has and it's
looking at D4 but our nimswitch once
said
damn that's a nice looking shirt he also
once said that Stephan Curry's the best
best basketball player that's crazy but
yes and then the third thing he said was
correct uh that Mayo is better than
sriracha and the fourth and final thing
in his very prolific chess career was
that the threat is more valuable than
the execution and right he doesn't
actually have to finish this move it
just has to exist this Knight is a beast
that's just gonna stand there forever
yeah and back to the idea of no contact
between the pieces when you have this
kind of closed kg position as you said
it's all about building potential energy
it's all about setting yourself up for
the situation when the center actually
opens so you have to look at the future
right you can't just say oh the night's
not coming to D4 as you're saying you're
gearing yourself up you're investing
your 401k because you're going to turn
60 one day okay and investment advice
aside I think we should take a look at
two gentlemen who have definitely
invested a lot of time in today's chess
and making it more exciting
Indonesia they're on the right side of
your screen uh very tense position and a
niche under a bit of pressure that night
has does it have to make a decision
actually it's under attack but uh ooh
now you were right no he just leaves at
the Hang Rook to C6 I I will just
quickly throw we don't have to go back
but Anish did not take on D4 in that
scenario so there was something about
that crazy line that he didn't like
instead he did go Knight take C5 and
queen B6 he went down the line we were
discussing yeah he's down seven minutes
oh yeah he's for some reason I thought
Neo was the one down seven minutes you
can't blame me for thinking that right
yeah that's right that would have at
least made sense but it actually also
makes sense this way I don't know why
Anisha is so pensive well because he
spent that long calculating C takes C4
and he didn't play it he spent four
minutes I was right
haha and then he spent another four
minutes on his last move the one we just
saw Rook C6 that moved on the board
right there on the right side of your
screen took him four minutes yeah we can
we can jump in a bit closer at some
moment to to take a look and uh oh yeah
that if I just take it back there yeah
95 Donnie and I were discussing when you
spend 33 of your clock time and you
don't play kind of the Tactical idea you
probably don't believe in it you said
you're it's a song cause but I I think
it is the song cost he's down to three
minutes don't cost any didn't play it
it's a sunk cost and he didn't play it
he did take on E5 and go Queen B6 and we
should try to understand why white is
the one holding all the cards here I
think the reason is tied very directly
into two things the fact that White
Knight has this C4 square and so I'm
considering a move like Bishop C3
putting the bishop on a defended Square
chasing the Knight away then getting the
Knight to C4 and mounting an all-out
assault on this B6 Pawn the highlighted
in origin even though that color existed
like just people not even on chess.com
yeah it's I mean discovering new things
every day and you could also bring the
the pawn up to F4 if you need further
further bolstering of the E5 Pawn
Black's Bishop on G7 is like hey this
was supposed to be the crown jewel of my
of your position what am I doing on G7
staring at the E5 one yeah I think Anish
will probably rely on F7 F6 as we
continue to add more lines and then
white will have a tough decision do I
take do I push do I ignore maybe I don't
have to do anything maybe I just play
Knight C4 let him take me in the long
run it's going to come down to these
pawns on this and apologies and this uh
technical difficulty that is a pawn will
likely decide the game for any Hall if
it makes it through it's interesting to
me that nihal is investing a lot of time
because Bishop C3 is is like asking to
be played I think he's already decided
that he wants to defend the bishop the
question is how because Bishop C3 isn't
the only way to do it you can also go
Rook B1 looks like you're just putting
the Rook on file occupied by the bishop
but you're aiming at the B6 spawn so I
think he's deciding on the order of
operations here I think it would be
smart for Neil to keep at the very least
something like a three minute time
Advantage
Geary has gotten nervous when he gets
low on time everybody does except Neil
Hall let's see
he gets more calm when he's got five
seconds on the clock we might see a
situation where he evens out the clock
like he did deliberately he already
knows what movie he wants to make he's
just making it interesting exactly he's
like all right okay I'm still up four
minutes that's not interesting I know I
know that I know they want a Time
scramble Bishop C3 is a very natural
move so is Rook B1 I think it really
just comes down to a choice yeah this is
this is a big moment but it's obvious
that nihal is better in the end game
he's playing without risk and
he didn't deliver on the previous game
let's see if he delivers on this one but
things are getting heated in the Hikaru
so game Let's drop back in and pay that
game a visit as you see it's on the
right side of your screen hikara bobbing
his head he seems really confident he's
got good reason to be confident with at
night sitting pretty on C3 Levy I'm not
sure that tells the entire story though
Wesley has just declined to draw so that
Knight isn't actually the only thing
that matters here is it yeah so I don't
exactly know when that happened but
Wesley made him did Wesley just make a
move sorry so this is the way it works
in chess if kikaru offered the draw just
now he played a movie offered to draw
Wesley making a move would decline the
draw but instead of making a move he
literally hit that press the button
that's like an alpha move yeah he
slipped up and he went no and then he's
thinking because what you do in chess is
you say I'll think about it not actually
but you know sometimes yeah it'll be
polite but you think about it then you
make the move that declines
yeah I won't think about it actually
it's just no now I'm gonna think so he
is so convinced he does not want to draw
he doesn't even need to come up with a
move he thinks he's better and he's
going to try to prove it that that is a
bit of an alpha move there yeah it's
interesting and I'm just gonna come back
for a second to this night on C3 because
a lot of people would look at this and
conclude that black is better on the
basis of this Knight but just probe what
it means to have an identity what
exactly is this Knight doing is is it
annoying for white absolutely it's
controlling the E2 Square you know it's
controlling the D1 score but white can
circumvent that night that night alone
okay so you can put the queen on D2 you
can compromise it's not bothering the
Rooks and most importantly has no
prospects to rejoin the king side D5 is
covered by white spawn and that is
precisely what Wesley so is trying to
exploit by pushing his Pawn to F4 one
thing Levy very important yes after ef4
Rook F4 a lot of people might be
thinking that he's blundered a piece he
might have blundered made into earlier
in the tournament but he's determined to
make that the only blunder he commits
yeah here there's Knight F5 counter
attacking the queen and that's disaster
disaster yeah good word
comes back to f2y doubles on F1 and bump
down the file he goes we're getting very
good at finishing each other's sentences
sandwich is very good in the words of
Danny wrench The Godfather of his
commentator which is that's the first I
heard that one F4 and uh well of course
one very unpleasant position one thing
you just said the night's not doing
anything but watch this after pontics
have four Rook takes F4 I see what
you're thinking it's our old friend the
Knight Returns back like monster reborn
right Pawn takes there's this so what
you would do here is you would move the
Rook back and if the Knight tries to
finish this journey oh that's adorable
but what happens to your defense well
now the Knight has to initiate another
Journey this one the journey The
Chaperone gets in trouble and the Knight
has to run away yep but uh yeah Hikaru
might have been bobbing his head there
and gave a little facial expression when
the move F4 happened I don't think he's
happy though he's not bobbing his head
any longer you can see the sort of
consternation on on his face both
players are just locked in concentration
what are these work consternations
consternation like he's he's that's not
a word it is a word to be consternated
look we got a lot of Graphics we can put
under us it can someone I don't know the
next few days we just need to like a
dictionary consternation yeah I was
inventing my own language here I'm
learning things I'm loving it it's like
GRE practice I now you've made me
question whether it is in fact a word oh
do you see all right well we'll confirm
that for you shortly but F4 is on the
board it's all of a sudden a two minute
time deficit for Hikaru Nakamura if he
doesn't take on F4 then first of all
Wesley can take on E5 and then he'll be
threatening Knight F3 suddenly that pawn
on D4 once the like pride of Black's
position is feeling very uncomfortable
because its chaperone is about to
disappear the thing about these e45
positions there's always attacks raging
on the same side it's like the
Cornucopia of K there you go
I mean listen stay away all right there
you go
always miss my handshakes and my face
they saw it and you were right here I
was looking at my computer screen I Fizz
bumped uh you know like this it's okay
uh anyway the corner Quest sorry see now
you're making me feel bad that's okay
well it's in the past we're on camera I
mean I wish it was a two it was just
Hikaru and Wesley and we were just
talking but now everybody saw that now
this is going to be a clip it's okay
it's good it's okay good good for more
views content um anyway you're the Chad
there you left me out to dry uh well
this is what I will say uh there's a lot
of same side attacking positions in e45
games and it's kind of got a reputation
of being a positional opening right it's
been around for centuries but uh there's
opportunities all over the place to
attack each other yeah no this is this
is squarely unpleasant now a three
minute time deficit Hikaru is in trouble
here let me just flat out say that he's
got to be very precise these next couple
of moves we'll keep an eye on whether he
can solve these challenges but there are
more challenges faced by Anish giri in
his game against any Hall star and we've
got a lot of action in that game we have
that better end game for white that
Anish is trying to hold I think he's
doing a pretty good job of trying to
hold it look at that time the time
Advantage is now down to less than two
minutes this is so tough this is very
very tough and okay what's Happening
Here There is a possibility he will go
down two pawns look at this wait but now
he's only now it's equal material he
yeah but check King H2 and two things
are hanging yeah but after he takes on
E7 it's only one Pawn actually ah
because black was black is up upon in
the initial position I also didn't
notice that right right okay but it's
going to be pawned down and essentially
he has to hold three on four which
is holdable yes but uh he's gonna have
to decide if he does things aggressively
or defensively and niho kind of might be
in his head after that second game where
nehal converted a similar not a similar
type of position but a similar type of
Advantage you know you could argue point
seven point eight you know Newhall is
going to enjoy his life here he's taking
his time what is he thinking about I
think he's deciding between your idea
Knight C6 or the immediate Rook take C5
both of which might essentially train I
forgot which move you proposed he takes
on C5 Mercedes moves ultimately
transpose into each other and we're
gonna get precisely the position you
talked about Rook takes C7 is going to
be on the board yeah then Knight E4 is a
fork but the Rook completing each
other's sentences 94 Rook C2 and white
stabilizes good move by Niche good move
active counter play King G3 Rook takes
F2 oh well sorry sorry sorry I thought
King G1 King G1 King G1 in my mind Rook
F2 yeah oh that's not that's an even
nicer idea Rook takes that too that was
my idea you you went out and hung a fork
uh in case uh not that but whatever
in any case this is good good drawing
chances for uh Geary because it's it's
hard for white to protect that F2 Pawn
we'll keep an eye on nihal's efforts to
convert this end game dropping things in
the comments as we look at our two board
if you love that view we see Hikaru
having captured on F4 and Wesley didn't
take back he played Knight F3 what
yeah we need to investigate that
decision I mean I get it he wants to
take on D4
but I'm surprised yeah Rook F4 there was
uh was quite good well let's put it this
way it's zeros but if and only if Hikaru
finds F takes G3 well that's not the
surprising what does he do after FG
Knight takes D4 yeah that that yeah
there you go your guess is as good as
mine it's like some crazy computer move
probably is it Queen H4 well then I take
on E6 Queen on B2 defense H2 so it can't
be that so what is it okay well let's
test it out FG Knight takes D4 so The
Rook is attacked the Knight is attacked
the stakes are high what you take what
no no get that out of my out of myself
oh King H1 obviously right yes so that
the queen keeps contact with the Knight
and now the only move Knight takes E4
and this is equal you hang the Rook end
the Knight but you can't really take the
Rook because of some checks all you can
only take one of my sacrifices at a time
and after a knight takes C6 what makes
things crazier that after Knight G3 King
takes E2 Knight takes F1 as a check but
King G2 you can't just take the Rook
you're getting mated on G7 you have to
play the ridiculously cold-blooded F
takes E6
then promote and then go Queen G5 with a
Perpetual yeah you're gonna buy it so
you guys later I'm going home he's
played F takes G3
and now you have to put this back on
again hikar missed it how do you miss it
no I mean he missed it because that was
complete bogus I mean stop showing this
to people all right we got children
watching that was insane instead icaro
gives up the exchange he plays the human
move and now Wesley back on top he's got
great winning chances but but Hikaru has
control over this very important Square
on D4 this one is far from over it's far
from over for sure in a very tough
decision almost as a human you want to
play this move and like try to but no
you just gotta take it you have to
recapture you could also play Rook F6
that move also does look why would you
even allow the queen to the Tea Party
Wesley has to avoid overthinking it and
he's got to keep the time Advantage I
think it's a lot more important for
Wesley to keep the time Advantage than
it is for niho because we know how
Hikaru is in his opponent's time
pressure yes yes that's exactly right we
kept talking about this that Hikaru and
nihal sarin are two of the most creative
defensive players in the event right
Wesley's a good Defender but the Hikaru
and nihal somehow are just they they
find these ways so three minutes he's
got four and a half minute deficit and
it's a plus two advantage to the
opponent it's the worst position that
your car was maybe had in the last three
months yeah exactly save his losses
against Judo but yeah oh Jesus are they
speed belt check they're fastened yes
sure they're fastened oh are you kidding
me constant well look at that oh sorry
no but you see the date there October
23rd 2019 yeah see that since then since
then the word actually has been removed
thank you producers All I'm gonna say is
I'm actually not going to say anything
I'm going to let the definition do the
talking it speaks for itself yes but
it's been removed actually it's been
they passed any legislation they said
the word is too bogus nobody actually
knows it well if a word is used by two
percent of the population does is it
actually a real word keep talking and
they might pass legislation Banning Levy
Osmond from being accommodated
if it means I don't got to deal with
consternation and foible all day is
maybe I'm not not the worst thing in the
world as we're talking though Wesley's
time is thinking he has to make a
decision it's taking I want us to go to
the two board view because I I'm just
like these two games are competing for
attention Okay so right side of yourself
or left right right side of your screen
is the knee Hall Saran Geary game and
it's up three on two now and with every
Pawn that disappears from the board
correct me if I'm wrong the drawing
chest is increasing I think Anisha is as
close as he's been in the last like 20
moves to drawing this game he's turning
Knight C5 check and then you know my cat
could draw this and I don't even have a
cat
well I have a dog and I don't think my
dog would be able to draw this position
with either color I think Benji is more
than capable of losing the game it's
very important when you talk about end
games and you think about end games
which you hopefully don't and have
better things to do uh that uh upon
deficit doesn't mean a whole lot because
when you break it all down rook and
Knight versus Rook is a draw and that
means that Anish giri could lose his
pawns and his Knight and nehal will keep
the Knight on the board and that is
still a draw with obviously best play
which uh Anish will likely demonstrate
so Rook end games three on two draw pawn
and games three on two not a draw
exactly but uh he will avoid that
situation yeah and I mean Anisha doesn't
even really have to trade Knights he's
fine keeping the knights on the board
look at nihal's clock he's down to seven
seconds so now it's over 67. there was
rookie seven there was 57 and 95 was
that just missed oh my God yeah I think
he just straight up missed the wind holy
cannot that is just unbelievable
yeah he had a he missed it yeah Rook D7
and I just said that is that winning no
that's got to be winning it's the best
chance you have Rook 65 you blunted a
piece oh my gosh it's a draw I think
it's a draw but he's got two seconds
yeah he's gonna have to hold this oh the
king is King G5 can't get 65. you have
to trade the pawn so E4 and then F4
don't go F4 first then blunder the pawn
yes no King F7 he's also thinking about
uh yeah there's Knight F6 Knight F6 try
to prevent white from playing out four
oh my God Is there is there actual
chances of winning oh there absolutely
are if I can keep the Jeep on alive
Knight H7 check okay this first dude
Newhall is never on the receiving end of
this he's always on on black side in
these kinds of games he was winning
there was some some uh and he's
apparently the move there he's getting
his Knight around to E6 Levy King F6 oh
King FC he's winning yeah he's
completely winning three or something
King I mean some move it's not that easy
though White's gonna go F4 if you move
the Knight F4 blunder's F4
oh my God and and oh Knight D4 F5 and
then G5 E5 check and it's a draw oh no
but the wind was so hard I didn't see
the win I didn't see the win there oh
and Neal pulls it off yes now you just
have to know oh you but Anish is just he
is just kicking himself right there this
is a oh oh he was hoping for a king F1
pre-move yeah wow yeah you got to go up
and down here he's trying every every
trick in the book what was that yeah and
he's gonna stick around he usually gets
up and leave I've never I've never seen
that might be the wildest finish of like
a knee Hall Siren game I've ever seen
Yandy Hall is a bit rough today yeah
making a lot of very uncharacteristic
kind of time pressure mistakes but two
to two is uh I'm seeing the computer
when it was really difficult I I'm not
blaming Gary for a sec he's gonna be
blaming blaming himself I'm not blaming
a niche for a single second for not
finding the win I'm putting it up flat
out by the way you see this both guys
still sitting there yeah they're like
they're guiding incredulous yeah they're
thousands of miles apart you know oh my
God that was insane we'll break that
down for you later but we have another
game to play I'm just gonna make it so
clear as we look at the scoreboard it's
two to two it's tied this match looks
like it should be anything but tied but
Anish really shouldn't be taking it too
hard on himself that was an impossible
win with two seconds on the clock yeah
that's just absolutely incredible
finishing we're 67 yeah that's I don't
know what to say I don't know what to
say about this game we're coming down to
the wire in this game as well will
kikaru hold this will Hikaru hold this
he is down in exchange the stakes are
high the match is tied is one and a half
a piece this is the final game of the
day can Hikaru keep his Knight stationed
on D4 can he keep the pressure on the
file at bayley I think those are the
questions that Hikaru has to make sure
are answered in the affirmative yeah and
what do you trade here if you're Wesley
do you try to get the Queens off do you
try to get a pair of Rooks off like Rook
F6 I mean you don't want to get too
desperate black has a blockade here
that's what it's essentially Hikaru is
saying you're not going to get through
here yeah blockade and maybe even a
fortress although some of us don't
believe in fortresses but yeah how do
you shoo right right through well Rook
F6 is actually not a bad try I think
Rook F6 and then what actually Rook F7
D6 doesn't look all that bad but I think
even in the event of The Rook trade it's
not that the Knight on D4 like
dissipates it's like it's still going to
be there the thing is about this
position it's it okay this is a bit of a
stretch it's losable with white if you
try to take risks to win it oh no
question right that's the Knight on D4
is super tricky you might lose both
bonds suddenly you lose B4 you lose all
your pawns you're in an end game down
Five Pawns I don't know but hey with the
car or anything can happen work out four
by Wesley Knight F3 is a very
interesting idea by the way oh my God
there's an amazing idea because the
queen is suddenly undefended and you're
trying to reroute the Knight to F5 and
win those Five Pawns I'm gonna try to
win yeah D3 before C5 A5 E4 G3 just take
everybody
so Knight F3
wow what a move in three different ways
but when the queen trade happens the
d-pawn suddenly can't be guarded and
with the deep and the 995 guards F7
playing this for a week object rolls
with a rook capturing the pawn in the
night guarding F7 Queen F2 though uh
Levy Wesley doesn't have to trade no he
doesn't but but after Queen F2 I think
Knight G5 is actually very logistically
unpleasant because now the pawn is
hanging the pawn on F7 is protected
position falls apart didn't trade Queens
we didn't play Queen F2 I think he
played queen queen E2 better move better
move but I this is the best Hikaru setup
has looked like ever since he's given up
and he's only down a minute and a half
I mean not only is he probably not going
to lose this he doesn't even come close
to losing these positions right because
the only weakness in his position is F7
is the king yeah everything else is
beautiful mine is the fact that he's
down a rook for night but what's
Happening Here is the relative value of
the Knight is increasing it's like a
three and a half Point night and there
was like a four and a half Point Rook
well put he can Shuffle between D4 and
E5 with his Queen he can Shuffle between
G and a G7 with his King the time
Advantage is now down below one minute
again a situation where if Wesley just
moves back and forth does he harder try
to push this somehow so he might I mean
maybe some H well timed H4 attack
hacking the bottom before how do you
defend it well you can play Queen D2
yeah then I guess he goes back so he can
test him he can also play 96 but but
Levy you pointed out the Knight is
actually very well placed I almost got
to Wesley again
jumbled in my head but 96 is a
possibility here I like the placement of
the Knight on G5 I think you should
Reserve 96 for the situation in which D4
is actually threatened right now he
deals with D4 in another way there's
Queen B2 but Rook 64. right rookie
then Black's gonna start playing for a
win exactly right that's why Hikaru
tanked there for nearly a third of his
clock time yeah Queen B2 would be very
scary were it not four this Rook takes
E4 tactic you know really don't want to
get pinned here but actually if
anybody's King is weaker on the diagonal
or an open space
right Queen E6 always Queen E6 Queen B3
ideas Rook back I mean Rook DC goes 96
and he's gonna go back right back to G5
on the next move I think right back to
G5
is this the repetition we're gonna get
Rook F3 Knight G5 this is Wesley
offering a draw not I don't know Wesley
might consider pushing this I mean even
psychologically you're up in exchange
you feel morally obligated to give it a
shot but I wouldn't hold it against
Wesley if he takes the draw he seems to
be here we go the car is taking a little
time he's like wait a minute can I flirt
with you know can you imagine Hikaru
plays this on for no I literally cannot
I the only reason he would is because he
might be thinking well Wesley declined
to draw earlier I'm going to show you
who the boss is I want to show you what
happens when you do find a dragon
playing on
down and exchange of Rook tonight that's
just for very good reason look at that
Queen Levy what is it doing it's
contesting both sides of the world th3
it's trending into Wesley might be in
trouble here this is such a nasty
feeling Wesley said are you kidding me
do you know who I am he car was like
yeah I played two times you should have
taken the draw when you had a chance to
see Carter Nakamura Wesley down in two
minutes how do you contain Black's Queen
in Black's Knight I don't think you can
you gotta choose oh my gosh Queen H3 is
coming in and barely white holds on
after King G1 I still think Wesley is
holding this queen H3 King G1 H4 already
deserves consideration you shouldn't
forget about Queen C3 but after HR I
think GH and why can sack The Exchange
back if necessary that's always a thing
that white can do give up The Rook for
the night when it comes in and just
basically say I cannot lose this we also
have to keep in mind there are various
Queen c3s lurking you just have to not
blunder the entire position over here
King G1 and Rook takes B4 is an insta
draw oh my gosh that's so gross so
hikara has a draw in his pocket with
every ticking second it becomes more
likely and there it is and there it is
yeah that's Wesley will uh
there's no way to lose right well Queen
B4 Queen G3 King H1 the Knight on G5 is
contained Knight F3 almost mates but
that Rook on F1 yeah yeah wait Knight F3
to check first and then you can but then
the Rook is how do you cover it though
well you're not really threatened I
guess well Queen H3 is a threat or maybe
Rook F2 and Rook H2 taken Queen F3 Queen
takes D1 can we make these Muslim board
really quick yeah okay never mind
they're making them ah okay they're not
they're pre-moving I guess there was a
reason Knight F3 doesn't work a draw is
agreed by repetition what a game what a
game yeah again we have two draws I know
we were calculating some crazy stuff
with Nike because if you take it then
the queen captures and forks the Rooks
yeah we were calculating this oh I get
it you get it Queen H3 oh you don't take
Queen G2 yeah crazy lines but we gotta
look at the scoreboard the score is now
2-2 we have four draws and this
definitely the craziest of the four
games that tells you a lot about the
first three games and how relatively
tame they were Levy what a match what a
first day of Nakamura Wesley just hasn't
disappointed no it hasn't disappointed
at all two to two with four draws seems
like it would be boring it's the same
way in any world championship match that
you have some draws and you think oh the
match has died it's so boring no the
first three games they were trying to
feel each other out as Fabiano Corona
said it very eloquently put I love it uh
I think it was of course a digital game
so that was not actually unless they
were kicking each other under the table
um but this game for was really spicy
and it really showed that in these
imbalance positions neither one is
afraid to fight but sometimes when it's
so early in Imagine when I take too many
risks on the other hand though giri
sarin huh what about that match I'm
totally speechless at that match I'm
speechless at the way that that game has
finished I mean first it was Anish Gear
with a great defensive effort in the
third game then also in the fourth game
nihal had Rook takes E7 should get a one
move win he had one easy tactic he would
spot this in an ultra Bullock game but
it's the nerves of the cgc that's what
actually makes it magical he misses it
then it's Geary who has a win but a very
narrow path indeed he didn't have time
to find it I think Anisha is the last
person who should blame himself nihal is
the one who's going to be very
disappointed at the score after day one
that's exactly how it works yeah you
have to look at who's going to be
happier with the score line and the
Hikaru Wesley match they're both gonna
go well nobody's really happy we got to
play four more games between a niche and
nehal you look at who had more chances
it's definitely nihal it most certainly
is and this sets us up for an epic date
to we will be back in a bit for the
brave move of the day but for now let's
swing it back to Danny and the gang in
the gameplay hall for their Reflections
Danny hello
thank you Dania we are back here on the
sofa guys it's good to be back on the
sofa right good to be back on the show
we'll talk about that in a minute uh but
wow we are in the semi-finals these are
the four players left standing in this
epic event that we've had for the last
several months for a reason guys look at
the deadlock score that each of these
matchups are in two games a piece
are what each of the players have
obviously there's a lot of details a lot
of bumps in the road to unpack and
navigate about how they got there but we
are deadlocked here headed into day two
of the cgc semifinals so let's let's
just start right here
uh and and talk about uh talk about what
we've had I want to start with the with
the Geary Sauron match and and Fabiano
want to start with you but I mean are
you are you comfortable it's good to be
back can I get you anything it's a bit
farther than we were last year
and we've got we've got a guy here
joining us you know but we're back on
the couch for me you continue to leave
me out of the car you're looking that
way wow all right all right
you you called the first two games you
had the uh the joy of being a spectator
with all of us out there for the last
two your thoughts on who has the upper
hand psychologically right now in the
Geary sarin match I think on each has a
slight upper hand psychologically I mean
the score is equal and maybe they can
just forget about everything that
happens today and just focus on the
chest tomorrow but yeah nihal had more
chances and the last game was of course
crazy they both had winning chances
which was impossible to predict simple
in that end game but nihal had the big
chance he was just winning one move one
move tactic yeah and Most states he
would see that it just you know low on
time anything can happen on each been
winning at the very very end for just a
moment in time pressure not as much like
I think he'll forget about that more
easily okay so Geary has the upper hand
psychologically because nihow's missed
more chances but if you're the youngster
nihal are you happy that you're tied you
got that first day of the semi-finals
behind you you're headed into day two
deadlocked you all play the better chest
today yeah game one was all in each giri
that was a master class in preparation
and execution but since then in those
three games it was what two to one in
Neil's favorite it could have been two
and a half to half maybe even three
nothing in the Ozark he outplayed the
Dutch number one from start to finish
from games two to four he just actually
couldn't conclude them with victories so
now we're now we're talking soaring
right I know he's your guy right and I
know you're right you're giving him pep
talks because I'm sure he's watching and
stuff so what are your thoughts on on
nihao's play right now and uh the fact
that he's played the better chess
according to Robert in fact yeah I agree
with Robert he played a better Chester I
think if I'm sorry and I'm in this
corner hey bro we just need to brush up
on some tactics just do some more just
do some some clean tactics because we
missed some obviously there and of
course uh the nurse showed because like
playing in each Geary there he didn't
really blunder as much in the other
matches and like you saw blunders that
he missed right that I mean he was in
time trouble obviously but missing that
tactic is like unreal for nehal dude
that does this all the time in the chest
right so it's very shocking to see that
I'm in that but I think for him he just
needs to bounce back with these tactics
tomorrow come back sharp he'd be good
all right well we'll see how nihow comes
back tomorrow but the other guy who's
got to be back in that match tomorrow
Anish Geary caught up with Nemo just a
few moments ago let's see what they got
into
thank you Danny I am here with Anish our
hearts were beating so fast for your
last game how stressful are time
scrambles
um yeah I mean
um
it was quite intense because it's
different though like when you're
playing for a winner when you're playing
for trying to save the Lost position or
Havelock position that's this different
kind of pressure
um
I I think like At first of course it was
a very very important position I think
it was close to lost and then I got this
very up less than three against two
thing four against three at first and uh
it's very annoying because with knights
and Rooks on the board it's hard because
then even the 19 games can be tricky I
think uh the rook and game is a draw but
it's hard for me to trade the knights
and then he fell for a very nice cheaper
and then fortunately I had just a little
a little bit too little time like I
think the first few moves I played the
world because I kind of pushed this King
back and then I I think from what I saw
afterwards like the engine goes with the
computer 2H we started with them with
the King to H6 somehow and maybe that
was the way to go but if I had just
seconds on the clock and okay I was very
happy to get the put I got and I was
hoping that I understood that I could be
winning there so of course I was trying
to win and hoping I would win but um
yeah I didn't have the time and really
the mindset to to switch to looking for
and I thought what I did that's winning
but then after he pushes the pawns I
just see that I'm unable to like At
first I wanted to provoke the pawn push
but then I realized that I'm unable to
somehow avoid the pawn trade
uh the Commissioners are very excited
since yeah
yeah absolutely intense your last game
was extremely intense what are your
thoughts about your other games today
well actually the match was quite
interesting because the first two games
were of a very high quality uh from by
the white players so first game I played
very well I think and he got in a bad
position after the opening and the
second game I got into trouble with the
black pieces and he converted it very
very well as well so it seemed like it
it might become you know a match of some
some good chess finally but obviously
not and uh the I mean what was happening
in game three I have no idea what he was
thinking I mean he's like he's
completely winning and he's thinking and
okay if you want to you can play it in a
very dumb way and you're winning you can
try to be sophisticated and you're
winning but uh yeah he tried to be super
deep but it didn't work and the last
game also like it went completely out of
control and that's good to see because
after game two I was slightly concerned
that okay maybe maybe you know
that that game he was completely under
control and I thought okay he's maybe
um you know Flawless when he gets a
better position but it seems that
luckily he's just like all of us humans
and uh yeah just things just get
completely out of hand yeah the games
were absolutely crazy as such watching
out here where it's it was so intense
what are your thoughts going into
tomorrow
I'm happy with the score I think like
the first game was good but the rest was
very shaky so I think it's a good score
and um
it's good to enter second day with tutu
because then basically the data decides
everything you are on equal terms with
your opponent and I think that's fine
basically it's like you play one match
not to
thank you very much Anish
all right well interesting thoughts and
an interesting end to that game four
Robert we'll go around the horn the
other way your thoughts on not just that
crazy time scramble but how Anish was
reacting to uh to the thought that he
almost missed a win but can't really
hold it against himself I don't think
I've ever seen anisha's hair not being
perfectly blushed that's right
that was sticking out that's how intense
that match was yeah and I think he made
some good points though he's happy yeah
the day ended two to two Bobby and I
talked to the start of the show that
those two had not played each other very
much so he's just getting a feel of his
opponent and he felt that nihal when he
gets a better position he plays
perfectly he just learned that's not
always the case even in time travel
nihal's reputation precedes him he is a
bullet Maestro the number one rated
player on chess.com when you look at it
seems like he's always up there but
today he wasn't perfect and that should
give Anish some confidence but he must
play better tomorrow
you were with Anish when he was looking
looking trippy looking great right he
was disheveled there good followed by
Robert what are you going to tell him
you know you gotta look good to play
good oh absolutely in fact and you know
what's funny you just said that he
actually said that in a quote a long
time ago did he really yes okay you must
I mean that's right maybe maybe looking
fresh all the time you know we know that
yeah we call him right fresh probably
but um Gary I think about what he said
he was very calm I thought he was very
calm about it and very objective and
very cool about it as opposed to like I
don't know or like maybe I should do
this maybe I should he didn't seem
jittery at all he seemed like a real
professional and like okay I'm gonna
take this information I'm gonna adapt to
it and then come back in here stronger
tomorrow and leave it at one match I
like that Bobby I was just just about to
ask on that he said the comments that
you treat it like it's one match you've
been in some of the biggest chess games
of anybody in your generation in peer
group you know you had 12 straight draws
with Magnus Carlson did you approach
every next game no matter how Wild the
fight was to get you a drawing like all
right well it's still just a new match
we're still fresh or is there a bit of a
hangover right you're thinking about
those last games in the moments that Got
Away take us into anisha's shoes and how
what do you think is really going on
there yeah the pressure of course in the
world championship matches is very
different uh there you feel every single
move like it's you know the move of your
life here I I don't think that they were
feeling the pressure so much today but
as I said it's like a new match tomorrow
I mean they're tied two too so the
stakes will feel much higher for them
tomorrow yeah the the weight of one bad
move or one bad game will be like this
might be the end of the match for me so
today we we saw some nerves but tomorrow
it's going to be a lot more nerves
especially once we get to those critical
last games and potentially an Armageddon
yeah and I think that Anish mentioned
this and I think it's good for him that
he does doesn't feel the weight of that
missed chance at the end of the game so
much because it was very brief moment
yeah when you're winning the whole game
and then you miss it you feel like how
could I how could I do feel terrible but
if it's just like a fleeting moment just
one thing then you're like you know it
doesn't stay in your head as as much
yeah okay well makes sense a lot more to
continue to make sense of we will do our
own check-in with the other match that
is of course the Hikaru versus Wesley
match in a bit but let's kick it back
over to dania and Levy for the brave
move of the day
thank you Danny those are some fantastic
insights it is indeed time for the brave
move of the day in which we highlight a
key move or set of moves that decided
the outcome of one of our matches today
and we're going to dig into a Wesley so
hikaranakamura epic battle in their
final game today they had this position
Hikaru with the black pieces down in
exchange his Knight on D4 pinned to the
queen he is in crisis mode and Levy this
is where he uncorks a vintage
hikaranakamura moment yeah exactly right
and I think one thing to remember here
is we had decisive games throughout
right so you would think oh it was one
of those but no this one could have very
well been decisive and turned the match
completely on its head but then Hikaru
busted out Knight to F3 walking through
danger in three different ways as the
Queens hit each other with the Knight
defending the queen acrobatically and if
the queens were to be traded here then
the pawn on D3 would fall leading to the
complete collapse of White's position
and maybe Hikaru is even playing for a
win indeed and upon an F7 is well
protected even definitely be playing for
a win here Wesley had to refrain from
the queen trade moving his Queen to E2
and now the Knight drops back to G5 and
the point of this is that the Knight on
D4 was actually a liability it kept
getting pinned by the queen now Black's
control over D4 is increased as is his
defense over F7 everything is watertight
and Hikaru went on to draw very
confidently in fact by the end he was
the one declining a repetition despite
being down in exchange he dropped his
Queen back to E6 using that Knight on G5
to infiltrate H3 and it was up to Wesley
to defend carefully he managed to do
that and the game ends in a beautiful
Perpetual with another Rook sacrifice
Levy this was awesome yeah this was
absolutely awesome and just friendly
reminder Dania and I were even
calculating some way that black could be
down two Rooks but threatening a couple
of very nasty checkmates and there's
only one line here that saves white it's
to give a check the King goes back you
cover up mate and here it looks like
it's game over because once you take
then you have Queen to F3 winning both
Rooks back that's how acrobatic Knights
are in chess but Queen G2 is a cold
shower he Hikaru saw this kind of
concept and shows instead to repeat
moves from what I would call a position
of strength a very exciting day but
Knight to F3 the key idea and that's our
brave move of the day Knight to F3 was
amazing hikaru's defensive resilience is
amazing and that folks was a brave move
of the day remember it's time to make
your move from chrome to Brave try it
now at brave.com chess and now let's
send it back to our hosts in the playing
haul Danny take it away
thank you again another great breakdown
by Dania and Levy and we're going to
talk about that match we're going to
talk about those big moments in a minute
but right now Nemo is actually standing
by live with Hikaru Nemo over to you
thank you very much Danny
um Hikaru you had four drawn games today
and while they were drawn they were
extremely sharp how did you feel after
sacking The Exchange in round four
um well I was just trying to find
something where I could make a lot of
quick moves I was already down about
five minutes on the clock and sometimes
you have to be practical
um and at least I had a clear idea to
blockade the pawns and and hope for the
best I think it probably was losing for
me at some moment but uh Wesley wasn't
able to convert and um yeah I was it was
a good Escape I guess in the final game
of course the whole match was insane
because I mean probably I should have
lost the first game I probably should
have won the third game
um second and fourth game is also very
very up and down both ways so
um it seems Seems like a normal result
yeah and we noticed that in round three
you were definitely pushing for the win
do you think you missed a win in round
three yeah I mean it was completely
winning but at the same time I mean
Wesley Wesley made a couple of crazy
mistakes that he didn't have to make in
the first place to get into that
situation so it's a bit of a Pity I
didn't win that game but again I very
easily could have lost the first game or
the fourth game so I think the results
even out okay
how do you feel
Morrow
usual 2-2 not surprising we draw a lot
of games it's life
thank you very much higaru and I'll
throw it back to you Danny
good stuff it's two to two right
sometimes you draw games and that's life
that's uh that's hey Carter's take on
where he is deadlocked against Wesley so
of course as we already broke down nihil
sarn and Anish Gary also deadlocked even
more of a topsy turbo Turvy match up
there though but all right let's talk a
little bit about the interview there the
discussion they got into Fabi I want to
go back to the first question Nemo asked
and hikaru's answer about finding Knight
F3 but then the answer he gave where he
said I was down a few minutes and I just
needed a position where I could make a
bunch of quick moves and mix it up how
good is Hikaru at sensing the moment
that he has to do that right you've
played against him for years is that
what you would argue maybe his best
skill in these online and Rapid quick
time control formats yeah I think one of
his biggest strengths is that he's very
cognizant about not only the objective
side of Chess but also the psychological
side and the Practical side making sure
that he doesn't get along time and one
of the biggest things that's brought him
so many wins or not even wins but just
like saved lost positions or won loss
positions is that once his opponents get
low on time they tend to make mistake
takes he does that less but he he always
keeps in mind the time Factor yeah and
so when he said that he wants to make
natural moves he understands that it's
not just about the objectiveness of the
position it's also about how easy it is
to play the position right sometimes
you're winning but it's very very
difficult sometimes it's very easy to
make moves and it doesn't even matter
about the objective value of your
position right just because your
opponent always has to make those
difficult decisions and when he had the
blockade with the the Knight on E6 The
Rook on D4 everything like the queen on
E5 it's very easy for him to make moves
Wesley is the one who has to keep all
his weaknesses together he's not
material but he still has to find the
difficult moves so let me ask you before
we get to canteen Robert who do you
think in that match has the
psychological Edge going into tomorrow I
don't think either of them okay as
Hikaru said it it was up and down they
both had some chances but it was also
very level for much of it okay there was
a bit more nerves in the third and
fourth games I noticed it seemed to to
be like the pressure of the match was
yeah a little bit a little bit more yes
we said that this match might ramp up a
bit more and more until we get to the
end of it and we're starting to see that
I think we'll see that even more
tomorrow but so far very level not just
from the result but also from the
psychological side of it missed chances
for both of them Hikaru alludes it to
that and he also didn't seem to think
that there was much
for either one of them it seemed like it
was very very level and equal so far
Hikaru does these uh makes these great
practical decisions calculates over
everything over all the time that's
right but he's also when he finds letter
three it's so entertaining right a guy
that's covered him a lot like me title
Tuesday what do you do when you're
watching Hikaru play like this hello
will you played at first off it's
inspiring 100 it's just to see that kind
of level I mean Hikaru has always
inspired me I've always tell I'm looking
one of my favorite players I learned a
lot I even do the Facebook expresses
when I'm calculating what I'm gonna eat
today what I'm gonna eat I don't know
right I'm talking to my sons uh I don't
know maybe you should do that but it's a
way of life to calculate right
calculation of everything once again but
your car was doing a great job with that
I think they are evenly matched right
now but tomorrow's gonna be a definitely
a test of strength I think he's going to
bring out some aggression tomorrow all
right we'll see it well speaking of
tomorrow Robert let's start talking
about Bobby says he thinks it's
deadlocked even against these two guys
but based on what you saw today if you
had to do the thing where you're like
given a slight Edge or a nudge to
someone who do you think has the edge
going into tomorrow between the two I
feel like the matchup is awkward for
them because they play similar openings
they game one in game two had the same
exact start yeah and that's it's
uncomfortable because like I like this
and I feel like it's good but you do too
so how are we going to deviate right and
then games three and four were more
shaky they were making mistakes that
some of which I think were solved in a
creative manner as a cars especially in
game four there uh but I feel like
Wesley's time management has been an
underrated storyline he is keeping a
healthy extra few minutes against
Hikaru and a car himself said in that
last game the reason he was able to
escape is he made this decision at some
point to give up material for easier
practical choices now there could be a
time place where Wesley punished that
this position was actually quite locked
up wasn't easy for Wesley to find a win
he didn't miss anything I wouldn't say
it like that I think his car was just a
creative Defender resourceful but I'm
worried about that clock separation I
think Wesley he should be happy about
how the games have gone for the most
part on day one but I do believe that
fourth and final game shows that he is
missing some of his chances like he did
in the first game of the match as well
yeah yeah I think that tomorrow we're
going to see a very very sharp fight
between them and I think we'll see
different openings too that's okay they
know that the Berlin Wall is you can't
you can't break it down plus no one
wants kanty to go to sleep you know yeah
they're also gonna for the fans I mean
we know Hikaru likes to play for the
audience too yeah and they want to
entertain the fans I think they'll play
some different openings although of
course they're mostly thinking about the
result of the match everything else is
secondary and yeah I think we'll see
something besides E4 because we saw all
E4 today which is unusual for them like
hikar I know has a big nimzo player yeah
he's a guy who loves to play nimso and
so I'm a bit surprised to see that both
of them who are D4 players E4 players
even C4 Knight F3 they're playing first
move that they they went for E4 where
they have the most solid repertoire and
it's most difficult to break down their
opponent absolutely of course yeah like
you said uh The Versatile versatility I
see on the Knight F3 B3 in fact the
chess.com stats say 60 win rate against
everybody he plays with the Knight F3 E3
B3 system he got replaced so yeah I mean
that's probably many other openings too
as well there's no Hikaru but of course
we do need to see some switching up I
want to see some switching up so we
don't fall asleep on the Berlin's
anymore Joko piano is just a little bit
I mean like you like sleep one eye open
you know what I mean so still sleep but
like one eye open because it might be
something and again four draws right so
hopefully we see some spice tomorrow
last one I just want to say uh was a
great point I think about Wesley keeping
an edge on the clock you'll be talking
about the X's and O's they're going to
maintain tomorrow I'm going to make a
mental note of that we'll see if Wesley
maintains that edge on the clock because
I think it may end up being critical but
all right we got to switch over now to
talk about the other match Sauron Geary
you said maybe Gary has the
psychological Edge because nihals played
better but what do you expect to happen
tomorrow when push comes to shove and
I'm gonna ask you this who do you think
would have the edge in Armageddon
against those two
Armageddon I would probably give a
slight Edge to nehal and the only reason
why is because no increment I feel like
he's he's going to be more accustomed to
that to when it gets down the last few
seconds and I remember this uh
ridiculous Armageddon game he played he
was down to like 20 seconds and the
position was unclear and he made it he
made it his opponent with black he just
needed to run he was down to 20 seconds
you think this guy's getting flagged and
he mates him in 20 seconds with like
three seconds left on the clock it was
like a James Bond movie Last seconds of
the bomber is going off and somehow he
finds a way wow but it would still be
only slight Edge because on each has
he has a he has a class yeah he has
experience I mean he he's such a classy
player he's so strong and his openings
are better than nehals objectively yeah
and that that might prove important it
we saw today like the openings D Hall is
trying to jump around trying to surprise
him he played these this weird opening
in the third game yeah and which
actually worked out remarkably well I
mean he was like borderline winning in
that game yeah and he was frustrated in
that case yeah but still um some you
jump around sometimes it works but
sometimes it doesn't it could also turn
into an opening disaster so we might we
might see that in the first game we
definitely saw the preparation play a
role all right you think uh it's in the
water uh if he gets to arm again you
also like Nihao State yeah yeah actually
it is in the water especially him being
faster too in that last game that grid
of like this is it this the last game
now of course gear is very solid like
Geary don't get weary right but at the
same time and that Armageddon one game
slight hits disarm literally it's like
well Robert over to you to to help round
us out here you think any of the X's and
O's we're talking about openings maybe
favoring Geary in the fastest moments
favoring CERN who would you give the
Edge to Tomorrow I feel like nihal son's
got to do his best Vince Vaughn
impersonated he's playing dodgeball
because he's avoiding that preparation
that you can dodge a wrench you can
dodge a ball I can't even Dodge wrench
ever I'm sitting next to you but I feel
like in all seriousness that's what
nihal is doing he played a kind of shaky
opening so that you would not see at the
highest level you couldn't pay 500
Carolina enough money to play that
opening it's just not the best sort of
thing and Magnus Carlson does it and
gets away with it but I think he already
saw in game one this is what happens
when you go down the line and each gear
is prepared in you might just get blown
off the board that's what he's choosing
to do is with the white pieces playing
solidly and played an amazing game too
Bobby and I looked at that that was
really Exquisite technique from the
youngster but with the black pieces
that's what I'm worried about so he
asked about Armageddon if I'm Anish giri
and we get that far you might just take
the white piece and say hey do your best
you'll have a few fewer minutes than I
will like try this random opening I'm
gonna punish you just been 15 minutes to
elaborate on that point I I noticed
something and I just thought about it
again uh the first two games were
Exquisite like Perfection from both of
them first on each player perfect game
then Neo play a perfect game games three
and four were shaky the quality dropped
dramatically the players yeah for both
of them so it's interesting how the
quality was so high for the first two
games and then the the last two it was
very especially the last one very up and
down I mean Nihao almost losing an end
game where he's just a pawn up yeah
that's a bit strange it shows the nerves
are coming into play yeah interesting to
see nerves play more of a factor as the
match goes on between those two but all
right the quality of play has been
incredibly high at the women's
candidates let's remind everybody that
that event has kicked off and we have
already reached the semi-finals for pool
a lay Ting ji versus anamuzi Chuck is
the match of recovering who will make it
through to the finals and one step
closer to the coveted seat across from
reigning world champion Juan Jun at the
2023 Women's World Championship don't
miss a thing game four is Saturday
November 5th that is tomorrow here at
twitch.tv chess type the command women's
candidates in chat for all the details
so all right guys well that's going to
be a wrap for us this has been an
awesome day for my team here Robert Hess
Danny wrench James Canty Fabiano caruana
of course Levy Dania Amon Nemo the whole
crew everyone crushing it doing a great
job thanks for being with us make sure
you uh join us tomorrow on Twitch and
YouTube of course as we begin day two of
the semi-finals the chess starts at noon
Eastern Time 9 A.M Pacific for now once
again I'm Danny this has been amazing
and this is good night from Toronto
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign